hello everyone welcome to this
interesting video on blockchain and
cryptocurrency full course for 2022.
blockchain is a groundbreaking
technology that enables anyone to track
transactions on a distributed digital
ledger without a central authority
the most notable byproduct of the
blockchain revolution is without doubt
cryptocurrency
which some refer to as the trust machine
technology
in this video we will explore various
important aspects revolving around
blockchain and cryptocurrency and the
related concepts in depth
but before diving deep into their
concepts we will first explore the
basics starting with what is
cryptocurrency and what is blockchain
and then moving on to understanding the
origin and functionality of various
popular cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin ethereum dogecoin solana sheba
in a coin nft
binance and ripple
followed by top crypto trading platforms
of 2022
then we will make you understand how one
can become a blockchain developer
and what are its eligibility criteria
then we will take you through in-depth
concepts of blockchain like smart
contracts mining hyperledger and crypto
wallets
also we will show some real-life
applications of blockchain and at the
end we will introduce you to some of
interview questions related to
blockchain and cryptocurrency to make
your base more stronger and boost
confidence in you
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your blockchain and
cryptocurrency related concepts would
have been cleared
so for this training with me i have our
experience specialist rahul together
we'll walk you through the different
crucial blockchain and cryptocurrency
keynotes
and concepts
so let's start with an exciting video on
blockchain and cryptocurrency full
course of 2022
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn
ever wonder if there's an easier way to
complete transactions without having to
deal with online wallets banks and
third-party applications well it's
possible thanks to blockchain here's
everything you need to know about
blockchain imagine four friends jack ted
sam and phil meet up for dinner after
they're done jack pays the bill and all
of them decide to split the expense
amongst each other now on the next day
when phil sends his share to jack via
online money transfer the transaction
goes through without a hitch then ted
and sam send their respective shares to
jack but their transactions don't go
through the failed transaction cites
some issues at the bank that's when jack
comes to know about the many ways a bank
transaction could fail it could be due
to technical issues at the bank one of
their accounts were hacked daily
transfer limits being exceeded and
sometimes additional charges like
transfer charges associated with
transferring money to solve these
problems the concept of cryptocurrency
came into existence cryptocurrencies are
a form of digital or virtual currency
that run on a technology known as
blockchain thanks to blockchain
cryptocurrencies are immune to
counterfeiting don't require a central
authority and are protected by strong
and complex encryption algorithms and in
a market of more than thousands of
cryptocurrencies like litecoin ethereum
c cash and so on one reign supreme
bitcoin now let's go back to our
previous example and have bill ted and
sam send jack two bitcoins each as their
contribution to the previous night's
dinner let's assume phil ted and sam
have three bitcoins in reserve while
jack has five first phil sends two
bitcoins to jack a record is created in
the form of a block the transaction
details between them is permanently
inscribed in this block this record also
holds the number of bitcoins each of the
friends own so after phil's transaction
jack has seven bitcoins while phil has
one following this sam and ted send two
bitcoins to jack a new block is created
for each of these transactions these
blocks hold the transaction details as
well as how many bitcoins sam ted and
jack have in reserve these blocks are
linked to each other as each of them
takes reference from the previous one
for the number of bitcoins each brand
owns this chain of records or blocks is
called a ledger and this ledger is
shared among all the friends which acts
as a public distributed ledger this
forms the basis of blockchain so what
happens when phil has only one bitcoin
left and he tries to send two more
bitcoins to jack the transaction will
not go through this is because all his
friends have copies of the ledger and
it's clear that phil has only one
bitcoin left his friends will flag this
transaction as invalid a hacker will not
be able to alter the data in the
blockchain because each user has a copy
of the ledger the data within the blocks
are encrypted by complex algorithms all
of this is made possible with the help
of blockchain technology blockchain can
be described as a collection of records
linked with each other strongly
resistant to alteration and protected
using cryptography now let's have a
closer look at the bitcoin transaction
between jack and phil and find out how
it works every user in the bitcoin
network has two keys a public key and a
private key the public key is an address
that everyone in the network knows of
like an email address of a user the
private key is a unique address that
only the user has knowledge of something
like a password first bill passes the
number of bitcoins he wants to send to
jack along with his and jack's unique
wallet address through a hashing
algorithm all of this is part of the
transaction details these details are
encrypted using encryption algorithms
and using phil's unique private key this
is done to digitally sign the
transaction and to indicate that the
transactions came from fill this output
is now transmitted across the world
using jack's public key with this the
message or transaction can be decrypted
only by jack's private key which only
jack has knowledge of different
cryptocurrencies use different hashing
algorithms while bitcoin uses the
sha-256 algorithm ethereum which is also
a famous cryptocurrency uses one known
as ether
this transaction and several other
similar ones are taking place all around
the world these transactions are
validated and then added block by block
the people who validate these blocks are
called miners
for a block to be validated and added to
a blockchain miners need to solve a
complex mathematical problem the miner
who solves this first adds the block to
the blockchain and is rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins the process of solving the
complex mathematical problem is called
proof of work and the process of adding
a block to the blockchain is called
mining
with this phil and jack's wallets are
updated just like every person in the
network who has completed a transaction
now that you know about blockchain and
its important concepts time for a small
quiz what is the concept of blockchain
that ensures data cannot be altered by
any of the users within the network a
public distributed ledger b
proof of work
c
proof of stake d
hash encryption let us know what you
think is the right answer in the
comments below three lucky winners will
get amazon gift vouchers details are
mentioned in the description below let's
have a look at how walmart uses
blockchain to provide its customers with
better service walmart was facing
problems in delivering quality products
to its customers they were facing a high
return rate and large amounts of refunds
due to their products bad quality they
were unable to determine the point of
failure in the supply chain which
started from farm to storage to
transportation to processing all the way
to the customer then walmart adopted
blockchain technology with blockchain
the quality of the goods at each step
was permanently inscribed within a block
for example when a customer flags a
product as damaged it can be correctly
identified where the product got damaged
in the entire supply chain thus helping
walmart to identify the problem areas
and fixing them and this is just one of
several ways blockchain is used in real
life application let's get started
with who is a blockchain developer
a blockchain developer is a person who
is responsible for developing and hence
enhancing blockchain related
applications famously known as dapps
smart contracts architecture and
protocols
for those who don't know what blockchain
is
blockchain is a system of recording
details of transactions in a block
taking place in the blockchain network
that makes it difficult or impossible to
change or hack
which means they are immutable
a blockchain is essentially a digital
public ledger of transactions that is
copied and distributed across the entire
network of computer systems on the
blockchain
basically blockchain developers enable
secure digital transactions by creating
systems and applications to record and
store blockchain data and prevent
external changes or hacks
that brings us to what are the types of
blockchain developers
there are two types of blockchain
developers
core blockchain developers and
blockchain software developers
each type has its specific type of role
let's go through them in more detail
the core blockchain developers design
the protocols required to run a
blockchain solution successfully which
means they are majorly responsible for
the architecture development of
blockchain
they are also responsible for designing
consensus protocols and making
high-level decisions
blockchain software developers
develop and implement the blockchain
using the designs and solutions created
by the core blockchain developers they
are majorly responsible for designing
and implementing smart contracts and
developing decentralized applications or
dapps
now let's understand what are the
technical skills required to become a
blockchain developer
to become a blockchain developer you
need to have a specific set of technical
skills let's take a look at them
understanding blockchain architecture
for starters you should have a complete
understanding of blockchain technology
its architecture how it works and its
critical concepts like hash functions
distributed ledger technology and
consensus protocols
next data structure and coding
data structures and coding are
considered the most basic and essential
skills required to be a fine developer
it is a must-have skill to become a
blockchain developer as it enhances your
ability to play and configure blockchain
according to your requirements
development of smart contracts
smart contracts is the most vital part
of blockchain technology the programming
language solidity is used to create
smart contracts
ethereum is the best example for smart
contracts it helps you set up the
business and develop and deploy dabs
using smart contracts
and at last basic knowledge of
cryptography
blockchain secures its data by using
highly effective cryptography algorithms
cryptography helps you implement dabs
and other blockchain services
now we have covered the technical skills
required to become a blockchain
developer let's explore the roles and
responsibilities of a blockchain
developer
both core blockchain developer and
blockchain software developer have
different roles and responsibilities
first we will discuss the roles and
responsibilities of core blockchain
developer
core blockchain developer understand and
implement the features and
functionalities of blockchain
they design protocols and consensus
protocols for blockchain networks
they create solutions for providing
security to the data stored in the
blockchain network
and then make sure that the blockchain
network functions smoothly and securely
now blockchain software developer design
and implement smart contracts
they develop and deploy decentralized
application or dabs as per the
requirements
also they look after the integration
with other applications and services
now let's dive down and explore the
companies hiring blockchain developers
there is a massive demand for blockchain
developers and if you know your skills
well you will surely get a good start
with your career as blockchain developer
joining a programmer's community and
working on real projects will help you
learn grow and upskill yourself
according to 2021 scienceof a software
development company ripple labs in
corporation and american technology
company that deals with the ripple
payment
leeway herds a software development
company for startup at enterprises
chroma way a blockchain technology
company
open ledger a decentralized financial
platform used to convert bitcoins to
smart coins
and intellect soft a company specialized
in providing software products and
integrated solutions are a few top
companies who hired blockchain
developers to work on blockchain
technology
now that we know about the demand of
blockchain developers worldwide let's
figure out the average salary of a
blockchain developer in both the usa and
india
in the usa the average salary of
blockchain developer is over 157
thousand dollars per year
and in india it ranges from 5 lakh
rupees 30 lakh rupees per year
so this is all about who is a blockchain
developer hi guys i'm rahul from
simplylearn and today i'm going to tell
you how you can become a blockchain
developer now before we begin let's see
the current situation of the market 84
of companies are now dabbling into
blockchain blockchain is the fastest
growing skill in the u.s freelance job
market apple steve wozniak is getting
involved with blockchain projects and
jpmorgan cio believes that blockchain
will replace existing technology as we
can see with the amount of focus
organizations are putting on blockchain
and what tech influencers around the
world have to say about it we can see
clearly that they really believe that
blockchain can have a tremendous
positive impact on our lives and the
market as a whole so it's no surprise
that blockchain has worldwide acclaim
now it's created a huge number of job
opportunities across the world and one
such job is that of a blockchain
developer so here's what we're going to
learn today who is a blockchain
developer what are the types of
blockchain developers the steps you have
to follow to become a blockchain
developer the obstacles you might face
while learning blockchain the salaries
offered to blockchain developers and how
companies are using blockchain right now
so who is a blockchain developer a
blockchain developer is someone who
designs implements and supports a
blockchain network so in a way they are
responsible for setting up the
blockchain network and then ensuring
that it works properly they create and
optimize blockchain protocols for
example is the network a public network
they create such protocols and then
optimize it based on that usage or
requirement they develop distributed
applications and smart contracts on the
blockchain network now let's talk about
the different types of blockchain
developers so they fall under two major
categories core blockchain developers
and blockchain software developers a
core blockchain developer works on the
core features and the architecture of
the blockchain network basically they're
in charge of the entire blockchain
network they manage the architecture of
the network supervise the blockchain
network they work on consensus
algorithms for example there's the
proof-of-work algorithm in bitcoin and
set up blockchain protocols a core
blockchain developer works very much
like a core web developer now the main
thing is that they both work on course
concepts now just like blockchain
developers work on protocols you have
web developers working on protocols like
http or tcp and so on now let's talk
about a blockchain software developer
now they work on blockchain to create
applications now they create smart
contracts develop distributed
applications and work on the front and
back end application development
blockchain software developers are also
very similar to web application
developers both of them create
applications on a network that's already
set up by core developers so how do you
become a blockchain developer so before
you start off on your path to becoming a
blockchain developer there are some
things that you really have to know now
we're going to talk about the
prerequisites first up you have
programming languages now it is
absolutely necessary that you be
well-versed in programming languages
before you can get onto blockchain
development most blockchains are created
in languages like java c plus plus
javascript go python c sharp and so on
so let me emphasize how important it is
that you know programming languages now
for core blockchain development any of
these aforementioned languages will do
the job for you however in case you have
to create distributed applications and
smart contracts on ethereum it is
mandatory that you learn the programming
language solidity then you need to
understand the fundamentals of object
oriented programming now the concepts of
object-oriented programming which anyone
who codes will know is the wrapping up
of data and functions into a single unit
this is exactly what blockchains
function on for example you have the
ethereum block here it has two
components data and function the user
details act as the data now this data
includes the person who's sending the
transaction or how much money they're
planning to transfer then you have the
function which is the command to send
and receive payments then you need to
learn about flat and relational
databases now blockchain was created on
the basis of these two types of
databases a flat database stores data in
a single table structure and a
relational database uses a number of
tables and can cross-reference records
across tables so it is necessary that
you understand how these two databases
work to completely understand how
blockchain was created from their
concepts then you need to learn what
data structures are you need to
understand the working of data
structures like stack linked list queue
and so on this is because blockchain by
itself is a backlinked list each block
in a blockchain references the previous
block now this is done by a field in the
blocks header known as the previous hash
that holds the hash value of the
preceding block knowledge about web
application development by being well
versed in web app development you're
opening yourself to a wide range of
opportunities to create web and mobile
applications using blockchain technology
because regardless of whether the
application works on blockchain
technology the front end can be created
only with web application development
then you need to know about networking
blockchains work on the internet so you
need to understand the many concepts
regarding networks for example how
systems are able to communicate with
each other how the network works and so
much more now after you're done with all
of this you're ready to start your
journey to become a blockchain developer
the first step is to understand the
concepts of blockchain now satoshi
nakamoto's whitepaper bitcoin appear to
be a electronic cache system gives a
detailed account on how bitcoin works
and introduces us to the concept of
blockchain so if you want to learn
firsthand how blockchain works from the
creator of bitcoin himself i would
suggest you go to satoshi nakamoto's
paper next you need to learn important
terms related to blockchain for example
what is a minor what is a block what is
a public distributed ledger hash
encryption proof of work mining and so
much more then you can learn how systems
other than bitcoin like ethereum
hyperledger hashgraph and so on use
blockchain to work with their technology
the second step involves understanding
the economics behind cryptocurrencies in
blockchain blockchain technologies work
on
economics which is nothing but the
combination of two words cryptography
and economics cryptography in blockchain
involves hashing digital signatures and
proof of work hashing is involved in
maintaining the privacy of a user within
the network this is made possible with
the help of cryptographic algorithms for
example in bitcoin we have the sha-256
algorithm and et hash in ethereum
digital signatures help validate a
particular user within the network this
is made possible with the combination of
the user's public and private keys proof
of work involves miners around the world
trying to solve a complex mathematical
puzzle to be able to add a block to the
blockchain on the economic side you need
to understand how miners are
incentivized the users who add and take
part in the blockchain are given
cryptocurrencies now people who take
decisions also have the right to charge
a fee for their service for example if a
person has a block and he has to decide
what transactions he's going to add to
that block he has the right to charge
you some amount of money if you want
your transaction to be added to his
block good users of the network are
rewarded with monetary compensation or
the ability to take decisions bad users
of the network have to pay a fine or
have their rights to take decisions
stripped away step three is to
understand how cryptocurrencies work
with cryptocurrencies there's a whole
number of steps before a process is
complete you need to understand how each
and every step works for example first
how a sender begins the transaction to
send money to the receiver how the
message is encrypted and transmitted
across the network how miners are able
to verify that transaction how the block
is added to the blockchain how money is
deducted from each of the participants
wallets you need to understand the
relationship between each and every step
of the process and how they interact
with each other step 4 getting some
hands-on experience now after you're
done with all the steps that i mentioned
before this one's the hardest practical
application so even if you know all the
theory if you don't have any practical
experience it won't have a very large
impact so you need to start coding and
creating your own smart contracts you
need to create your own distributed
applications on the ethereum platform
also let me remind you for you to be
able to create smart contracts or
distributed applications you need to
have learned the programming language
solidity and finally you can invest in
bitcoins or other cryptocurrencies so
that you can have an understanding of
how they actually work now it's very
important that you also keep yourself
updated regarding cryptocurrencies and
blockchains and bitcoins by reading up
on blogs and forums you can take part in
discord chat rooms you can use the
telegram application which has a very
active community on cryptocurrencies and
blockchain you can involve yourself in
subreddits like r slash blockchain r
slash bitcoin and other related
subreddits you can get on coin market
cap that talks about market
capitalizations of several
cryptocurrencies coin market cal and so
much more there's an abundance of
resources on the internet that you can
take advantage of now let's talk about
the obstacles that you might face while
learning blockchain now you've noticed
that blockchain isn't very easy there's
a lot of content to cover now to make
matters worse you could also face some
of these problems first of them is
outdated content now the tutorials and
content that you might find online
cannot possibly keep up with the
constantly changing technology so it's
only natural that the content that you
might get might be a little outdated
which isn't what you want you want the
latest and the most highest quality
content secondly lack of quality content
now there's an abundance of sources that
you can learn from and since there's
such a wide variety
it's possible that you might end up
using a type of source that's of low
quality or of substandard quality now
let's talk about salaries that you can
get in a blockchain job now in the
united states blockchain developers earn
130 000 per annum according to burning
glass technologies in the more tech
oriented areas of us like silicon valley
new york and boston they earn up to 150
000 per annum several companies around
the world have invested heavily into
incorporating blockchain into their
processes now you have companies like
alphabet bank of america wells fargo
apple microsoft and so on so this is a
clear indication that companies are very
interested in hiring people who are
skilled enough in the concepts of
blockchain and finally how are companies
using blockchain walmart uses blockchain
to keep track of each and every step in
the supply chain with this they are able
to track down where the problem area is
and to ensure that that problem is
solved before it can happen again you
have jpmorgan chase and co this company
created their own blockchain application
called quorum that solves the processing
that allows private transactions to take
place in a group of participants whose
identities are known the agricultural
bank of china created a learning system
using blockchain that aim to help small
and medium-sized agricultural businesses
that didn't have a good credit record
now how can simply learn help you
simply learn provides certification
courses that give you an introductory or
an advance understanding into the
concepts of blockchain the introductory
blockchain basics course provides 12
hours of self-paced learning and covers
all the concepts related to bitcoin and
blockchain data structures moreover it
gives you an introduction into
blockchain bitcoin blockchain mining
buying and selling bitcoins emerging
trends in blockchain and so much more
now the advanced course or the
blockchain certification training course
provides 32 hours of instructor-led
training 50 plus hands-on exercises
using blockchain technology nine
practical projects covering ethereum
hyperledger and bitcoin case studies and
so on it also helps you understand
solidity programming ethereum coding
advanced smart contracts ethereum
application architecture real-life
projects and so much more the content of
these courses are constantly updated to
keep up with emerging trends in the
market and it is of highest quality so
now let's have a look at supply chain
management now let's look at a scenario
before blockchain so there's a delivery
boy bringing jon his order of apples now
john thanks him and sees that his apples
are rotten and jon says that he wants
his money back however the delivery boy
says he can't help since he's just the
delivery boy not the person who created
the product so these problems are the
ones that were faced before blockchain
but with blockchain technology there is
traceability across the supply chain
this means that you can trace back to
what happened to the product at each
step of the supply chain blockchain
technology enables these transactions to
be tracked in a very secure and
transparent manner now some benefits of
using blockchain technology other
there's a single record policy which
means there's a single record throughout
the entire supply chain there's reduced
costs since there's no requirement for
multiple records across the entire
supply chain there's eliminating error
and less human intervention now the last
two points come somewhat in correlation
since the less of the human intervention
usually the lesser the amount of error
let's have a look at an example of a
supply chain management so the product
starts from the farm goes through
storage undergoes food processing it's
manufactured distributed given to the
retailer and finally reaches the
customer now in supply chain management
blockchain is able to provide a
permanent record a whole lot of
transparency and the ability to validate
the transactions that are shared across
multiple supply chain partners with
blockchain the transactions are recorded
in a decentralized distributed ledger
now the advantage of this is that anyone
can verify the authenticity or the
status of a product that is being
delivered now if you want to look at a
real life example you have to look no
further than walmart walmart is building
a blockchain distributed ledger so that
they can connect and track poke
suppliers shippers purchases and other
units involved in its supply chain that
are delivering the food product across
china now this is done to reduce the
risk of data tampering or inaccuracy or
inaccuracy now let's have a look at how
blockchain helps cyber security imagine
the scenario where a is sending twenty
dollars to b a sends this money and this
transaction details are stored in the
cloud now what if a hacker hacks the
data within the cloud and tampers this
he tampers this in such a way that he
receives the 20 instead of b here you
can see the hacker being all smug about
it now this is the main problem with the
current banking system now it is prone
to cyber attacks because it has a
centralized network this can also lead
to fraud as well as data theft cyber
attacks are one of the biggest threats
that the public has to face however
blockchain is a solution that makes sure
that your data is protected from
tampering as well as helps improving
cyber security across a number of
different industries some of the
benefits are that it provides high
security with the help of the
cryptography that i mentioned before it
has a decentralized storage quick
transactions which take only about 10
minutes and lower cost as compared to
banking transaction costs now let's look
at the same scenario but with the help
of bitcoins or blockchain now a is
sending
0.0025 bitcoins to b which amounts to
approximately 20 dollars these bitcoins
are sent and blockchain which is a
distributed ledger distributes the data
across multiple nodes within the network
and secures this data using cryptography
another thing that you have to remember
is that each node has a copy of the
ledger and cryptography protects the
data within it against any changes
making it immutable now imagine a hacker
trying to hack the data here he's
unsuccessful because the peer-to-peer
connection which prevents data from
being altered as well as tampered now
and finally b receives the twenty
dollars in bitcoins now for a real life
application mastercard has its own
blockchain project where mastercard is
using blockchain for sending as well as
receiving money it also allows the
exchange of currency without the need of
a central authority now let's have a
look at how blockchain can help with the
voting process now before blockchain a
voter would have to submit their water
id their water ids need to be verified
and after the verification the voter
would submit his or her word to the evm
or the electronic voting machine after
that the voting is complete however it
is possible for the evm to be hacked
since it's a centralized system this can
lead to some amount of manipulation with
the vote count however with the
decentralized system like blockchain it
is possible to completely eliminate any
scope of forgery as well as data
manipulation now let's have a look at
how voting can be performed with the
help of blockchain now first the water
downloads the voting application the
voter submits a voter id and registers
for the election after the verification
is complete the water has been
authorized to cast his or her vote and
the water submits his or her vote
without revealing their identity to the
public now once the support has been
added to the blockchain the information
within the blockchain can never be
erased after this the officials can
count these words knowing that each id
can be attributed to just one vote now
with blockchain voters can also count
the number of votes themselves using
blockchain in the voting process
provides complete transparency by
eliminating any need for third-party
systems to be involved along with that
it can also eliminate voter fraud as
well as election triggering it increases
the transparency in the voting process
and reduces the expense of conducting
the elections now in real life examples
me vote which is a token based
blockchain platform works very similar
to that of a digital ballot box now it
protects the integrity of the world as
well as protects the security of the
election process now this is already
implemented in australia so it's only a
matter of time before this or similar
technologies can be set up across the
world now let's have a look at some of
the other applications there's insurance
where with blockchain they can eliminate
forgery as well as false claims and real
estate where this increases the speed of
the conveyance process and eliminates
any requirement for money exchanges so
if talking about blockchain and its
applications have caught your interest i
suggest we get on to simplylearn.com
and check out our blockchain
certification training course here we
provide 50 hours of in-depth learning 40
plus hands-on exercises with integrated
labs 11 practical projects covering
multiple technologies like ethereum
hyperledger multi-chain and bitcoin
flexibility to choose your own class
timings case studies and 24 7 support
we'll be covering technologies like git
ethereum ganache go docker hyperledger
and much more we'll also be talking
about bitcoin blockchain ethereum
deploying smart contracts hyperledger
blockchain or multi-chain and a whole
lot more so why don't you go on to
simplylearn.com and get started on your
journey to getting certified and getting
ahead
i think blockchain is going to be a very
critical technology
for the future development of the world
it's not only
about financing
blockchain technology is not about
bitcoins
bitcoin is just a small function of the
blockchain technology
i'm a strong deliverer of the blockchain
technology this is not about bitcoin or
digital currencies or crypto assets it's
the underlying blockchain technology now
people can trust each other and they can
transact with anything from money to
music to votes to
their identities peer-to-peer bitcoin is
either myspace or it's facebook i don't
know
but blockchain is
social media
so at the macro blockchain is going
nowhere
right like blockchain's here to stay
forever and it's a very big deal
enter
blockchain
satoshi nakamoto 2008 anonymous person
came up with this way of people
transacting doing business with assets
peer-to-peer and trust is not achieved
by a middleman it's achieved by
cryptography by collaboration and by
some clever code and what that means is
that we now have a native digital medium
for value effectively as software okay
it's a distributed database that's
managed independently and that
inherently that inherent combination
makes it a utility makes it software
effectively that has value
[Music]
the business world of the future say 10
years from now
is going to run on smart contracts it's
going to run on strong encryption and on
you know peer-to-peer base consensus
mechanisms so the core technologies
underlying blockchain
[Music]
are going to pervade everything just
like the internet has just like
object-oriented software has right no
so the choice when i talk to people i
said what do you think will be here in
2040 approximately 22 years from now
will gold still be here well it's been
here since eternity
will the dollar will the dollar be here
i don't think so
and will blockchain be here i think so
we think of bitcoin as a digital gold so
gold 2.0 but it's money the first step
of money that was ever built purposely
for the internet so it's sort of like
what your email did to snail mail
cryptocurrency or bitcoin does for money
well bitcoin is
exciting because it shows how cheap it
can be
uh bitcoin is is better than currency
you don't have to
be physically in the same place and of
course for large transactions currency
can can get pretty inconvenient
the customers we're talking about aren't
trying to be anonymous you know they're
willing to be uh known so
the bitcoin technology is key and you
could add to it or you could build a
similar technology
where there's enough attribution that
people feel comfortable this is nothing
to do with
terrorism or
any type of money laundering
it's still very early um institutions
everybody knows about it everyone's
heard about it and there's some very
sophisticated people in even these banks
who know about cryptocurrency but
they're still not really in the game yet
it's still very much a retail driven
market um very much a lot of the actions
out in asia so we we still think it's
the bottom of the first inning it's if
you read this book you understand how we
got here and how far it's come
but it's also just sort of the beginning
in a lot of ways
well i think it is working um and
there will be other currencies like it
that may maybe even better um but in the
meantime um there's a big industry
around bitcoin and
um you know people have made fortunes
out of bitcoin some people have lost
money out of bitcoin um it's vulnerable
it's volatile yeah but it is quite
volatile but um but you know when in
volatile volatility people can make
money out of politics so where i see
crypto as effectively as a replacement
for cash
but not as a replacement for as a
primary
uh
not as i do not see crypto being the
primary database
[Music]
i would say there's a lot of need for
developers even at the core protocol
layer so things like improving protocol
scalability working on the kind of
limitations
implementations of things like proof of
stake
layer 2 systems things like snake
channels and plasma i could probably use
a lot more smart people
um on
the application stuff i mean i guess you
could always use more but there's
probably quite a lot more of that
already
welcome to this session of blockchain
tutorial part one my name is saurabh and
i'm part of the simply learn team so
let's get started and understand what's
in it for us today so let's check in
hypothesis in a city not so far away
somebody was up to something bad so
there is a hacker who hates the bank who
wants to steal the money of all the
people lying in the bank
now here's why i hate them even more
what are the nuances and the problem
areas of the banking system the banking
system has higher transactional and
international transfer costs a lot of
documentation is required for setting up
of an account for opening an account and
onboarding a customer and the banking
system is not always accessible it's not
24x7 it's closed on banking holidays and
it has other limitations also like
transfer limits in a day and you know
you can't transfer x amount within a
stipulated time now banks in such an
ecosystem acts as a center point of
failure it is a centralized based system
which is prone to failure from a
centralized point of view so if the bank
fails all the transactions will come to
an halt which are dependent on the bank
now let's see what happens if the hacker
is able to get into the banking system
and hacks the bank all the investors or
the people associated with the bank the
information associated with them will
get corrupted will get jeopardized and
it can lead to huge losses to the bank
and to the individuals and all this can
happen with a click of a button it's as
simple as that so once a hacker has
access to the system he can manipulate
the system compromise the information
share it with the parties which are not
supposed to have that information and
lot can go wrong though the hackers can
be caught right it is possible through
cyber security and various means but
once the information is compromised it
is very difficult to roll that back and
that's why we need more secure systems
and systems which are not dependent on a
centralized authority which work in a
more decentralized fashion thereby
making it hack proof plus lowering the
transaction cost also now this incident
of course will catch the bank manager's
attention now he will go to his advisors
and want to make sure this does not
happen again so the technology com
people the advisors will make sure that
this does not happen but what is the
remedy so the remedy is setting up a
blockchain now of course the manager
who's looking into the banking functions
might not be aware of the technology and
what benefits blockchain bring onto the
table in order to prevent such an
incident so that's what we are here for
we will learn before we go and
understand what can blockchain actually
achieve for us so we will understand
today what is blockchain the bitcoin
story the features of blockchain like
public distributed ledger the hashing
encryption the proof of work consensus
algorithm and the concept of mining and
then we will cover up a use case where
how blockchain can be used for banking
operations now what is blockchain
blockchain is a list of records called
blocks which stores data publicly and in
a chronological order and the entire
information is persisted using
cryptography it is secured using
cryptography so cryptography ensures
that the privacy of the user is
maintained and data cannot be altered
information on a blockchain network is
not controlled by a centralized
authority so unlike modern financial
institutions nobody controls the data
within a blockchain the data is
maintained by the participants of the
network and they are the democratic
authority in order to approve any
transaction which can happen on a
blockchain network access to anyone on
the network so a typical blockchain
network is a public blockchain so as
long as you have access to the network
you have access to the data within the
blockchain if you are a participant on
the blockchain network you will have the
same copy of the ledger which all other
participants have so therefore everyone
every participant on the network has the
same copy of the data so everyone in the
network has a copy of the blockchain
data which is used for ensuring the data
remains untampered so even if one node
or data on one particular participant
computer gets corrupted the other
participants will come to know
immediately that this particular
instance or node has gone corrupted and
they will rectify it as soon as possible
so basically the question is is this the
same technology that bitcoin works on
and the answer is yes bitcoin could not
have been possible without blockchain so
we will understand how bitcoin adopted
blockchain in order to reach to its
journey today so bitcoin was introduced
in 2009 by someone or a group of people
known as satoshi nakamoto it aimed to
solve the problem faced by fiat
currencies with the help of blockchain
technology now as of today in 2018 there
are more than 1600 cryptocurrencies that
follow the concepts of bitcoin and
blockchain for example the other popular
cryptocurrencies are like ethereum
litecoin dash ripple and many more now
let me explain how a bitcoin transaction
works the sender transmits the
transaction details worldwide basically
whenever a sender has to do a
transaction he has to send bitcoins to a
receiver he will submit the transaction
on the public blockchain network of
bitcoin and transmit it now verification
to authenticate users it is done by the
miners around the world so basically
there are specific participants in the
bitcoin network which are called as
miners whose job is to verify the
authenticity of the sender and the
receiver and also validate whether the
sender has the right amount of balance
for the bitcoin which he is trying to
send to the receiver and ensuring that
the sanity of the underlying blockchain
network to the bitcoin remains correct
and not get corrupted so once the miner
has authenticated the transaction
verified all the parameters the
transaction is added to a block and then
that block is made part of the main
blockchain once the block is added to
the blockchain the money the
transactions which were associated in
the block then gets executed money is
deducted from the sender's wallet and is
added to the receiver wallet thereby
once the transaction is completed the
block is added and the ledger across all
the nodes are updated each and every
participant ledger copy is updated with
that particular block which has been
added in the blockchain so therefore all
the participants have the same copy of
the information now so what makes
blockchain special now these are the
special four features of blockchain
which we're going to talk about in
detail it is a public distributed ledger
it works using a hashing encryption each
and every block has a hash value which
is the digital signature of the block
all the transactions are approved and
verified on the blockchain network using
proof of work consensus algorithm and
the blockchain network utilizes the
resources of the miners who are there to
validate the transaction and the miners
in lieu of putting up investing in the
resources and validating the
transactions get rewards in terms of
bitcoin and that process is called
mining now public distributed ledger
let's imagine four friends sharing a
particular document amongst each other
correct now if there was only a single
copy of that document and one of them
altered the data it may go unnoticed
however the outcome would be different
if each one of them had a copy of the
data so therefore if each and every
participant has the same copy of the
data even if one of them changed the
data the others would find that the data
does not match with their own so
blockchain works in a similar fashion
the data within a blockchain is
accessible to everyone so with this as
long as you are part of the network you
could access the entire history of
transactions that have taken place since
the blockchain was created since
inception and the first block in any
blockchain is called the genesis block
so from the genesis block to the current
block you will have the access to the
entire chain any additions to blocking
have to be approved by the participant
users in the blockchain network so a
majority of the members within the
network have to approve of any additions
to the blockchain this is the public
part of the ledger and this is important
because any additions made to the
blockchain are permanent and are
immutable so immutable transactions are
the transactions which cannot be altered
once registered they cannot be modified
and are available for audit and
verification 24x7 so this means that
each and every detail is recorded and
any alterations can be detected by
verifying it against everyone's personal
version of the blockchain so if
someone's tried to modify a data on a
block on a particular node then the
other ledgers which are having the same
information
will come to know that someone has
modified data on one particular node and
they will try to rectify it and the
fourth property no central authority is
controlling the working of this
blockchain network it is a decentralized
network so this is where being
decentralized helps everyone has a copy
of the blockchain which means there is
no central point of failure there is a
single source of truth even if things go
wrong the data can be recovered if one
node goes wrong the data can be
recovered from other nodes but what
about security how is privacy maintained
if everything is so public and here
hashing encryptions comes into picture
it takes care of that now we will talk
about the second feature which is
hashing encryption but to understand
hashing encryption we need to understand
the contents what are the contents of a
block so a block in a blockchain is like
a container that holds aggregated
transactions it contains certain set of
transactions so we will see what all
things construct a particular block so a
block has two parts it has a header and
it has the second part is the
transaction details it is the set of
transactions which are aggregated in
this block now the header has following
set of attributes it has the block
version number it has the hash of the
previous block to which it is linked the
current timestamp the timestamp at which
the block was verified the nonce nonce
we will see what is the attribute what
is the meaning of nonce and target value
now the transaction details are nothing
but the example which we talked about
earlier it is the transaction which the
sender and receiver are sharing the
sender is trying to send certain amount
of bitcoin from his account to the
receiver's account now it is represented
in the form of a 256 bit hash value in
the header called as merkle root or the
hash root so basically the merkle root
is the hash of all the transactions
structured in a merkle tree called
binary tree it's a kind of a binary tree
and the hash value of the root node of
the merkle tree is called the merkle
root hash so the transaction details of
a block are contained in the header in a
hex value known as merkle root the
merkle root can be calculated in this
way so basically the list of transaction
each transaction is passed through a
hashing algorithm then all the hashes of
the transactions are paired and then
again passed through another hashing
algorithm until only one value remains
and which will be the root now let me
tell you how a hash function works
blockchain utilizes a hash function to
perform cryptography data from a data
set of random size is sent as input to a
hashing function to get an encrypted
value of fixed size and that is the
feature of any hashing function so some
unique properties of hashing function
are these are deterministic the same
input will always produce the same hash
output small changes in the data can
drastically change the output so
basically any small change to the input
produces an output that's drastically
different from its previous obtained
outputs it can be computed easily the
output values can be obtained without a
whole lot of calculation and hashing
functions are one-way functions
basically you won't be able to determine
the input based on the output value so
you can't do the reverse calculation now
let's go back to our block we were
talking about earlier so as we were
discussing what are the features in the
header the previous hash is the
resultant hash of the previous block in
the blockchain and this is the way two
blocks are linked together now
transaction details these are used to
provide details about the sender
receiver and how much money they want to
exchange between them and this is a list
of transactions and they are structured
in a merkle tree and the hash of the
merkle root is put in the header nonce
is a value that is varied to create a
unique hash address of the block which
should be less than the target hash
value so this is the structure of the
header it has a block version number
basically the sequence number of the
block it has the hash of the previous
block the timestamp when the block was
mined and verified the nonce value the
header is then this entire header is
then passed through a hashing algorithm
in the case of a bitcoin network it is
sha-256 and a hash value is generated
and now this hash value becomes the hash
value of the block now this value is a
256 bit value that is used to uniquely
identify the particular block so sh 256
ensures that alterations to data can be
easily detected so for example consider
these two blocks in the blockchain they
have a similar structure and definitely
different hash values now if someone
alters the transaction details in the
first block the corresponding hash value
of the block would change too now the
values of hash value of the first block
and the previous hash value of the other
block will not match basically the block
subsequent to the hacked block will get
d-linked now this will raise an alarm
among the users informing them that data
alteration has taken place the users
will then be able to flag the block so
the alteration can be easily identified
and rectified immediately to ensure
security blockchains also include
digital signatures these ensure that the
message come from the right identity
right person and that the message is not
tampered with users are provided their
own private and public key so whenever a
user onboard a public blockchain he is
provided a pair of public and private
key now private key is used by the user
to control his her own account this is
kept as a secret by the user so
basically it is like his own password
and public key public key is used to
identify the user on the network this is
shared by the user along with the
transaction on the network for others to
verify so these are the steps involved
in creating and authenticating a digital
signature so at the sender side the
message to be transmitted is passed
through the hashing algorithm in in this
case of bitcoin it is she-256 and the
hash is generated plus the private key
is used to generate a digital signature
now this output is passed through a
signature algorithm along with the
user's private key to create a digital
signature now during the transmission
the user's message their digital
fingerprint which was generated in the
previous step plus the public key are
transmitted across the network so these
three things are published on the
network for the validators for the
miners to use and verify the
authenticity of the sender now at the
receiver's end first the message is
passed through a hashing algorithm now
at the same time the sender's public key
and his or her digital signature are
passed through a very fiction algorithm
now both the functions will generate a
hash if both the hashes are compared and
if they match then the transaction and
the identity of the sender is approved
otherwise it is rejected so basically
this is the process by comparing the
hash values to authenticate the identity
of the sender now what about the people
who verify these transactions and how do
they actually do it so remember that one
field in the block header called norms
that becomes very important in order to
verify the transaction so now we will
talk about the third feature which is
the proof of work consensus algorithm so
proof of work involves people around the
world the participants in the network
called miners competing to be the first
one to add a block to the blockchain and
in lieu of this they will be rewarded
there are competing miners around the
world they are trying to solve a
mathematical puzzle to be the first one
to be rewarded and to add a block to the
blockchain so this is the reward so
thereby they invest in the computing
power they invest in the resources in
order to mine and validate a transaction
to get that reward now what is the
mathematical puzzle so basically they
need to find a hash value that satisfies
certain predefined conditions now in
order to find the hash value they will
use norms so this target hash value is
decided months in advance for every
block the miners keep variating the
nonce value to find out an output that
falls within the target requirement so
they keep on generating a hash value
using the norms and if it is less than
the target the hash value is accepted
and if it is greater than the hash value
is rejected the minus effort is not
considered valid now a minor transmits
across the world that he has found a
nonce that satisfies the target
requirement as soon as he find it and
thanks to the hashing algorithm used
this claim can be easily verified by
others so basically the proof of work
algorithm it is very hard to generate
the nonce and get the hash value but it
is very easy to verify the transaction
by the other miners so that's a whole
lot of work what a miner's payoff is so
for all his or her hard work they get
paid in the bitcoins and this is the
only way the bitcoins get added to the
network sometimes they get other forms
of remuneration as well and this is the
concept of mining so the entire process
when the miner has done the proof of
work consensus they are rewarded and
this is called as mining so mining is
the process of adding a block to the
block kit this miner is the first person
who found a nonce value that fell within
the target requirement right now for
doing this the miner is rewarded as of
today on the bitcoin network a miner is
paid 12.5 bitcoins for adding a block
onto the blockchain but the reward a
miner gets reduced by half every four
years so when the fourth year will
approach for the threshold the bitcoin
reward will go down to 6.25 bitcoins and
miners also get the sum of all the
transaction fees for that particular
block so the 12.5 bitcoin reward is
justified as mining is a very expensive
process it has a heavy toll on
electricity computing power and other
resources on which the miner has
invested now we will take a look at the
use cases where blockchain is applicable
in banks so we have been incorporating a
program where banks can validate user
identity as of now a user needs to do
the process over and over again in each
bank he has to go and prove the identity
in each bank is there a way we can ease
the process with blockchain and the
answer is yes we can we will be using
truffle ethereum ganache and smart
contracts all of these blockchain
technology ecosystem to make it work and
welcome to this demo for how to build
your kyc blockchain application now i'm
gonna show you all the steps required to
deploy your kyc application what all
components are to be developed and how
to go about deploying and testing your
application so primarily this kyc
application will allow banks to do us
decentralized kyc of the customers which
come to their banks so in the demo we
will see when a customer walks into the
initiating bank will do the kyc for a
customer enter its details and verify it
and if any subsequent bank wants to use
the kyc done by another bank he or she
needs to take the permission of the
customer and then he can use the same
kyc for verification so we will see how
can we do that so just to start off with
we have developed a kyc
solidity contract
which has all the necessary functions in
order to do the actions required for
doing a kyc of a particular entity by
the bank now once this contract is ready
we will be placing it in our sample
truffle package so this is my truffle
package and in this i have the contracts
folder in the contracts folder i have
kept my kyc dot solve file
now in the command prompt i will
compile my contracts
we can ignore the warnings
so here is my ganache client which i
have just started and in my ganache
client as you can see it is running on
port 8545 and it has already given me 10
accounts pre-funded with 100 ether now i
had already mentioned that my truffle is
connected to localhost 8545. so now when
i'll do my truffle migrate command it
will connect to my ganache and deploy my
kyc contract so now i can go to truffle
console and for me it's very important
to see at which particular address my
solidity contract has been deployed i'll
copy it and in my
ui code under root jscontractdetails.js
i will make the change of this address
where my contract has now been deployed
now after doing these steps my
application is ready to interact with my
solidity contract which is being
deployed on my local blockchain network
now as you can see when i deployed the
contract this is my primary account from
which the ethers were deducted in order
to deploy the contract now there are
certain steps in order to get the
application up and running so first we
need to sign up the banks
so suppose i say bank one and the
password should be the first address of
the bank so basically we are associating
one bank with one account which we have
on our ethereum network so we will sign
up now bank one is successfully
registered so our i now in order to
login i can check
now bank one i have logged in now i need
to do add a kyc for a particular
customer
now after filling the basic details i
will create the customer and the
username i have kept is customer1
ideally this is the unique identity of
the customer it can be any social
security number or the idhaar number or
any unique identity which is attached to
the customer or the email id and can be
used as the unique identifier for the
customer now once customer profile is
successfully created we need to login as
a customer to allow this bank to see the
kyc details now suppose if i say
customer 1 and search it it is saying
access denied and take the permission
from customer to proceed so
before the bank can do the kyc complete
the customer need to approve it so i am
creating the credentials for the
customer
now customer can see his details
whatever were filled by bank one and he
can see that there is a request from
bank one to allow to view his kyc now
before we allow i will also create
another bank bank 2 and associate it
with my another address
and try to log in with it
now bank 2 is also logged in now bank 2
has not done the original kyc right but
it is trying to look up and its access
is also denied so it needs to explicitly
take permission so the bank will take
explicit request from the customer
so now the customer has requests from
bank one and bank two for the kyc it is
up to the customer whether he or she
wants to allow and deny the kyc request
after the permission has been granted
then only the banks can be able to view
the kyc so if i say bank one allow and
bank to deny
now all the requests are done from the
queue so bank 1 was allowed and bank 2
was denied so if i again log in with
bank 1
and the password is my first address
view kyc customer 1
so here it is the bank 1 is able to see
the details now if i log in as
bank 2 and give password and try to see
the it is saying permission denied so
let's
ask bank 2 to again request
now bank 2 is now again a question and
now this time it allows
now bank 2 can see the details so all
these transactions in the back end are
happening on the blockchain network
which is interfacing with the contract
through its subsequent methods now the
primary details of the contract are in
the contract details.javascript where we
have to provide the address at which the
contract was deployed the abi file the
abi so you can get the abi at here this
is the avi and you can paste it here and
this is the binary data
which has to be
pasted over here so the binary data can
be fetched
from remix
this is the binary data for the contract
it has to be copied and pasted over here
now with these essential inputs provided
our application allows us to interact in
a decentralized fashion to access the
kyc records of a particular customer now
we can modify
the details also
and we can add a new customer again so
this is a basic demo of how a typical
kyc application works in a banking
environment so hey thanks for coming
back to explain how blockchain work now
let's talk about the features of
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger it uses a hashing encryption to
encrypt all the information on the
blockchain it uses proof of work
consensus algorithm for a consensus
mechanism and it works with the concept
of mining in order to reward the miners
for keeping them and maintaining the
sanity of the network and finally about
how you can implement blockchain in a
banking system so we talked about how to
implement a kyc based blockchain
decentralized app and how it allows you
to create a decentralized banking system
where a kyc done by a one bank can be
leveraged by another bank and the
customer does not have to go through
multiple kyc iterations with each and
every bank whom he or she wants to
transact with now we will get a little
deeper into blockchain and today we will
talk about these topics we will talk
about what is a candidate block we will
talk about byzantine fault tolerance
which was one of the earlier consensus
mechanisms then we will talk about the
problem of if we have to add two blocks
at the same time then how does
blockchain handles that then we will
talk about the concept of forking what
are soft forks what are hard forks and
other areas where blockchain is getting
used what is the future of blockchain
and what are the upcoming blockchain
jobs and the profiles which are upcoming
in the market and then in the end we
will do a quick demo on how to create a
smart contract and deploy it for a
particular use case now before a block
can be mined a miner has to make a very
important decision which transactions
would be added to his block so before
transactions are added to the blockchain
they are collected in a temporary
container called a memory pool the
miners select transactions from the
school and they put it in a temporary
block called candidate block so
basically the candidate block is a
temporary block which a miner hopes to
add to a blockchain it's a candidate to
be added to a blockchain so the
candidate block holds transactions that
the miners select from the memory pool
the miner then tries to be the first
person to find the nonce value that
satisfy the hash requirements now the
question comes if someone in a
blockchain wanted to input the wrong
data by spreading wrong information
around would he or she be able to get
away with it and that's why we had
something known as byzantine fault
tolerance so in order to maintain the
sanity of the network and to have the
correct consensus there was something
called as byzantine fault tolerance
consensus algorithm to understand this
you need to know what the byzantine
general's problem is so let's imagine a
byzantine general and three other
lieutenants need to take over this town
however they are at different places and
can't directly communicate with each
other so here we have the general and
his three lieutenants the general has to
ensure that all lieutenants follow the
same order he or she gives them to
attack or to retreat now this has to be
ensured even if one of the lieutenants
is a traitor so this is the byzantine
general's problem that how does the
general communicate the correct decision
which he has taken to all his
lieutenants in his network irrespective
if someone is a traitor in this case a
twitter could ruin the unity of the
group by sending different messages to
different lieutenants now here we can
see that general is giving all his
definings the command to attack the
traitor could ruin this by sending every
other left hand the command to retreat
the opposite now in this suspicion the
traitor would make others believe that
the general asked them to retreat so as
we can see the left in end in brown is
the traitor and he could communicate to
other lieutenants the wrong information
and make them act on his behalf as a
traitor in themselves now this would
cause the lieutenants to retreat and the
generals attacked to fail so how do we
tackle this the only way an attack or a
retreat will be successful is by having
a majority supporting that particular
action to achieve this the lieutenants
keep a tally of the orders they receive
so in this scenario the general sends
the attack order to each of his
lieutenants the lieutenants in turn
collect the order they receive and pass
it on to the left-hand end near to them
so each left-hand end will pass this
order to the nearest left in it the
traitor also will do the same but sends
the retreat order to the other left lens
however this will not be successful
because each lieutenant now has a
majority of attack and minority of
retreat so this shows that the majority
of the left lanes would follow the
general's command and the attack will be
successful the scenario i mentioned
before is byzantine fault tolerance now
the same station can be encountered in
blockchain as well the traitor would add
invalid transactions into the blockchain
the trader would send the inconsistent
information to other nodes in a
blockchain this would affect the
reliability of blockchain network
blockchain are able to achieve byzantine
fault tolerance with the help of proof
of work let's see how it is effective it
is effective because the process of
adding a block to a blockchain is a work
intensive process which involves a
hashing algorithm the process is very
hard very computative because it is
heavily reliant on value obtained from
the existing blockchain to have any
meaningful impact the hacker would have
to take a lot of time resources
producing sufficient proof of work
interesting imagine if you and i were
miners and we both add a block to the
blockchain at the same time how do we
handle such a situation so although this
does not happen very often there is a
way to decide whose block should be
added to the blockchain in an ideal
scenario you just need to be the first
one to find the hash value you need to
be the first miner to generate that hash
value and win the block so adding two
blocks at the same time the hash value
of the block only needs to be within the
predetermined limit if the generated
hash value is less than the target then
the value is accepted and the block is
added to the blockchain but if it is
greater than the target then the value
is denied and the block is not added to
the blockchain but in this case if two
people have obtained a satisfactory hash
value at the same time so minor one and
minor two were able to find the hash
which was less than the target then what
will happen whether minus one block will
get added to the blockchain or minus two
block will get added to the blockchain
now fifty percent of the network has
accepted minus one block and suppose
rest has accepted minus two blocks so
half of the network continues to work
considering miners one block to be the
right block and the other half network
continues to work considering minus two
block to be the right block however only
one minus blockchain can be allowed to
remain we cannot have two blockchains
running it will defeat the purpose now
this is achieved by selecting the sub
chain to which miners have first added a
block so suppose miner 3 adds a new
block to miners 1 blockchain this block
now added by miner 3 is verified by
everyone in the network it is then
accepted as the dominant blockchain and
is used by everyone else in the network
the other version of the blockchain the
miner two is completely discarded and
the entire network now accepts miner
one's blockchain and we have now a
single blockchain existing now this
suspicion is also called an accidental
fork so i heard about a version of
bitcoin called bitcoin cash what's the
difference between them there are other
kinds too like bitcoin gold and bitcoin
private these are all outcomes of a fork
so what is a fork a fork is said to have
taken place when a blockchain diverges
into two potential parts a fork happens
when the users of a network cannot come
to an agreement with regards to a
network's transaction details and the
new rules to validate those transactions
so there are two types of forks which
can exist either it can be a software or
it can be a hard fork a software occurs
when a change in the software protocol
makes new blocks added to the blockchain
following the new rules but are backward
compatible but in order to have a
software it requires a majority of the
users to commit to that change to be
successful so a soft fork could have
multiple uses it could be for tighter
rules it could be for cosmetic changes
addition of new functions but not
affecting the structure so consider the
scenario where the accepted block size
is to be reduced from 1 mb to 100 kb so
first of all it has to be approved by a
majority of the network now the old
version will be running on 1mb block
size but once approved the new version
will start working on a block size of
100 kb so anything which is less than
100 kb will be approved and will be
added to the new block so over time
people following the older version of
the blockchain would be forced to move
to the new one since none of the
transactions would go through so
basically people using the old
blockchain they will be using the 1mb
block size their transactions will not
succeed and they will be forced to use
the 100kb block now let's talk about
hard fork a hard fork involves a change
in the software protocol so radical that
it forces a new blockchain to be created
altogether so basically in a hard fork
there will be two versions there will be
one blockchain that hasn't upgraded and
there will be a blockchain that has
upgraded according to the new software
protocols both these blockchains will be
considered valid and legitimate the new
path would follow new updated rules
while the other one keeps following the
old path so the old one will not be
discarded and will remain into existence
now bitcoin performed a hard fork on
first august 2017 which created bitcoin
cash so thereby both bitcoin and bitcoin
cash remain existent now bitcoin cash
was different from regular bitcoin
because it increased the block size from
1 mb to 8 mb so thereby it helped
reducing the transaction cost
significantly lesser than that of the
original bitcoin network now other than
with bitcoin where else is blockchain
used the other areas are for preventing
voter fraud blockchain helps in ensuring
that there is only one vote per person
ensuring that the data is not being
tampered with or any false alterations
are done it helps creating an immutable
ledger to record the votes as tallied so
once a transaction or a vote is recorded
it cannot be modified it is also used in
quality assurance ensuring the products
are of highest quality being able to
identify problem areas easily so where
do you think blockchain is going to be
used in the future so blockchain is
seeing wide range of adoption amongst
organizations as of now only one percent
of all organizations have begun using
blockchain technologies but this
percentage is expected to increase in
the next five years or so then there is
a need for blockchain regulations the
rules and regulations surrounding
blockchain are not very clear for
organizations to be comfortable using it
and move towards faster adoption also
there's a need for removing this
negative speculations surrounding
blockchain several industries fear that
blockchain will disrupt their normal
functioning and believe that the
adoption of a blockchain system isn't
worth the effort and there is an
increase in job opportunities for
skilled personnel so as the technology
is maturing they would be a huge
requirement for individuals who can
understand and implement the concepts of
blockchain so what options do people
have for jobs involving blockchain at
the moment there are many job
opportunities but the two most famous
ones are blocked in architect and
blockchain developer blockchain
developer is a profile which requires
designing implementing and supporting a
distributed blockchain network analyze
user requirements design technology
around a certain business model to build
and launch a blockchain network
blockchain architect profile requires to
design and architect blockchain industry
solutions creates blockchain networks
leveraging blockchain technology
platforms produce high quality code
based on project requirements
conceptualize design and build
blockchain frameworks and assets so
let's have a quick demo on how to deploy
a rating smart contract and have
decentralized application running on a
local blockchain network we will be
using truffle and solidity to build this
application so in order to build this
application we should have installed
truffle and ganache on our local system
so this is a ganache client which is
running on my local host it is running
on port 8545 and network id 5778
whenever you run a ganache client it is
preceded with 10 accounts and 100 ether
balance now this is my movie rating app
and in this app i am going to deploy a
smart contract called rating.soul which
is gonna capture the ratings for a
certain set of movies which i'll
pre-define and the users will be able to
set the ratings on a blockchain network
in a decentralized fashion and we will
be able to see that in every transaction
a block is getting generated in my
ganache client so in my
movie rating app under the rating folder
i will run the command trough compile
and it will compile my smart contract
rating dot soul now the next command
which i have to run is trough migrate
now at this instance the trough migrate
command will deploy my smart contract on
my ganache client so if you see there
are four blocks which have been created
and my contract was created in this
transaction and this is the address of
the contract at which my contract is
deployed so i can go back to my command
prompt and say truff console and check
the address of my
contract so this is
0x695 which is this address now when i
deployed my smart contract i had given
the entry of deployment in a file called
deploy contract.js
under rating migrations and in that i
had given this entry i had given the
path to my rating solidity file and i
had initialized my smart contract with
three movies star wars avatar and
inception and given some predefined
guess now once these steps are done and
i know the address at which my contract
is deployed i will copy that
and paste it
in the file of ethereum setup.js which
is lying under my rating app ui source
folder and i'll just change this address
now once this rating address is changed
i have to go back to my movie rating app
folder under app ui i have to give the
command npm start
now my application is up and running on
localhost 3000 and as you see i'm able
to do the voting and at each rating
level
my block is gonna increase block 6
inception block 7 and as and when my
rating is increasing a block is getting
added so this demonstrates the usage of
truffle and ganache in order to build
your decentralized app hyperledger and
its importance
hyperledger
hyperledger is an open source
collaborative effort created to advance
cross-industry blockchain technologies
it is a global collaboration hosted by
the linux foundation including leaders
in finance
banking internet of things
supply chains manufacturing and
technology
it is a framework to create deploy and
maintain blockchains for businesses that
ensure accountability transparency and
trust among business partners
as a result hyperledger makes business
networks and transactions more efficient
concept of hyperledger
now before i tell what hyperledger is
let me tell you what hyperledger isn't
hyperledger isn't a blockchain a company
or a cryptocurrency
hyperledger is a software used to create
one's own personalized blockchain
service
it is basically a project within the
linux foundation just like several other
projects under them which include nodejs
all join
dronecode and akumos
since it is open source people across
the globe can come and help develop and
grow the platform
restrictions in public blockchain with a
goal in mind to develop an
enterprise-based blockchain platform
developers started testing interactions
between applications and secure
blockchains and realized that public
blockchains require each peer to
validate transactions and run consensus
this is a major challenge when it comes
to scalability moreover the transaction
confidentiality and privacy was also
getting lost as every node in the
network was receiving a copy of the
ledger
private and confidential contracts
let's consider an example a certain bank
is giving better privileges to its
premium customers for instance in credit
cards
thus if i am a premium customer of the
bank and have been banking with them for
quite some time then it will give me a
better offer on credit cards or will
give me a loan at discounted rates these
things are common in the banking world
however if these banks start using
public blockchains which have complete
transparency disparity like these will
become evident
moreover there is an issue with regards
to competition
all banks are competing with each other
in order to create a better place for
themselves in the market
thus they want their confidential
information about transactions and other
operations to stay completely
confidential
this won't be possible in a public
blockchain like ethereum which stores
all smart contracts on public ledgers
this is where platforms like hyperledger
come into the picture which permits
permissioned and private transactions
and it is highly scalable as a platform
solution to the restrictions
on hyperledger network only parties
directly related to the transaction deal
are updated on the ledger thus
maintaining privacy and confidentiality
hyperledger primarily leverages the
concept of channels to ensure privacy
and confidentiality
a channel is basically a virtual
blockchain network which sits atop a
physical blockchain network and has its
own access rules
they employ their own mechanism for
transaction ordering and thus ensures
scalability thereby permitting effective
ordering along with the separation of
data
in the above example when john and cat
are conducting a transaction a private
channel between them serves as a method
of interaction
the smart contract can thus be viewed by
only these two parties and the network's
endorsement policy verifies their
membership with the network to ensure
privacy thus the transaction is secured
and private and confidential
hyperledger transaction
in the above example john is initiating
a transaction to send a message to cat
let's assume that we have a state in the
ledger named as message denoting the
last message that had been sent and its
store as a key value pair in peer of
organization
now john has decided to send a new
message to cat and submit a request to
the node.js backend from the message
dashboard the node.js sdk client takes
this new proposed state and sends a
proposal to all the endorsing peers of
the organization as per the endorsing
policy defined in the channel
configuration as well as confining to
the membership services
this includes a proposal request to
invoke the corresponding function
described in the chain code the message
thus gets verified by the order and
finally gets committed to the couchdb
thus confirming the transaction
linux family
hyperledger is a part of the umbrella
project under linux foundation where a
community of developers work on open
source projects
linux foundation provides infrastructure
services events
training and financial resources for
creating sustainable open source
ecosystems
linux foundation is known for its open
source projects
hyperledger is a consortium of
organizations
it's not a blockchain platform
with hyperledger there are different
blockchain projects
the original code for these projects was
submitted by various companies like ibm
intel etc
linux then made these codes open source
to invite the entire community to work
together and contribute to the codes
the vision was to create an enterprise
level blockchain platform hyperledger
projects
hyperledger umbrella strategy
hyperledger nurtures a lot of blockchain
frameworks and technologies under the
umbrella strategy some of the well-known
projects under hyperledger are as
follows
lake
hyperledger sawtooth is a blockchain
platform implementation which builds
deploys and runs distributed ledgers
it is a modular platform which provides
a digital record without a central
authority or implementation
it is primarily used for supply chain
networks
fabric
hyperledger fabrics framework was
contributed by ibm
fabric works as a foundation for
developing applications with a modular
architecture the framework utilizes
container technology to host smart
contracts chain code comprising the
system's application logic one of the
examples where it is used is fishing
industry to track the supply chain of
fishes
boro
hyperledger burrow hosted by the linux
foundation is a blockchain framework
implementation
the framework was contributed by monax
and co-sponsored by intel
burrow is a permission smart contract
application engine partially developed
in accordance to the specifications of
ethereum virtual machine evm
it is used to run ethereum smart
contracts
eroja
hyperledger eroja hosted by the linux
foundation is another blockchain
platform implementation
the framework was contributed by sora
mitsu hitachi
ntt data in kulu
written in c plus plus hyperledger eroja
incorporates a unique algorithm on
chain-based byzantine fault-tolerant
consensus
it provides a small set of fast commands
and queries covering most common
operations for the digital asset and
identity management
it can be used in mobile application
organization
indie
hyperledger indie is a distributed
ledger and utility library built for
decentralized identity
the distributed ledger provides tools
libraries and reusable components to
create and use independent digital
identities based on blockchains they are
inoperable across administrative
applications domains and any other silo
it is used as a decentralized identity
database
sawtooth
hyperledger sawtooth is a blockchain
platform built for enterprise use where
the design focuses on maintaining the
safety of smart contracts and the
ledgers are kept distributed
sawtooth offers a simplified platform
for blockchain application development
by separating the application domain at
the core system level
application developers could opt for a
language of their choice to write smart
contracts logic
following are some of the key features
of sawtooth
application layer in core system
separation parallel transaction
execution
pluggable consensus algorithm
private networks with sawtooth
permissioning features
ethereum contract compatible with seth
event system
hyperledger architecture hyperledger
blockchain network participants
following are the different participants
within hyperledger blockchain
blockchain user
a blockchain user performs transaction
on the network
the user can invoke a function from the
chain code in order to send the
instruction message to the underlying
network which can then process the
transaction
certificate authority
the certificate authority ensures that
only certain restricted parties can be a
part of the business network on
hyperledger they access security
certifications in order to determine the
parties who have required privileges to
be an actor on a network
traditional database
it is a standard database which is used
to store data
traditional processing platform it
stores access to the logical code
written which is used to run the network
as per the design
blockchain development network
it operates the blockchain network which
enables the execution of smart contracts
chain code as well as various
transactions that take place between the
participants which are part of the
network
blockchain developer
a developer develops applications on the
blockchain using chain code currently
hyperledger fabric supports node.js
java and golang languages to write such
chain codes
regulator
regulator runs oversight to ensure that
the platform is operating without any
bias
hyperledger architecture
following are three main components of
hyperledger membership service
it is a set of cryptographic materials
certificates that defines organization
by itself
every peer and orderer needs this type
of certificate
this certificate has some common
property by which we decide whether the
peer and the orderer belongs to the same
organization or not
a peer which is a part of the same msp
can communicate with each other a peer
from other organizations cannot be
allowed to communicate with each other
blockchain and transaction layer
this layer constitutes the core code of
the blockchain it comprises of consensus
algorithm which is required to make the
final decision on the state of every
transaction
it also contains the distributed ledger
and ledger storage which stores the
entire history of the transactions and
the last known states
lastly we have the pdp protocol which is
used for communication between different
nodes on the network
chain code it is the logical programming
layer which consists of the business
logic required to run an operation on
the hyperledger permissioned blockchain
and its consensus model permissioned
blockchain maintains an access control
layer and allows certain actions to be
performed only by a few identifiable
participants it is also called private
blockchain
following are the properties specific to
permissioned blockchains
it has legally accountable validators it
is suitable for off-chain assets they
can be used as an i.t tool for
settlement and clearing examples include
ripple which determines roles for a
select number of participants who can
act as transaction validators on their
network
such blockchains are also popular among
industry level enterprises and
businesses for which security identity
and role definition are important
permissioned versus permissionless
blockchain let us see some differences
between a permissioned and a
permissionless blockchain
one in regards to access a permissioned
blockchain only allows pre-approved
members to access the network and make
transactions to it whereas a
permissionless blockchain allows anyone
to be a part of the network as it is
completely open and transparent
two
permissioned blockchain are faster than
permissionless blockchain when it comes
to performance as they have less number
of participants in the network
three
permissioned blockchain use different
types of consensus algorithms like pbft
proof-of-stake and more
usually permissionless blockchains rely
on proof-of-work
4. the transaction cost in a
permissioned blockchain is lower than
that of a permissionless blockchain
five in regards to stability
permissioned blockchain are considered
more stable compared to permissionless
blockchains as the former have a better
governance due to known parties which
are a part of the network
six
in a permissionless blockchain all
participants have the same level of
access whereas a permissioned blockchain
provides full access only to the members
which are registered to be a part of the
business network
7.
permissionless blockchains work in a
peer-to-peer fashion relying solely on
consensus algorithms to create a trusted
environment however permissioned
blockchains have trusted members as part
of the network which enhances the trust
on the network consensus and its
interaction with architectural layers
consensus
consensus is the process by which a
network of nodes validates the block of
transactions and provide a guaranteed
ordering of transactions and validating
those block of transactions that need to
be committed to the ledger consensus
must ensure the following in the network
confirms the correctness of all
transactions in a proposed block
according to endorsement and consensus
policies
agrees on order and correctness and
hints on the results of execution
depends on smart contract layer to
verify correctness of an ordered set of
transactions in a block hyperledger
makes use of the permissioned voting
based consensus from the pool of the
other consensus named the lottery-based
consensus
consensus properties
consensus must satisfy two properties to
guarantee agreement among nodes
safety and liveness
safety means that each node is
guaranteed the same sequence of inputs
and results in the same output on each
node
the algorithm must behave identical to a
single node system that executes each
transaction atomically one at a time
liveness means that each non-faulty node
will eventually receive every submitted
transaction assuming that communication
does not fail
activities performed to reach consensus
hyperledger frameworks reach consensus
by performing two activities transaction
ordering transaction validation
by logically separating these activities
we ensure that any hyperledger framework
can work with any hyperledger consensus
module
the first step of the consensus process
flow is receiving the transactions from
the client application
consensus depends on an ordering service
to order transactions
transaction order enables
confidentiality of the transactions
it also increases the efficiency of the
transactions
to validate transactions consensus
depends on the smart contract layer
because it contains the business logic
behind what makes a transaction valid
transaction validation contains business
logic to make the transaction valid
it also ensures the confirmation of
policies and contracts specified for the
transaction then it also checks for
syntax and logic errors
consensus model for permissioned
blockchain
consensus in hyperledger fabric as seen
in the image above is broken out into
three phases
endorsement
ordering and validation
endorsement is driven by policy e.g m
out of n signatures upon which
participants endorse a transaction
ordering phase accepts the endorsed
transactions and agrees to the order to
be committed on the ledger
validation takes a block of ordered
transactions and validates the
correctness of the results including
checking endorsement policy and double
spending
as soon as a new transaction is created
it is sent to the endorsement peer to
generate a read write pair the read
write pair from every endorser is then
sent to the order which orders the same
and generates a block based on consensus
the ordered block is then sent to the
validator to update the couch db with
the most recent state
api and network topology in hyperledger
api it enables clients and applications
to interface to the blockchains
hyperledger supports the following types
of apis
admin apis
this class creates an administration
connection to a hyperledger composer
runtime the connection can then be used
to
deploy business network definitions
undeploy business network definitions
update business network definitions
send a ping message to the runtime to
ensure it is running and correctly
configured
story connection profile document in the
connection profile store
common apis
they are used to obtain information
about the connected networks
this information can include business
network
metadata
enum declaration and many more
runtime apis
these are used to perform all
transaction operations like running a
query managing assets and more
network topology
network topology is a technical
infrastructure that provides smart
contract services and ledger to
applications
listed below are the components of
network topology
ledger
a ledger consists of two distinct parts
a blockchain and the state database
unlike other ledgers blockchains are
immutable in contrast the world state is
a database containing the current value
of the set of key value pairs that have
been added modified or deleted by the
set of validated and committed
transactions in the blockchain
smart contract a smart contract is a
code that is invoked by a client
application external to the blockchain
network it manages access and
modifications to a set of key value
pairs in the world state
in hyperledger fabric smart contracts
are referred to as a chain code peer
nodes
it is a network entity that maintains a
ledger and runs chain code containers in
order to perform read write operations
to the ledger
peers are owned and maintained by
members
ordering service it is a defined
collective of nodes that orders
transactions into a block
the ordering service exists independent
of the peer processes and orders
transactions on a first come first
served basis for all channels on the
network
channels a channel is a private
blockchain overlay which allows for data
isolation and confidentiality
a channel specific ledger is shared
across the peers in the channel and
transacting parties must be properly
authenticated to a channel in order to
interact with it fabric certificate
authorities hyperledger fabric ca is the
default certificate authority component
which issues pki based certificates to
network member organizations and their
users
the ca issues one root certificate to
each member and one enrollment
certificate to each authorized user
steps to create a hyperledger network
following steps should be followed to
create a hyperledger network
step one create a network the network is
created from the definition of the
consortium including its clients peers
channels and ordering service
the ordering service is the
administration point for the network
because it contains the configuration
for the channel within the network
step two
define a consortium a consortium is
comprised of two or more organizations
on the network
consortiums are defined by organizations
that have a need for transacting
business with one another and they must
agree to the policies that govern the
network
step 3
create a channel for consortium
a channel is a means of communication
used to connect the components of the
network and or the member client
applications
step 4
join peers to channels
peers are joined to channels by the
organizations that own them and there
can be multiple pure nodes on channels
within the network
step 5 install smart contracts
smart contract chain code must be
installed and instantiated on a peer in
order for a client application to be
able to invoke the smart contract
step six optimize the network
while there is no theoretical limit on
how big a network can get
as the network grows it is important to
consider design choices that will help
optimize network throughput stability
and resilience
step 7
add another consortium definition
as consortia are defined and is added to
the existing channel we must update the
channel configuration by sending a
channel configuration update transaction
to the ordering service
step 8
add a new channel
organizations are what form and join
channels and channel configurations can
be amended to add organizations as the
network grows
when adding a new channel to the network
channel policies remain separate from
other channels configured on the same
network
step 9 add peer and join it to multiple
channels
you can continue adding new peers and
connect them to several channels within
the network
network topology
the diagram above shows a fabric network
with the following configuration
there is a fabric network in
with network policy np1
and ordering service 0
channel c1 is governed by channel policy
cp1
channel c1 has been established by
consortium rarb
channel c1 is managed by ordering
service o and peers p1 and p2 and client
applications a1 and a2 have been granted
permission to transact on c1
client application
a1 is owned by organization ra
certificate authority ca1
serves organization ra
pure p2 maintains ledger l1
associated with channel c1 and l2
associated with c2
prp2 makes use of chain code s4 and s5
the orderer nodes of ordering service 0
are owned by organization rd
meet frank and daniel
one day they decide to go for a trip to
venice they made a budget list for all
their expenses like residence flight etc
they thought of making their bookings
online from a site that offered
discounts to the first 10 visitors on
that day
while making their respective flight
bookings daniel's transaction failed and
he missed the offer going on
on the other hand frank paid his share
very quickly and easily and became one
of the three lucky draw winners
daniel was surprised and asked frank how
he could make the transaction when
daniel himself could not
to which his response was it's simple i
used bitcoin a type of cryptocurrency
daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
frank stepped up and explained to it
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 by
satoshi nakamoto
daniel felt that it sounds similar to
other online payment options yes what
makes it so different
frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference
which means it is not issued and
controlled by any government or central
authority unlike other payment systems
that banks or governments are handling
and that's why a cryptocurrency
transaction never fails there could be
many reasons for why daniel's
transaction failed like he may have
exceeded his transfer limit for his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or maybe due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank
but on the other hand cryptocurrency
charges almost no or very low
transaction cost
there is no limit for making
transactions
in fact you have 24 7 access to your
money there is no extra delay or extra
charges on making international
transactions and the best part is that
anybody can use cryptocurrency without
the hassles of paperwork all you need to
do is create an account on any digital
wallet of cryptocurrency this is what
makes cryptocurrency different from
other online payment options
daniel was impressed by cryptocurrency
but he wondered how it works without the
control of an external authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital ledger that is distributed
across the entire network meaning the
data is replicated and stored on each
node across the entire blockchain
network making it more secure and
impossible to change hack or cheat the
system
then it is verified and validated by
every node to proceed with the process
of making the transactions
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives
now daniel was completely aware of the
whole technology and concept behind
cryptocurrency and was influenced by
frank to adopt cryptocurrency in his
daily lifestyle too
he did that by booking his ticket but
sadly no discount
like daniel cryptocurrency has
influenced and impacted an enormous
number of people worldwide
due to this increasing popularity new
companies like metoo and paypal are
coming forward and investing in
cryptocurrency every day
in 2018 malta an island located in the
mediterranean sea south of italy was
titled blockchain island as it led to
the economic stability of the nation
many fintech companies like binance and
ok x have already begun to take
advantage of malta's financial
incentives and have moved their
headquarters to the blockchain island
so here is a question for you
which hashing algorithm does
cryptocurrency use
a
script
b
ethash
c sha 256 d
none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
cryptocurrency is revolutionizing
finance and banking around the world
thanks to cryptocurrency now anyone with
an internet connection can trade spend
and borrow money around the world
and nobody can stop them
people like bill gates co-founder of
microsoft corporation and elon musk ceo
of tesla support cryptocurrency as it is
much better and secure than physical
money and also holds a great future for
the world's economy
and on the other hand some people think
of cryptocurrency as a bane to the
world's economy like warren buffett ceo
of berkshire hathaway and ajay benga ceo
of global mastercard feel that
cryptocurrency is a platform of criminal
activities and will destroy the world's
economy
well one thing is clear that this
conflict is going to stay put for a
little longer
welcome to this session of blockchain
wallet now before these blockchain
wallets came into existence what were
the means in order for us to do the
transactions and what were the drawbacks
in the old days the transactions with
whatever medium and channels we had the
problems were that the transactions were
slow and banks were the central point of
failure basically any transaction which
has to go through has to go through some
intermediary channels and has to pass
through certain intermediaries like bank
which makes them a single point of
failure also there are issues in keeping
track of all accounts and balances data
get jeopardized manipulated or even get
corrupted across multiple systems where
the accounts and balances are maintained
now here comes into existence what is
called as blockchain wallet now what is
blockchain wallet a blockchain wallet is
a cryptocurrency wallet that allows
users to manage different kind of
cryptocurrencies for example bitcoin
ethereum etc now a blockchain wallet
helps exchanging of funds easily
transactions are secure as they are
cryptographically signed the wallet is
accessible from web or mobile devices
and the privacy and identity of the user
is maintained so therefore a blockchain
wallet provides all the features which
are necessary for a safe and secure
transfer and exchange of funds between
different parties a blockchain wallet is
a typical cryptocurrency wallet that
allows users to manage cryptocurrencies
it is very similar to the process of
sending or receiving money through
paypal or any other gateway which you
use today but now you can use
cryptocurrency instead similar to paypal
which you're using for making
transactions with your fiat currency now
let's take a look at the ecosystem of
blockchain wallets here are certain
examples like electrum blockchain.info
jaxx mycelium samurai and bitcoin paper
wallet these are just to name a few
blockchain wallets which are existing in
the market but there are many more based
on the requirement you have based on the
security you require and based on the
kind of wallet which suffices your need
so we will see what are the
categorizations of these kind of wallets
are now how do blockchain wallets work
let's take a look so before we move on
to how blockchain wallets work let's
understand what a private and a public
key is and how are these keys related to
a blockchain wallet now whenever you
create a blockchain wallet you are also
provided a private and a public key
which is associated with your wallet now
let's take an example in order to
understand this imagine a person knowing
your email address is sending you an
email so in our regular day-to-day
activity if we want to receive an email
from someone we give him or her our
email id and expect an email from them
now what if an unknown person is able to
send emails through my account so i am
giving my email address for receiving
email but when i am disclosing my email
id i am not assuming that someone will
be able to send emails through my
account because then for that he has to
be aware of my email account password so
knowing your email address will not give
a person the ability to send an email
from your account you are not giving
your password to the person to send an
email you are just giving the email
address to send an email from a
particular email address an individual
has to be aware of the password
associated with it now blockchain wallet
follows a similar process using public
key and private key both together public
key is similar to your email address so
basically whenever your wallet is
generated a public key is generated you
can share that public key with anyone in
order to receive funds private key is
top secret it's similar to your password
it should not get hacked or you should
not disclose it to anyone and you use
this private key to spend your funds so
now instead of sending an email imagine
you want to transfer money to your
friend this transfer process is done
through your blockchain wallet with
blockchain wallets you can now send and
receive cryptocurrencies so as i said a
blockchain wallet has two keys a public
key and a private key public key is
shared with everyone just like an email
address private key is just like your
password which should be kept secret
with the sender so with blockchain
wallet no one will be able to send
crypto coins just like emails through
your public key until they know your
private key but if someone gets access
to your private key there is a high
possibility that your account is hacked
and you might end up losing all the
cryptocurrency deposits in your account
now let's take a look what are the
typical features of a blockchain wallet
it's easy to use it's just like any
other software or a wallet which you use
for your day-to-day transactions it is
highly secure it is just a matter of you
securing your private key and it allows
instant transactions across geographies
barrier-free without intermediaries and
also these transactions charges you low
cost fee and these wallets help you do
transactions across multiple
cryptocurrencies so you can make
payments across cryptocurrencies so
which helps you do easy currency
conversions now let's talk about what
are the different type of blockchain
wallets now basically there are two
types of blockchain wallets based on the
private keys one is hot wallet and
another is the cold wallet hot wallets
are like normal wallets which we carry
for day-to-day transactions and these
wallets are user-friendly cold wallets
cold wallets are similar to a vault
where cryptocurrencies are stored with a
high level of security now let's take a
look at the differences hot wallets are
online wallets through which
cryptocurrencies can be transferred
quickly they are available online on
internet example coinbase
blockchain.info cold wallets they are
digital offline wallets where the
transactions are signed offline and then
later disclosed online so they are not
maintained on the cloud on the internet
they are maintained offline to have high
security and the examples of cold wallet
are trezor and ledger now in case of hot
wallets private keys are stored in the
cloud for faster transfer in case of
cold wallets private keys are stored in
a separate hardware which are
disconnected from the internet or the
cloud or are stored in a paper-based
document hot wallet they are easy to
access available online 24 7. it can be
accessed through desktop or mobile but
has a risk of unrecoverable theft when
hacked cold wallets this method of
transaction helps in protecting the
wallet from unauthorized access from
hacking and other online vulnerabilities
now the wallet can be further
distinguished on these criterias there
can be software wallets they can be
hardware wallets which are like kind of
usb driven and you plug into your usb
drive and your hardware wallet can be
used or they are a typical paper based
wallet where you print your public key
and a private key on a paper and keep it
in a secure place so let's talk about
software wallet a software wallet is an
application that is downloaded on a
device either it could be a desktop or a
mobile or it could be a web-based wallet
which can be accessed online now here
are certain examples dax bread wallet
and copay are the popular software
wallets so software wallet can be
further categorized into desktop wallet
online or we can call it web wallets or
mobile wallets now desktop wallets are
like cold wallets in which the private
keys are stored in cold servers
basically the desktop wallets the
private keys are stored in your desktop
you can unplug it from the internet do
some offline transactions and then bring
it back online now in case the main
server is lost then a cold server
basically a desktop is used as a backup
server these wallets can be downloaded
on any computer but can only be accessed
from the system they are installed on so
you make sure the desktop or the machine
on which you i have downloaded the
desktop wallet is safe has a backup
you're maintaining the hardware you're
not letting the machine go anywhere and
it is on a secure location now these
wallets are definitely cost efficient
and one of the examples is electrum and
is one of the most popular desktop
wallet online wallets are the other kind
of hot wallets that run on the cloud
that are available on the internet now
here users have the benefit of accessing
these wallets across any device it could
be tablet desktop or you can use it from
your mobile browser the private keys are
stored online and are managed by a third
party you have to be dependent on a
third party service now for example
green address is a bitcoin wallet which
is available on the web has an android
app is available on a desktop and also
is available on ios apple mobile wallets
mobile wallets are like similar to
online wallets except that they're built
only for mobile phone usage and
accessibility these wallets are also
user friendly and they have a
user-friendly interface for which helps
you in doing transactions easily the
example is mycelium which is the best
available mobile wallet hardware wallet
hardware wallet is a type of cold
storage device typically like a usb
which stores the user's private key in a
protected hardware device these wallets
are similar to portable devices that can
be connected to the computer can be
plugged in as i said earlier it is less
prone to malware attacks malicious
attacks and it is hack proof examples
are nanoledger trezor and kiki are the
top hardware wallets available in the
market to make a transaction from your
hardware wallet you have to ensure the
hardware wallet is plugged into your
computer system before you can do a
transaction from your hardware wallet
paper wallet a paper wallet is an
offline process for storing
cryptocurrencies this wallet is a
printed paper consisting of both your
private key and a public key which are
accessed using a qr code now since these
wallets are safe they are widely used
for storing large amounts of
cryptocurrencies now for example our
bitcoin paper wallet and myetherwallet
are one of the widely used paper wallets
but the question arises how do i add
cryptocurrency in my paper wallet in
order to make a transaction with your
paper wallet paper wallet works with
your software wallets the online wallets
to transfer funds from your software
wallet to the public address shown on
your paper wallet so basically first you
park your funds in a software wallet
then you transfer the funds from your
software wallet to the public address
printed on your paper wallet now let's
do the comparison blocked in info
blockchain info is a cryptocurrency
wallet which supports bitcoin and
ethereum it is easy to use and has a low
transaction fee it has its apis exposed
you can easily use them to order to make
your own custom wallets also ledger nano
ledger nano is a hardware wallet which
offers a high security to your account
it is available for bitcoin ethereum and
litecoin users it is also possible to
maintain multiple accounts and access
them anytime bitcoin paper wallet paper
wallet helps you to print your own
tamper resistant bitcoin wallet it
minimizes the threat of hacking jacks
jax is a software wallet which enables a
user to exchange currencies within the
wallet it is available for bitcoin
ethereum litecoin and many other
cryptocurrencies with jax a user can
view his updated balance as soon as the
processing is complete now let's take a
look at certain demos for the different
kind of wallets we have talked about so
let's first take an example of paper
wallet so bit address dot org provides
you a paper wallet it uses the client
side javascript in order to generate a
random hash for your wallet so you keep
moving your mouse and it will generate a
hash public and private key it is
recommended that when you are doing this
process you should be disconnected from
the internet and once these keys are
generated you can print it and keep it
secure and clear the cache of your
browser so as you can see on the screen
this is my public key for receiving my
bitcoins and this is the private key for
me to spend it i can print it and keep
it handy with me but of course the
safety of these physical documents
cannot be entirely guaranteed if a
hacker discovers the location of your
paper wallet and physically steals it
then they can access your bitcoin
holdings so basically it is of high
importance that you keep the paper
wallet in a very very secure location
some users hide or disguise the paper
wallet it should be protected from
physical damage if the keys fade or can
no longer be scanned then the user will
never again be able to access the
bitcoin which are parked in that address
also take care if you are using an
incorrect type of printer that also may
damage the paper wallet
now let's take a look for our second
example of online wallet here we are
taking an example of bitpay so you can
download bitpay online and create your
account over here
you can create a personal wallet you can
create a shared wallet or a joint share
wallet once you create a wallet like if
you see the example over here this is my
personal wallet and i have 3.645
test bitcoins over here
now in order to receive test bitcoins in
my account you can receive these test
bitcoins from testnet dot coin faucet
dot eu's hyphen in
now in order to receive it you just need
to
copy your bitcoin address
in the testnet address
so the test net has given me 0.87
bitcoin so now my balance has increased
from 3.5 to 3.64 and i can see this
transaction
see three minutes ago i just received
0.87228
bitcoin the transaction is still in
process but in a while as this
transaction is getting mined on the test
net i will receive it now as i have
received it i can even make a
transaction and send it to someone so
from my personal account i can send
bitcoin to
someone whose bitcoin address i have and
i have to just paste it over here
transfer to bitcoin wallet either i can
select one of my own wallets or i can
search for any other bitcoin address
which someone has shared with me and i
can send it to that particular address
now let's take an example of our
hardware wallet how does hardware wallet
works with the online wallet so here we
have metamask which has a feature of
connecting with hardware wallet so once
you have metamask installed you will see
this option of connect hardware wallet
now metamask has provided support for
trezor so now once you connect your
hardware wallet the usb with your
computer you can select an account you
want to view on that particular hardware
wallet and you can only choose one at a
time and then you can start using that
particular wallet for your decentralized
apps so basically once you have your
hardware connected it is integrated with
your meta mask and then you can start
running your decentralized apps so that
they can start using the tokens or the
currency in the particular hardware
wallet so use your hardware account like
you would with any ethereum account log
into dapps and send ethereums buy and
store erc20 tokens and non-fungible
tokens like cryptokitties so if you
click connect to trezor over here
metamask will start looking out for the
connected trezor device now what is
bitcoin bitcoin is the first
decentralized digital currency that
allows users to transfer money
peer-to-peer without any intermediaries
like banks governments agents brokers
nothing is involved and all this is done
using blockchain technology so as we saw
in our previous example two parties
wants to exchange money transfer money
they don't need an intermediary now
bitcoin can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument and it can
be primarily used for payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009 it came into existence by a person
or a group of people called satoshi
nakamoto now bitcoin helps transferring
of assets faster than regular fiat
currencies it has definitely lower
transaction fees because as it has
removed the intermediaries from between
the cost of transaction also goes down
and it is cryptographically secure it
uses cryptography infrastructure and
thereby the identities of the sender and
the receiver are also secure and entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the users information who are doing
the transactions or are part of the
networker is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to
counterfeit or hack the transactions
which are running on a bitcoin network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions or
charging a fees in order to validate the
transaction it is the participants in
the decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information is accessible to public it
is available publicly on a public ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the bitcoin network and it
is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other mediums and
channels through which today digital
transactions are made now what is
blockchain so bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger in which transactions made in
bitcoins or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it is
cryptographically secure signed using
your private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized authority or the body and
the transactions are stored in
containers aggregated in containers
called blocks so a block is the smallest
unit of a blockchain which records all
the transaction a basic structure of a
block is something like this it has four
fields these are the primary attributes
for block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block
nonce so in proof of work consensus
algorithm which is used in bitcoin nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the output of the hash value so every
block is supposed to generate a hash
value and nonce is the parameter which
is used to generate that hash value and
the proof of work is the process of
transaction verification done in
blockchain now hash is the resultant
hash value obtained by passing the
previous hash value the data and the
nonce through the sha-256 algorithm to
generate the hash of this block so this
is the digital signature of the block
which is generated and this is the
basically identity of this block now
sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
bit alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographic algorithm
whatever input you give it will always
produce a 256 bit hash now let's
understand the concepts of bitcoin miami
what is bitcoin mining bitcoin mining is
the process of verifying bitcoin
transactions and recording them onto the
public blockchain ledger in blockchain
the transactions are verified by bitcoin
users so basically the transactions have
to be verified by none other than the
participants of the network those who
have the required hardware and computing
power and those entities are called
miners so we will be talking about them
later but the point to be highlighted is
that there is nothing like a centralized
body as in case of legacy transactions
where we used to be dependent on a
regulatory or governing body or a bank
to make our transactions go through now
in bitcoin here any user with mining
hardware and internet access can take
apart that kind of computer can be a
participant and contribute to the mining
community process is solved based on a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work so every miners job is to
solve the mathematical puzzle which is
called proof of work in order to
validate the transaction and earn the
reward and all the miners as they are
competing amongst themselves to mine a
particular transaction the miner who
first solves the puzzle gets the reward
now users trying to sell the puzzles as
i said are called miners they are the
participants in the network who have the
necessary hardware and computing power
to do all the transactions to validate
the transactions and validate it they
are called as miners now in order to
understand bitcoin mining we need to
understand three major concepts of
blockchain it is based on distributed
public ledger it uses sha-256 encryption
algorithm and proof of work is the
underlying consensus algorithm for
bitcoin mining so distributed public
ledger a distributed ledger is a record
of all transactions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by bitcoin users
called as miners sha-256 now blockchain
prevents unauthorized access by using a
hash function called sha-256 to ensure
that the blocks are kept secure they are
digitally signed their hash value once
generated cannot be altered now seq 256
it takes an input string of any size and
returns a fixed length 256 bit output
value and that is the primary feature of
shf 256 encryption algorithm you give
any input it will always give you a 256
bit output and it is a one way function
you cannot derive the input reversally
from the output what you have generated
and third is the proof of work in
blockchain mining is a process to
validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now in order to do that
the primary objective of the minor is to
determine the nonce value and that non
value is that mathematical puzzle that
miners require to solve in order to
generate a hash which is less than the
target defined by the network for a
particular block now in the bitcoin
network users trying to solve
mathematical puzzle are called as minus
now the puzzle is solved by varying a
nonce which produces a hash value lower
than a predefined condition which is
called as a target miners verify the
transactions and add the block to the
blockchain when confirmed and verified
as of today the miners who solve the
puzzle gets a reward of 12.5 bitcoins
now once a block is added to the
blockchain the bitcoins associated with
the transactions can be spent so once
the block is validated then the transfer
of bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block the
transfers are made then from one account
to the another now in order to generate
the hash let's see you use the sha-256
hashing algorithm you define the hash
value if it is less than the defined
condition the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved and if not then you
keep on incrementing nonce value and you
repeat the sha-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
define generate the hash value again and
you keep doing this process till the
time you get the hash value which is
less than the target now let's check an
example so for example beyonce wants to
share 10 bitcoin with jennifer now in
order to do that what will be the steps
so beyond transaction data is shared
with bitcoin users the miners from the
memory pool the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of unmined
transactions so in a memory pool set of
unmined or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool now miners
competing to validate the transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the unconfirmed
transaction pool they pick up those
transactions and start validating those
transactions they aggregate in a data
block and start validating they start
solving the puzzle the miner who solves
the puzzle first shares his result
across the other nodes the other set of
miners now once the block has been
verified the nonce has been generated
then the nodes will start granting their
approval if maximum nodes grant their
approval the block becomes valid and is
added to the blockchain now
simultaneously the miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
bitcoin which as of today stands at 98k
around dollars now the bitcoins the 10
btc for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred from beyond to
jennifer now let's take a look at
certain facts in proof of work a
predefined condition the target is
adjusted for every 2016 block which is
approximately every 14 days and an
average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash target of
the first block divided by the hash
target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify by
the miners so once you have solved the
puzzle and you have broadcasted that yes
you have earned you have validated a
record you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority then
the block gets validated and gets added
to the blockchain now since the
difficulty depends on the hash target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block as i said and as you can see
in due course from the day of inception
of bitcoin in 2009 till today difficulty
has increased exponentially and it has
been increasing and thereby the entire
effort of mining and the computing power
is also increasing so as of what was the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of blocks abc now
each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to tamper a block block b and
tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if the data
of the block will change the hash value
which is the digital signature of the
block will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it basically the blocks ahead of block b
will all get dealing because the
previous hash value of block c will not
remain valid so in order for the hacker
to make the entire blockchain valid for
the block b which he has changed he has
to change the hash value of all the
blocks ahead of block b which will
require huge huge amount of computing
power which will be next to impossible
so as you see the results in the
following block being invalid so with
this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non-hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying hardware requirements for
bitcoin mining and how the hardware is
evolved so in the early days miners used
to solve the puzzles using regular
processors the controlling processor
unit cpus now but it used to take a lot
of time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as i said the
difficulties level keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so this
discovered that graphical processing
units gpus proved to be more efficient
than regular cpus so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any miner who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today they are using a
hardware called asic application
specific integrated circuit which was
specifically introduced for mining which
consumes less power and has a higher
computing power and a better hardware
for mining so miners are profitable when
their cost of resources to mine one
block is less than the price of the
reward they receive so definitely they
have to have the investment less than
the reward what they own so as of today
in blockchain miners use their resources
to verify a transaction they each time a
block is mined new bitcoins are created
in the network so the bitcoin total
supply is limited it is at 21 million
dollars approximately 21 million bitcoin
are in supply 17 to 18 million bitcoins
have already been mined so only three to
four million are left as of today a
reward of 12.5 bitcoin is given to the
miner on doing the transaction
verification but the bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle the
reward given to a miner is half every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so then after that
threshold is reached the bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 bitcoins so let's
take an example of a lottery ticket
where your chances of winning is
difficult so we are talking about what
is bitcoin mining pool your chances of
winning the lottery is difficult but in
a community if individuals buy multiple
lottery tickets and pool their tickets
together then this will increase their
probability and chances of winning more
so suppose you won the lottery then
based on the contribution the reward is
distributed among all the participants
bitcoin mining pool is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together to mine a
block now when a block is solved the
miners split the reward equally based on
the amount of processing power they have
invested so it takes the pool members to
generate a final hash value then it
checks how much amount of work was
contributed by each pool member and as a
result the bitcoin reward gets
distributed proportionally amongst the
participants now let's take a look at a
demo on how can you see what is the
bitcoin reward now this is a actual
block of the bitcoin network as you can
see this is a block and
this is the block reward 12.5 bitcoin so
this was a block which was mined
this is the block number and
these are the set of transactions which
were part of this block now once this
block was mined by the miner all these
transactions then be done these are the
transfers of bitcoin from one account to
the other this is the nonce which was
generated by the miner or the mining
pool in order to mine the block and
these are the other attributes
and if you take a look at this url this
is an example of a mining pool it's a
demo account where the participants have
shared their mining resources and they
are mining it in a pool and see this is
the reward for which they are mining
this is the unconfirmed reward this is
the confirmed reward this is what they
have already validated and this is what
they have earned so far
so these are the hash these are the
block numbers which they have mine
ethereum and its concepts
ethereum
simply put while bitcoin is defined as
digital money ethereum is a
decentralized platform that runs the
smart contracts exactly the way they are
programmed without any downtime
fraud and third-party interference and
also has its own cryptocurrency called
ether
ethereum aims to enable innovations in
three key areas
currency assurance through ether which
serves as an innate currency for the
ethereum blockchain decentralized
autonomous organization
smart contracts
features of ethereum
the first feature of ethereum is that it
is secure because it is almost
impossible to tamper with the
transactions in the block or to add any
fraudulent blocks in the network
the second feature of ethereum is its
community following ethereum has
attracted a lot of attention from people
all over the world
the third feature of ethereum is its
corporate friendly structure
the platform is being leveraged by a
number of corporates to test and build
various applications
the fourth feature that we will take a
look at is the possibility of creating
new assets on ethereum blockchain that
can be used as currency a representation
of an asset
a virtual share
a proof of membership or anything at all
the next feature is the ability of
ethereum to process the transactions
fast
while bitcoin requires a block time of
10 minutes in ethereum it's only a few
seconds
the last feature that we will discuss is
the fact that ethereum is uncensored
ethereum's open source network allows
complete transparency to view every
transaction
alright that's all about the features of
ethereum let me tell you about an
important concept in ethereum called gas
gas in ethereum
gas is the fundamental block of ethereum
ecosystem that is paid for every
operation performed on the ethereum
blockchain
it is the crypto fuel for ethereum
it can be considered a transaction fee
which has to be paid when one party
sends ethers to another party
even when a person deploys a smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain a
transaction fee needs to be paid for
that as well this payment has to be made
regardless of whether the transaction
succeeds or fails
gas price is expressed in ether and the
miner decides whether to refuse the
transaction process or not based on the
expected gas price
one can see their transaction fee in eth
or usd when searching for the
transaction on etherscan.io
when somebody refers to gas they are
either talking about gas price or gas
limit
the total cost of a transaction is the
product of gas limit and gas price
the gas limit is defined as a limit
since it's the maximum amount of units
of gas one is willing to spend on a
single transaction
this avoids situations where there is an
error somewhere in the contract and you
end up spending a very high amount of
gas
however the units of gas required for a
transaction are defined by the amount of
code executed on the blockchain
lowering the gas limit below the amount
required will not help much
if enough gas to cover the computational
resources of the network is not supplied
with the transaction
the transaction will fail due to an out
of gas error
so
gas is a commodity which is essentially
a cost of using the system
like bitcoins ethereum also has its
currency which is called ether
ether
it is an incentive that the client of
the platform pays to execute requested
operations
it ensures that the developers write
error-free codes because unnecessary
codes will increase the cost
ethereum is a blockchain-based platform
and ether
is the cryptocurrency that fuels the
platform it is commonly denoted as eth
let's have a look at the differences
between bitcoin and ether
bitcoin versus ether the first
difference is in the hashtag algorithm
used by these cryptocurrencies
while bitcoin uses
sha-256 to encrypt blocks of blockchain
ethereum uses eth to encrypt blocks
technically both are one-way
cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
bitcoin and ether
as we have discussed earlier bitcoin is
only used for financial transactions
like purchase and sale of goods and
services however
ethereum being a touring complete
platform also supports smart contracts
and decentralized applications
the third difference is in the price of
the two cryptocurrencies
currently the price of btc is
approximately 3 500 u.s dollars while
that of eth is approximately 100 u.s
dollars
the market cap of btc is almost six
times greater than that of btc even
though eth has a higher circulating
supply
the fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two
cryptocurrencies
btc is a currency created to compete
against the gold and flat currencies by
acting as an alternative however eth is
created as a token to facilitate smart
contract deployment and operations
lastly the transaction speed of btc is
much slower than eth
while btc's transaction speed is
measured in minutes eth is just a few
seconds
like bitcoins ethers are also stored in
cryptocurrency wallets
let's understand what are wallets in
ethereum
ethereum virtual machine
ethereum wallets a wallet is the place
to securely store ethers and other
cryptocurrencies
basically a wallet stores the means of
accessing your currency using the
private key
now that i have told you about the
ethereum and its currency
it will only be fair that i explain evm
now
evm
ethereum virtual machine abbreviated as
evm
is an engine which executes translation
code
smart contracts are compiled into byte
code which an evm can read and execute
the ethereum virtual machine can be
regarded as a quasi
complete machine
it possesses its own programming
language known as the evm bytecode
once the code is written in higher level
programming languages the code can be
compiled to an evm byte code
the ethereum virtual machine uses a set
of instructions called opcodes to
execute specific tasks thus if a user
triggers a transaction of 5 eth using
his desktop wallet the wallet sends the
message to the evm which connects with
the wallet address on the ethereum
network to process the transaction and
send it to the receiver
smart contracts are written in ethereum
specific programming languages
let's learn more about these languages
ethereum languages
every contract written for ethereum is
compiled into the evm bytecode and
deployed to ethereum blockchain for
execution
ethereum uses the following languages
the first language is solidity
solidity is an
object-oriented high-level language used
for implementation of smart contracts on
the ethereum blockchain
solidity was influenced by python c
plus and javascript
it is designed to target the evm
the second language is a low-level lisp
like language
abbreviated as triple l it is one of the
original ethereum smart contract
programming languages and is similar to
assembly
it is meant to be a very simple and
minimalistic language essentially
serving as a tiny wrapper over coding in
evm directly
the third language is viper which is a
contract oriented programming language
influenced by python the fourth language
is serpent which is an assembly language
that compiles to evm code that is
extended with various high-level
features
the next language is mutant
mutant is similar to c like language and
supports a dynamic
full higher level language
it compiles to native ethereum assembler
however mutant is now deprecated
the last language is julia
it is an intermediate language that can
compile to various different backends
like evm 1.0 evm 1.5 and
ewasm
let me now tell you about the accounts
handled by ethereum
types of ethereum accounts
externally owned accounts
eoa is an account controlled by a
private key that has the ability to send
ethers and messages from it
following are some of the properties of
an externally owned account
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no associated code
smart contract
smart contract is a code running on top
of the blockchain
containing a set of rules for the nodes
to agree upon so that they can interact
with each other as an account it has the
following properties
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it has an associated code
thirdly a code execution is triggered by
transactions or messages received from
other contracts
and fourthly when executed it performs
operations of arbitrary complexity some
of the advantages of smart contracts are
as follows
first smart contract is the simplest way
of implementing decentralization
second it provides a high degree of
security
third it eliminates the need for a third
party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement
fifth it turns legal obligations into an
automated processes and lastly it lowers
the transaction cost
characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self-verifying and
self-executing
they operate autonomously to execute the
terms of the contract and verify the
transactions without the need of a
third-party intervention
the elimination of third parties reduces
the cost of operations and further makes
the contracts tamper resistant
process of smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works
first
an optional contract between the parties
is written as a code into the blockchain
the individuals involved are anonymous
but the contact is made through a public
ledger then a trigger event like an
expiration date or a strike price is hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms
next regulators can use the blockchain
to understand the activities in the
market while maintaining the privacy of
an individual's position let me show you
the implementation of smart contract in
a simple use case
contract example
here we have an example showing the
purchase and sale of a house thus once a
buyer is matched with a seller all
assets are sent into the contract
the contract then distributes the assets
based on certain predetermined
conditions agreed between both parties
and coded into the smart contract
thus the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes undisputed due to the
transparency of blockchain
eoa versus smart contract
in this slide we will understand the
difference between an eoa and a smart
contract based on four critical
properties
nonce
in an externally owned account nonce
represents the number of transactions
sent from the account's address
however in a contract account the nonce
is the number of contracts created by
the account
the next property is balance
this number shows the amount of whey
owned by the address whether the eoa or
contract account
each ether is divided into 1e plus 18
wei
the next property is code hash it is the
hash of the ethereum virtual machine
code of an account this is the code that
gets executed if this address receives a
message call
it is immutable and thus it cannot be
changed once the construction is done
for externally owned accounts the code
hash field is the hash of the empty
string for contract accounts this is the
code that gets hashed and is stored as
the code hash
the last property is storage root it is
a 256 bit hash of the root node of a
merkle tree that encodes the storage
contents of the account encoded into the
tree as a mapping from the keycap 256
bit hash of the 256 bit integer keys to
the rlp encoded 256 bit integer values
this tree encodes the hash of the
storage contents of this account and is
empty by default
that was all about the ethereum concepts
and accounts
let's understand the process of mining
now
ethereum mining
ethereum mining
ethereum makes use of proof-of-work
mechanism to ensure security
the algorithm used in ethereum is called
ethash
each time an ethereum transaction is
made a miner is responsible for ensuring
the authenticity of information and
updating the blockchain with the
transaction
let's consider an example where bob
wants to send one each to alice
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process that is followed in
order to confirm this transaction
through mining
first bob attempts to send alice 1 eth
once bob's transaction is initiated it
is combined with other transactions that
have occurred in the last block
the miners will then validate the block
with a new set of instructions
once validated the miner creates a new
block and is rewarded for it
thus
alice receives one each after the
transaction is validated
ethereum mining
the term transaction is used in ethereum
to refer to the signed data package that
contains a message to be sent from an
eoa to another account on the blockchain
ethereum blocks contain two things a
transaction list and a recent state of
the ledger that comprises these
transactions
in the example shown on the screen we
can see a transaction where one wallet
sends 20 eth to another wallet the
diagram shows the previous state and the
next state for the transaction
state storage
the states are assembled into a state
tree that is linked to the account and
the block
the ethereum includes state routes that
store the root hash of the hash tree
which represents the system state when
the block was created
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process to see how ethereum
stores transactions
first a hash is generated for each
transaction
then pairs are selected and a hash is
generated for each pair
this way the last remaining hash becomes
the root
the block header as seen in the image on
the screen contains the previous block
hash and three merkle trees these trees
are to maintain the state
to maintain the transactions and to
maintain the receipts
also each block always refers to its
previous blocks hash
ethereum ecosystem
types of ethereum tools
the ethereum ecosystem consists of eight
major tools
they are
geth
ganache
parody
metamask
missed wallet
sporm
ipfs
whisper now let's move forward and take
a look at each of these in detail
geth
geth is a multi-purpose command line
tool that runs an ethereum node
implemented in go it is the official
golang implementation of the ethereum
protocol and is commonly used to
interact with the ethereum network
though there are several ways to
download geth the fastest one is to get
it from the ethereum.org website
next we have ganache cli
ganache cli
ganache cli is a customizable and fast
emulator for blockchain which permits
making calls to blockchain without the
need for running an actual ethereum node
following are some of the properties of
ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost
thirdly accounts can be recycled reset
and instantiated with a fixed number of
ether without the need for faucets or
mining
fourthly gas price and mining speed can
be modified
fifthly a convenient gui gives you an
overview of your test chain events
parity
parity is the fastest lightest and most
secure ethereum client that provides the
core infrastructure essentials for quick
and reliable services
parity is written in rust language it
offers better reliability
code clarity and performance
it is an ethereum client that is
integrated directly into your web
browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of basic ether and token
wallet
it also serves as an ethereum gui
browser
it provides access to a diverse range of
ethereum features including d apps
meta mask
metamask turns google chrome into a
browser that allows the users to send
and receive transactions and also fetch
data from the blockchain
it is a browser-based wallet which can
be added as a plug-in to your chrome
browser
it permits you to run ethereum d apps
directly from your browser without the
need for running a full ethereum node
metamask accounts
practically it is unrealistic for
everyone in the world to run a node to
interact with the ethereum blockchain
to overcome this metamask hosts a number
of nodes so you don't have to
a user simply needs to install metamask
and can automatically get connected to
the nodes
thus you can use the ethereum blockchain
seamlessly
let's talk mist which is another
important tool of the blockchain
ecosystem
mist wallet
mist wallet is the end user interface
for ethereum that is developed for
browsing and using d-apps
mist is an official ethereum wallet it
was developed and distributed by the
team which is responsible for the
management of ethereum ecosystem it is
usually used by developers who want to
create deploy and use smart contracts
it is a full node wallet which means
you'll have to download the entire
ethereum blockchain onto your computer
some of the applications of missed
wallet is as follows
first sending and receiving transactions
second
storing ether
third creating multi-signature wallets
and fourth deploying smart contracts
swarm
swarm is a platform which supports
distributed storage and provides content
distribution services
it acts as a native base layer service
of the ethereum web 3 stack
it provides sufficient decentralization
and redundant storage of ethereum
records to distribute blockchain data as
well as the app codes
it leverages the underlying ethereum
infrastructure through the use of
contracts and ethers to encourage
cooperation among nodes
the files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nodes of the network an
accounting protocol is used by peers to
keep track of these chunks delivered and
received and resulting micropayments
associated with it
ipfs
ipfs is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to ethereum
but can be integrated with it
ipfs stores data by use of a distributed
hash table or dht
once we know the hash we request the
peer network who has a copy of the
content located at the corresponding
hash
and then we download the content from
the node who has the desired data which
we need
the data transfer between the nodes in
the network uses a mechanism which is
similar to the one used in bittorrent
it also provides a versioned file system
capable of storing files and tracking
versions over time
thus it defines how files move across a
network making it a distributed file
system by combining all of these
properties ipfs is enabling a new
permanent web and augmenting the way we
use existing internet protocols like
http
whisper
whisper is an identity based
communication protocol for d apps to
interact with each other
d apps that need to publish small
amounts of information to each other and
have the publication last some
substantial amount of time prefer using
whisper for instance
a d app running a currency exchange may
use whisper to record an offer to buy a
currency at a pre-agreed price on the
exchange platform
some of the drawbacks of whisper are as
follows
it has low level api which is only
exposed to d apps and never to users
second it has low bandwidth and is not
designed for large data transfers
third it has uncertain latency
and lastly it has no reliable methods
for tracing packets
ethereum frameworks
we'll look at two types of ethereum
frameworks
web3.js
web3.js is a set of libraries which
permit one to interact with a remote or
local ethereum node it can be done with
the use of ipc or an http connection the
key connection between ethereum network
and dap that allows you to compile
deploy and interact with smart contracts
is called web3.js
it gives us a way to build a website or
client that can talk to the ethereum
blockchain
let's take an example of traditional
development
when you develop a website it talks to
apis using json or jquery to make ajax
calls
a website talks to blockchain using web3
using json.rpc
which is similar to making a remote
procedure call
ethereum comprises of a large number of
nodes which talk to each other
we use
jsonrpc to make a request to a
particular node which is like an api
call
thus if we want to talk to a smart
contract or read an account we do it
through web3
ethe.js
it is a highly optimized lightweight js
utility for ethereum based on web.js
in this all the unnecessary characters
are removed from the source code and the
code is reduced to 160 kilobytes
ethereum development environment the
three commonly used ethereum development
environments include
remix ide
truffle
and embark
let's understand these environments in a
little more detail
remix ide
remix ide is a browser-based compiler
and ide that enables users to debug
transactions and build ethereum
contracts with solidity language
you can simply log on to the web-based
editor write the code and compile the
same to create the byte code in order to
test your code
the next slide shows how remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle
truffle is a development environment
testing framework and asset pipeline for
blockchains using the ethereum virtual
machine or evm
it helps users in developing smart
contracts
publish the contracts and test them
then we have embark
embark embark is an environment that
allows you to easily develop and deploy
decentralized applications
it performs the following functions
first automatic deployment of contracts
second keeping track of deployed
contracts third
managing the complex systems of
interdependent contracts
fourth
performing test driven deployment with
contracts using javascript
fifth
managing different chains like testnet
private net and livenet and lastly
redeploy the contracts if any changes
are done
let's talk about ethereum networks
ethereum network
the basis for decentralized consensus is
the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes which maintain and
secure the blockchain
a node is defined as a device or a
program that can communicate with the
ethereum blockchain network
they are also referred to as clients
they provide wallet functionality and
allow users to perform transactions on
the blockchain
thus a node serves as a machine running
as an ethereum client
it is used to store the data and
transfer money it is formed by combining
one or more nodes and each node contains
a copy of the blockchain
types of network there are three main
types of networks the testnet the main
net and the private network
ethereum d-apps and daos
d-app
decentralized application is an
application that is used on networks
with trustless protocols to avoid a
single point of failure
they run on a peer-to-peer computer
network all the activity which takes
place on an ethereum decentralized
application is cryptographically secured
on the blockchain
d-apps are open source which means that
everyone can verify the contents of the
software
some properties of d-apps are as follows
it uses ethereum as a development
platform
it uses cryptographically encoded blocks
it is not governed by a central server
and there is no master copy of d-app
let's talk about the advantages of
d-apps now
advantages of d-app
ethereum d-apps have the following
advantages
improved stability due to a distributed
network
higher reliability
automatic credentials assigned through
smart contracts
no downtime
no third party intervention
and high security
example of d-apps
some of the known examples of d-apps
include we fund
storage
kyc chain
and 4g capital these companies have
developed different applications using
blockchain
next we have the daos
dao
daos or organizations designed to hold
assets and use the voting system to
distribute them they exist entirely on
blockchain and are governed by the
consensus protocols
they show the potential of blockchain to
revolutionize human social institutions
called daos
it is an organization run by rules
agreed through a consensus process among
its members and written in a set of
contracts run via a blockchain
it is an open source software capable of
modification by its members
process of a dao
now let's take an example and see how
this works
let's consider that a country is holding
elections and wants to prevent fraud in
the voting system a dao is created to
keep transparency in the voting
this is insured by embedding predefined
conditions in the code
people eligible to vote are assigned
voting tokens and the voting starts
every vote is processed on the ethereum
blockchain and it ensures transparency
by allowing everything to run in a
decentralized way
in this video we will explore ethereum
mining and will go through some of the
fascinating concepts and components
revolving around it
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secured in the network
ether is the cryptocurrency of ethereum
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
ether basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network it tracks and
facilitates all the transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple words ethereum mining is a
process of creating and adding a block
of transaction to the blockchain network
of ethereum
it uses the proof-of-work consensus
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network needs to get approved
by the miners
miners is a community of people using a
hashing script etas to solve
computationally hard puzzles for
successfully mining the blocks are
transactions in the ethereum blockchain
network
which helps secure the network from
attacks like hacking or manipulation of
identity
now let's understand why you need to
mine ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money a data mining contract of
sectoring the network into a relatively
complex but profitable business
also miners receive a certain amount as
a reward for mining each block of the
ethereum blockchain network
including the transaction fees paid by
the users
thus italian mining benefits each and
everyone participating in ethereum
blockchain network
so
what are the types of ethereum mining
material mining can be performed in
three ways ethereum solar mining
ethereum cool mining and aquarium cloud
mining
in ethereum solar mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mind that item block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies you have to be very
good at your work
also solo mining is only profitable when
you have plenty of resources with you
like 100 plus graphics cards
and in solo mining having so much
equipment may leave a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of air needed
italian coal mining is the easiest and
fastest way to get started with itaria
mining
in this you walk along with other people
together in a single pool
and if someone from the pool gets the
hash code correctly they share the
reward among everyone in the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool life goal
size minimum payout and goal fee
school size determines the number of
blocks we find in the ethereum network
and it shares rewards
as the number of miners increases the
chances to get rewards also increase
minimum payout is the minimum amount of
iteration you need to mine before it
gets credited to your wallet
and safety is the amount you need to pay
to continue using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum you're mining
iterating cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you
you pay some amount of money as peace to
them for investing their time and
resources
and in return they provide you with the
reward they gained by the mining
ethereum
this
this technique of mining ethereum has
some pros and cons to
suppose you're not responsible for any
equipment damage you don't have to
require all the necessary equipment and
look for ample space to store it
you can set that observe market and
enjoy the reward for your investment
interior mining
cons if the ethereum price drop then
there is no way you are getting your
money back the money you invested or the
fees paid to the miner is lost
and you can't ask the other person to
change the equipment according to your
concern
italian cloud mining is considered a
safer way for mining service providers
to guarantee a profit for the resource
they have purchased
now let's understand how the ethereum
mining process works
ethereum mining follows a specific set
of steps to function
step one a user requests a transaction
with the help of the private key of his
digital wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pending transactions that
needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 the miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction and
perform a complex mathematical puzzle on
the transaction data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified
and it stores a copy of it in india the
process of proof of work begins for the
respective blog
step 6 when the notes of the ethereum
network verify that the checksum of the
state of the miner's block matches the
checksum of the updated state of the
email after execution of all
transactions
step 7 only after that the block is
added to the italian blockchain network
step 8 on successfully mining the block
it rewards the miner with some amount of
ether in their wallet
the block reward of ethereum is 3 ether
step 9 the requested brand matching is
approved and credited to the respective
wallet or wallet
each transaction is mined only once but
every participant of the ethereum
network verifies it
this makes me curious about how to mine
ethereum
tools you will need to be an efficient
miner for ethereum on your personal
computer are an italian wallet to store
all your currency on
gpu drivers or graphics card with a
minimum of 3gb ram
a mining software suitable according to
your hardware like gpu
and a compatible operating system
windows 7 or 10 with 64 bit
before getting started with mining
iteration you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your ether
pressure model t and ledger nano are the
most reliable and secure wallets in the
market of cryptocurrency
installing gpu drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet you
need to update all the hardware
that is drives in your system
you can use two types of graphics cards
they are amd graphics card and nvidia
graphics card
claymore is considered the best
processor mining ethereum on gp drivers
now we need to follow a few
set of steps to get started with mining
step one download the latest version of
claymore dual miner for the operating
system
the latest version is claymore 11.0
step 2 click on the latest version of
windows and download the zip file
step 3. extract the files of claymore
11.0 to a folder on the desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5. right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6. edit the start.txt file and add
these lines
step 7 choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better search results
than these according to your region
step 8 type in your full address instead
of mining pool address
step nine save your start.txt file with
the new updates
remember while saving select type as all
files
and step 10 once you save click on the
clay.that file to begin mining ethereum
now let's explore will the proof of
state transition field trooper work
the newly introduced concept of ethereum
2.0 roadmaps plans to upgrade to proof
of stake
consensus algorithm in which it will
provide all existing miners of the dairy
network with a limited time to earn a
return for the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021
or the starting of 2022
it was supposed to be launched by
october 2020 but the history of delays
regarding this update is worth talking
about
nobody truly knows when ethereum 2.0
will be completed and introduced to the
crypto mining world
now we may know all about ethereum
mining this makes me wonder if ethereum
mining is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity in
that particular area
as a rule anything below
0.12
per kilowatt consumes in an hour is
considered profitable you can mine ether
and turn it into a vital source of
income by analyzing these figures like
hash rate of ethereum block reward
number of blocks per day and the coin
price of ethereum
you can also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors
or you can use this formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years so it is
an excellent opportunity to invest in
and save an ethereum now why smart
contract now let's take a look
traditionally how contracts used to
happen if suppose two parties a and b
have to get into a contract they will
utilize the services of a third party
whom they have to trust and get the
contract executed now with the
introduction of smart contracts and the
technology which is evolving removes the
dependency on such third parties and
automates the execution of such smart
contracts so if we compare traditional
versus the new smart contract in
traditional we used to have governments
lawyers or any other third party on
which we can trust in smart contracts we
don't need any third party we don't need
any intermediate execution time
definitely there's higher execution time
in traditional contracts because as many
number of middlemen and their
intermediary layers that many number of
days and time it takes smart contract is
just a matter of minutes it gets
executed because it is automated
programmable running on a computer and
it has some predefined condition
remittance if any remittance of either
of the parties have to happen then it's
a manual process approvals workflows
processes
and these manual processes take time
under traditional contracting system but
in a smart contract as the conditions
are predefined pre-embedded as soon as a
condition is met the remittance happens
automatically either of the parties who
have to be credited with an amount is
credited automatically and that is the
primary advantage of using a smart
contract transparency
is not available 100 in traditional
contracts the transparency is bound
peripheral between the parties and the
entities and the intermediaries involved
as compared to smart contract
transparency is 100 available 24x7
online anyone can go and review audit
and validate the transactions executed
by the smart contracts archiving
archiving is a big difficult problem for
traditional contracts as most of the
transactions are paper based or the
records are maintained offline it
becomes very difficult to maintain and
identify the traceability provenance of
all the transactions which have happened
in a traditional contract whereby in a
smart contract it becomes easy as all
the transactions have happened through
the smart contract there's a hundred
percent traceability available from the
provenance point of view you can trace
the transaction from its day one the
point of origin till present day and
archiving is automatically happening the
log the audit the transaction history is
automatically getting generated security
definitely is a concern in traditional
contracts as the intermediaries and
involved manual processes involved
security can be compromised at any level
at any stage but in a smart contract the
security is maintained through
cryptography mainly through public key
infrastructure the public and private
key infrastructure it is a very secure
way of maintaining security and
cryptography of the transactions using a
smart contract cost yes traditional
contracts are expensive the cost of
transaction is high as compared to smart
contracts as the middlemen are involved
smart contract the cost is low as we
don't have any intermediaries and only
the cost of transaction is charged by
the underlying infrastructure of the
blockchain network which is running the
smart contracts signatures its manual
process all the transactions are signed
manually and verified manually but here
in the smart contracts all the
transactions are digitally signed using
the private key of the entities and can
only be decoded by the public key shared
by the parties involved in the smart
contract so in a nutshell smart
contracts give us n number of advantages
the primary advantages are listed here
and these are the advantages which
enforce us to move towards an economy
and to a system where we start using
smart contracts for our transactions to
avoid any disputes to keep the
transaction cost low thereby giving the
advantage to the end consumer now what
is a smart contract let's consider a
real life example where you are taking
out a chocolate from a vending machine
you deposit a two dollar note in a
vending machine after that you hit a one
button which is mapped against the
chocolate bar that you want to buy as a
result a liver in the vending machine
moves and pushes out the chocolate so
basically even button is programmed to
the lever in order to move the chocolate
out now a smart contract is very similar
to a vending machine it eliminates the
need of an intermediary in case of the
vending machine is replacing a direct
seller and allowing you to make a
purchase without a middleman and it
eliminates the need of escrow services
now smart contracts are self-executing
contracts which contain the terms and
conditions of an agreement between the
parties and the peers who are involved
in the technique so the terms and
conditions of an agreement are written
in a piece of code and it is executed on
a blockchain based decentralized
platform now these agreements
facilitates exchange of any digital
asset it could be digital currency it
could be shares it could be property or
it could be anything which you want to
transact so a blockchain based
decentralized platform gives you a
democratic system where the transactions
are authorized by the majority of the
participants and the identity of the
participants is also kept anonymous now
let's consider an example where rachel
is at the airport and her flight is
delayed but this inconvenience could
have been beneficial to richard as smart
contract insurance would ensure she is
given a compensation for the flights
delay instantly so just imagine there is
a smart contract which the insurance
company has already deployed and it's
monitoring the flights delay rachel has
already taken that insurance for delay
in flights so as soon as that condition
is met for a delay of flight above x
amount of hours for example two hours
then in that case the insurance company
will automatically get that trigger and
rachel will be credited with that amount
for which she is insured in her account
so let's see how smart contract can be
helpful here so axa flight delay
insurance is one of the examples of
ethereum smart contract axa is an
insurance company the smart contract is
linked to the databases that record
flight status so that smart contract is
connected to the databases it is
fetching that information and evaluating
the delay it enables automatic
compensation when there is a delay for
two hours or more so that is the
condition when the flight delay is
beyond to ours then the insurance
contract will get executed and rachel
will get paid a smart contract is
created based on the terms and
conditions so condition compensation is
equal to flight delay is less than two
hours based on the code smart contract
holds the company's money until a
certain condition is satisfied this
smart contract is submitted to the nodes
on the blockchain network to their evms
for evaluation so evm is a runtime
compiler to execute smart contacts code
it is the brain it is the electronic
virtual machine which executes the smart
contract all nodes on the network
executing the code using the evm must
come to the same result because all the
evms would have the same copy of the
smart contract deployed if the flight is
delayed two or more hours smart contract
will be self-executed and the
compensation amount will be given to
rachel and that is the objective of the
smart contract without involvement of
any middlemen paperwork which rachel has
to do to submit and then the insurance
company going through the manual process
all that has been bypassed and rachel
has been compensated directly now let's
understand why do we need solidity for
developing our smart contracts now here
comes the important question which
programming language does the smart
contract use there are two widely used
programming languages for writing
ethereum smart contracts solidity and
serpent however on blockchain platform
solidity is widely used for implementing
smart contracts and this is what we were
going to talk about in our subsequent
slides now solidity is a high level
programming language used for
implementing smart contracts it enables
to check the program at runtime rather
than compile time solidity is a turing
complete language it has all the
conditions all the while loops for root
operators etc which are there in any
matured programming language in order to
write your code in order to write your
conditions if you have certain loop if
you have while conditions etc now what
are the advantages of smart contract as
we have already discussed there are no
intermediaries involved the process
executes without the need of a third
party it's an automated process they are
automated with the code which eliminates
manual effort for execution it's a high
speed highly computative smart contracts
which runs on programming code the speed
of its execution is higher than a
traditional contract as the data is
stored in the decentralized system the
chances of modifying the data is
difficult and i would say more than
impossible accuracy based on the
requirements terms and condition of a
contract is recorded accurately so as
soon as any transaction is recorded it
is registered on a blockchain network
and it is immutable transaction no one
can modify or make changes in any record
which has been added onto a blockchain
network through a smart contract now
let's take a look at certain blockchain
implementation of a smart contract using
blockchain in voting process can
eliminate voting malpractices a
centralized voting system faces a lot of
problems when it comes to tracking votes
there could be manipulated identities
there could be manipulation in counting
there could be biased decision making a
smart contract is introduced to
eliminate all these malpractices there
are certain predefined terms and
conditions which are already set in the
contract no voter can vote from a
digital identity of any other voter the
counting is full proof every vote is
registered on a blockchain network and
the accounting is happening
automatically without any interference
from a third party or dependency on a
manual process so terms and condition
each id should be attributed to just one
vote the validation is done by the users
on the blockchain network itself so the
voting process can be in a public
blockchain or it could be in a
decentralized autonomous organization
based blockchain setup also but it is
100 transparent and every voting
transaction is recorded result every
voters would get recorded on the ledger
and that information cannot be modified
it is transparently publicly available
for audit and verification now let's
take a look at one of the examples of
our voting solidity contract so here we
have our voting solidity contract it is
built in solidity and i'll just give you
a brief overview of what are the primary
functions in this so if we look at this
particular contract this contract
gives you certain basic parameters like
what should be the minimum number of
participants or proposals which are
required for voting then what should be
the minimum amount of time for debate
that needs to pass before the vote can
be executed then the margin of votes for
majority a proposal passes if there are
more than 50 percent of the votes plus
the margin so basically we are defining
what is the winning condition what is
the majority margin for any word to be
accepted then you have data structures
where you are accepting the proposals
right and then subsequently we are
defining data structures for members who
are participating in the proposals who
are submitting the proposals we are
fetching the addresses of the members
basically this is the digital identity
of the members who are submitting the
proposals and etc so the smart contracts
basically allows you to create a voting
system where you can add members we can
remove the members you can change
certain voting rules based on certain
conditions like if you want to increase
the minimum quorum if you want to change
the debating period minutes or the
majority rule changes then this is the
function for submitting a new proposal
for which the voting has to happen so
basically this example is about if i
have to take a vote within a
decentralized autonomous organization
for a particular decision so rather than
a central authority taking a decision
you can have a voting mechanism within
your organization to give a majority to
your proposal if you get the majority
the proposal is accepted otherwise
reject then there are peripheral
functions like check proposal code then
there is a voting function the actual
vote happens and for a particular
proposal you start increasing or
decreasing the number of votes then you
execute the proposal if the majority has
been achieved now let's take a look on
how to deploy a smart contract so here
we have our boating smart contract now
we will take a look on how to deploy our
voting smart contract on the ethereum
test network called robston this is our
voting smart contract now when you open
remix you should also have metamask
which is a chrome plugin installed this
is a utility in order to connect to the
robston testnet which is an ethereum
test network so basically you say
option.etherscan.io
and this is the ethereum test network on
which we will deploy our contract so
once you login into the metamask you
will have a account created and in that
account you should have some test ethers
already so that you can use them to
deploy your contract so when you create
an account on robsten you can buy
certain ethers using the robston test
faucet
so when you reach this site that option
test faucet has already taken the
address for the account for which you
are raising the request and you can
raise request of one ether now whenever
this transaction will get processed your
account balance will get incremented by
one so as i already have ethers in it i
can utilize it to deploy my contract now
in order to compile and deploy my
contract i have copy pasted it here and
if i go to my run my remix has already
communicated via injected web 3 to the
metamask and taken my account which has
7.83 ether
now i need to do some settings
now as my contract is compiled you can
see it has taken all the contracts you
can see the drop down and congress is my
major contract now i will deploy my
contract so on the run section you will
be able to see in the drop down the name
of the contracts which are there in my
smart contract like i had owned token
recipient then there's an interface and
there is a congress so i need to deploy
my congress contract now in order to
deploy this contract there is a
constructor which requires certain
inputs so i can give certain values like
what minimum number of proposals i need
hundred then minimum number of debates
10 and margin of votes for majority so i
said deploy now as soon as i'll click
deploy it is going to request me for gas
because when the contract gets deployed
it will deduct certain ethos from my
account so when i will say submit
if you notice now this transaction has
got initiated on the robsten
etherscan.io i click on that so this is
the transaction on which the contract is
getting deployed it is taking time and
the contract is getting processed on the
ethereum network now once it will get
deployed we will be able to see the
address at which the contract has got
created and deployed now as you can see
my contract has got deployed at the
address 0xcc i can load it now this is
the contract address and this is the
amount of actual ether which was spent
from my account in order to deploy the
contract
now there are certain attributes on the
option ether scan which you can go and
check you can verify and publish your
smart contract over here so that others
can also view the code and utilize your
smart contract and if you go and check
your meta mask this is the transaction
which has just been done in your account
and if you click it will take you to the
same transaction which we opened here
now after you have deployed the contract
you can interact with your contract
directly through remix just to test your
contract all the pink members are the
ones which make changes onto the
blockchain and all the blue ones are the
ones which are only performing read
operations so in order to do any read
operation you will not be requested to
spend any gas so there will be no
pop-ups for metamask requesting for gas
spending but if you do any of these pink
actions then you will be required to
spend gas as it will be requiring to
make some changes onto the blockchain so
this was a example of a voting smart
contract and this will be available as a
link for you to take a look now all our
other contracts which we will be
covering subsequently will be deployed
in a similar fashion on the robson test
net now let's take another example if we
want to use smart contract to issue your
own cryptocurrency or called digital
token you can use ethereum based smart
contract to create your own digital
tokens for performing transactions a
design and issue your own digital
currency create a tradable computerized
token that can be utilized as a currency
share or any asset which you want to
transact these tokens use a standard
coin api like in case of ethereum we
have standardizations of erc20 etc which
allows contract to automatically access
any wallet for exchange as a result you
build a tradable token with a suffix
supply and this particular platform
becomes like a central bank issuing a
digital money your smart contract
becomes the bank issuing the money so
let's take this example here so this is
a implementation of a erc20 token which
is a specification by ethereum and
the primary attribute for this token is
that you need to provide a name of your
token a symbol the decimals to which you
support and the most primary is the
predefined supply so just like in an
economy you have limited supply of money
here also you have to define what will
be the supply of your tokens and it will
be capped that will be the supply so you
need to redefine these parameters and
then you create certain data structures
within solidity to keep a tap on the
balances of the entities to which you
are giving the tokens and how much
allowance you want to keep per address
then there are certain methods which you
have to implement as per the
specification like transfer transfer
from approve and call etc so all these
methods in a typical token allows you to
do the transaction send and receive your
custom token among multiple parties so
this would also be available as a link
for you to take a look now let's take
another example of a use case for
crowdfunding using smart contracts to
crowdfund your project so suppose you
want to start a business and for a
business you need a lot of funding which
is required but who would lend it money
to someone whom they don't trust how
will you generate that money for such
problems smart contract plays a major
role with ethereum you can build a smart
contract that will hold a contributor's
funds unless a given date or a goal is
net based on the result the funds will
be released to the contract owners or
will be sent back to the contributors so
basically you can create a crowdfunding
project for yourself if you want to
raise certain amount of money and the
contributors or the investors will give
you the money but the amount will be
kept on hold till the time your project
goal or date has been met and
accordingly the investor will get you
the token which you have developed for
crowdfunding in hers or his account
accordingly now centralized crowdfunding
system has plenty of issues with
management systems so therefore a dow a
decentralized autonomous organization is
utilized for crowdfunding the terms and
conditions are transparently set in the
contract every individual participating
in the crowdfunding is given a token and
the token is credited to their ethereum
based account now every contribution
gets recorded on the blockchain because
when the token transfer has happened
from the dow to the individual investor
that transaction get recorded on the
blockchain network so let's uh quickly
take a look at the
contract for a crowdsale also so a
crowdsale contract provides you the
basic attributes like what is the goal
of the funding how much money you need
to raise what is the amount raised real
time you can keep a track what is the
deadline right and what is the price of
the token in ethereum basically what is
the your token amount in ethereum then
there could be that you might give
certain tokens in reward then you can
have attributes for your reward and then
you have your methods in order to keep a
check that once you have received the
funds you can withdraw the funds you can
check whether you have reached the goal
for funding and then you have the
methods for transferring tokens from the
sender to your own account this
particular kind of contract allows you
to maintain and keep a check on amount
of funding you have received or you want
to receive have you achieved your target
who are the investors in your token how
much percentage share belongs to your
account and how much percentage share
has been already been distributed on
amongst the investors etc so everything
can be tracked so the smart contract can
build in such a fashion that there are
methods and utilities available in order
to run your entire crowdfunding in this
video we will explore ethereum 2.0 and
will go through some of the fascinating
concepts and components revolving around
it
so what is the ethereum network
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized application
ether is the cryptocurrency for ethereum
used to build decentralized application
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
it tracks and facilitates all the
transactions and make sure they are
cryptographically secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades that will make the ethereum
network more secure scalable and
sustainable
multiple teams from across the ethereum
ecosystem have come together to work on
these upgrades in ethereum 2.0
then what led to the region of ethereum
2.0
with growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network has gotten more blocked
by transactions
currently it is capable of handling 15
to 45 transactions per second
which is comparatively impressive but it
is not enough to handle all of
ethereum's users worldwide
also the high demand is affecting the
driving up of transaction fees
nodes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently its nodes are
experiencing too much volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed that making its
nodes bigger wouldn't be practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable to handle all of the
activities on the ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.0
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of state and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations suffer from
performance issues because they rely on
a processing power intensive process
known as proof of work
to record and validate their
transactions
the problem with proof-of-work design is
that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof of stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency and
ability to scale
in the current version of ethereum
blockchain all data that is added to the
chain
undergoes verification by all
participating nodes
that means that the speed of its fluids
participant limits the processing speed
of the entire network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources by breaking data
verification tasks among its set of
nodes and each of them will be
responsible for validating and verifying
just the data allotted to them
this will increase the network's overall
capacity and make it much faster and
efficient than its outdated version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
why ethereum 2.0 has been in research
and development since 2014.
it has actually been making some
progress
the beacon chain went live in december
2020 introducing the staging concept but
still there is no official claim for the
completion of this transition
the next phase is mainnet
merging the beacon chain into the
current ethereum network
mining ethereum tokens will officially
end in this phase and staking will
become the primary way to create new
tokens in the ethereum
network the last part of the transition
is expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the sharp chains to give the
ethereum blockchain network more
capacity and efficiency to handle all of
the demand and increase transactions per
second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated and on their way to completing
the whole transition so what is the
future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0 could be a total game
changer it will create a modified
network that could potentially process
one lag transactions per second
and a much more sustainable network
without the energy intensive mining
process and it will introduce smart
contracts worldwide
increasing the ethereum's network
utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
alex buterin once said that the issuance
of new token should be highly reduced
under ethereum 2.0 which could increase
its demand
given all these factors ethereum 2.0
seems to hold a bright future for
ethereum blockchain network did you know
there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies worldwide
and among them bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world by market
cap
also recently ethereum as well as
bitcoin reached its all-time peak in
worldwide trading
according to decrypt.go everyday new
companies like metoo and paypal are
coming forward to invest in bitcoin and
ethereum
on march 7 2021 mitu confirmed that it
had purchased 40 million in bitcoin and
ethereum on the other hand people is
about to launch a scheme where the
public can purchase and sell
cryptocurrencies initially featuring
bitcoin and ethereum via paypal digital
wallet
but have you all ever wondered how they
compare based on their similarities and
differences in various aspects
well before moving any further let's
have a quick look at how bitcoin and
ethereum originated and made a benchmark
in the economic system worldwide
bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
satoshi nakamoto to resolve cyber
attacks double spending and eliminate
the middleman between the transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
on the other hand ethereum came into the
picture years after bitcoin it was first
introduced in the late 2013 by vitalik
buterin after that it was very quickly
and widely adopted because it offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized application
now let's move ahead and see the
difference between them which make them
compete with each other in this economy
this video will cover individual aspects
for comparing ethereum and bitcoin's
performance in that particular field
by time bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency however
ethereum with different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but before moving ahead let's
have an introduction to ethereum and
bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an application
for its users without any centralized
interference for bitcoin it is an
alternative to fiat money or physical
currency the main function of ethereum
is to provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using dapps or decentralized application
on the other side bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money and
value stored in its blockchain network
now let's get started and move towards
the first comparison which is algorithm
ethereum uses the etas cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network on the other hand
bitcoin uses the she-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
bitcoin network
ethash algorithm is mainly used during
the proof of work function
proof of work is a small piece of data
that is difficult to generate but easy
to validate and satisfy certain network
requirements
sag 256 algorithm helps bitcoin users to
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys moving on the programming
language of ethereum
and bitcoin ethereum uses solidity
solidity is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts but in
terms of programming language bitcoin
keeps it simple bitcoin uses c plus as
its programming language it is a stack
based programming language used to give
bitcoin software instructions on how to
make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies now let's take a look
at the mining process of both
mining is a process in which transaction
made are validated and added to
blockchain public ledger and blogs and
the people mining these blocks are
called miners
ethereum miners mine the unvalidated
transaction using the proof of work
method but it aims to switch to proof of
stake because it will make its network
more immune to centralization energy
efficient and stronger support for its
shared chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the
proof-of-work method to mine unvalidated
transactions
these method is enough to function in
bitcoin network worldwide now let's
proceed towards the monetary policy of
both cryptocurrencies but let's first
understand what monetary policy is
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the
competent monetary authority to control
the money supply and achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth so
italian's policy is defined by the
reward paid out by its protocol
ethereum's monetary policies are best
described as minimum issuance to secure
the network therefore there is a
constant trade-off between the
transaction speed and security but
bitcoin's monetary policy comprises two
parts halving and block frequency
halving event is when the reward of
mining bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block the current
block reward for ethereum is two ether
per block and for bitcoin the block
reward is 12.5 bitcoins per block
also every 14 seconds a block of
ethereum is generated and one block of
bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate
monetary policies are considered to be
fixed and non-inflationary due to this
over time mining blocks will become more
difficult next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it on the other side bitcoin's
transaction speed is 5 transactions per
second and it can take up to 60 minutes
or more to confirm either the currency
of ethereum acts as the fuel for
ethereum networks and bitcoin is only
used as the value for real-world
transaction to compete with already
present electronic cash like credit
cards and google pay it element bitcoin
require higher productivity to attain
widespread adoption not talking about
the availability of both
cryptocurrencies
ethereum is not limited but it can
occasionally reduce due to large network
upgrades however bitcoin is limited to
21 million coins and as of today 18
million bitcoin is already used
but in the end both bitcoin and ethereum
being the top crypto currencies share a
few similarities like both are
decentralized and can be used to have a
peer-to-peer transaction
proof of work also both have a large
network of independent nodes choose from
over 300 in-demand skills and get access
to 1 000 plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now let's have a demo now let's have a
look at the media outlet website
coindesk where we will see all stats
related to bitcoin and ethereum in
detail
coindesk is a site specialized in
digital currencies it is used to explore
the news and price data related to
cryptocurrencies and also explains how
cryptocurrencies contribute to the
evolution of financial system worldwide
now see this graph this graph shows the
change in bitcoin price in 24 hours
duration this graph shows the gradual
change in the price of bitcoin it
started from 64
439.29
on april 14 at 12 p.m
and right now by april 15 at 6 00 am it
is at 63 189
the rate of change is minus 0.46 percent
which shows the change in the price of
bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum 2.
the value of ethereum started at 2388.13
on april 14 at 12 p.m and the current
status on april 15 is positive with a
value of 2442.37
with an increasing rate of 4.67 percent
down below we have a metrics table that
shows the change between the starting
and ending value of ethereum the total
supply of a cryptocurrency in 24 hours
the total number of transaction that
occurred and the average transaction fee
for all these transactions now this
graph shows the current status of
cryptocurrency in usd dollars we can
also see its value according to any
centralized currency like euro or inr
this graph shows the concentrating
change in the value of cryptocurrencies
every moment
we can also access the data of trading
from an hour to its lifetime recently we
all have been hearing about a
cryptocurrency famously known as
dogecoin but what exactly makes it so
different from others that almost every
person is talking about it
so let me tell you that dogecoin is an
altcoin and an almost sarcastic meme
coin that serves as a peer-to-peer open
source cryptocurrency
well that's not enough
so let's dive down and understand the
concept of dogecoin more precisely but
before starting let's have a look at why
is it in the news since the beginning of
the year 2021 dogecoin has surged more
than 950 percent from less than half a
penny to more than five cents per doj
coin
then elon musk ceo of tesline
corporation took his interest in it and
tweeted too much concentration is the
only real issue for cryptocurrency
making the owner of the dogecoin wallet
a subject of attention later on other
celebs like snoop dogg also started
taking an interest in dogecoin and
started tweeting and promoting it on
social platforms which made dogecoin
climb to a peak of 8.2 u.s cents and
market capitalization of 10 billion
dollars in this video we will come
across the following topics first we
will see the origin of dogecoin and then
we will understand what is dogecoin how
does it exactly works
and then we will see what led to the
growth of dogecoin
what are the areas of uses of dogecoin
then we will figure out what is the
current value of dogecoin today
and lastly how can we buy it let's start
with the origin of dogecoin
dogecoin was invented by two software
engineers ibm engineer billy marcus and
adobe engineer jackson palmer did you
know that they never even met before
combining the two most significant
phenomena of the year 2013 bitcoin and
deutsche well now let's move ahead and
see what is dogecoin dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer open source cryptocurrency
that provides its user a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transaction
deutsche coin was intended to be an
altcoin and a meme coin inspired by
shiba inu's popular meme aka doge moving
ahead let's have a look at how it works
to understand the workflow let's take
the example of two friends mark and
susan
mark owes some money to susan and now he
needs to return it
she thinks of an idea and decides to
send her dogecoin instead of giving her
physical money
they both open their digital wallet
account
to pay her he needs two essential pieces
of information
first his private key
and second her public key
to get access to susan's private key he
needs to scan a qr code from his
smartphone
then the application alerts all the
dogecoin miners around the world to
proceed further with the process the
dojo and miners validate where the mark
has enough dogecoin to make the payment
or not
and after the validation process they
approve the transaction request dogecoin
miners race with each other to collect
all the data of the pending transaction
known as the nonce
the miners then apply a mathematical
function to produce the correct hash
number for the particular nonce of the
pending transaction the miner who
successfully produces the correct hash
number is rewarded with 25 dot coin in
his account
after that mark and susan gets a
confirmation message that the request
for the transaction has been approved
and within 10 minutes the requested
amount of dogecoin is credited into the
wallet of susan
thus the transaction is completed
so what led to the growth of dogecoin
dogecoin officially came live in 2013
and became an instant hit within the
community of people who just wanted to
play around the cryptocurrencies freely
as i said earlier dogecoin was intended
to be a joke for content creators but
they were very well received it uses of
internet forums like reddit and twitter
adopted dogecoin and started tipping
their content creators this usage of
dogecoin made it surpass the trading
value of the other cryptocurrencies
specifically bitcoin in 2014.
it also started doing charity work to
introduce and promote themselves in the
real world for example once they raise a
fund of 55 000
for a nascar driver josh weiss and in
return he printed the logo and 98
dogecoin over this race car eventually
it almost became the mascot for what
crypto should be let's have a look at
who uses dogecoin
today many companies and firms like
restaurants
process
web hosting
products retailer ebook sellers and
travel services uses dogecoin for
transaction
these are a few examples
of companies in every sector that uses
dogecoin
grossers hello pets gamerheats.com
for web hosting
gamer
for products retailer meltdown and
noddex
ebook seller canal
and travel services like bello leo dot
id this makes me curious about the
current value of dogecoin let's have a
look at that too
according to the market cap today the
current value of dogecoin is 0.059357
usd with a trading volume of 16 billion
dollars the circulating supply of this
cryptocurrency is 129 billion dogecoin
and the max supply of dogecoin is not
available
how can we buy dogecoin
so to buy dogecoin we will have to
follow a few steps step 1 open a digital
wallet buy you coin is considered a
perfect application for trading
cryptocurrencies step 2 register your
account
step 3 complete your profile kyc by
providing your identity and address
proof like aadhaar step 4 add your bank
account details
step 5 secure your account by creating a
convenient trading pin that is only
accessible by you
and step 6
there you go now you can start trading
that is all about dogecoin currently we
have heard a lot of buzz about the
cryptocurrency dogecoin and the
shenanigans of its community
did you know that on 20th april 2020
dogecoin searched its value to one
dollar
making this day named after itself as
deutsche
the supporters of dogecoin were trying
to amplify the value of it to make it
one dollar
but how is it done in reality how can we
affect the value and availability of
cryptocurrency
well all this is done by a process
called mining
and this is what affected torch coin
resulting in the rise of its value
mining coins of the deutsche coin
network is called dogecoin mining
so let's get started and have a quick
look at what is dogecoin
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on blockchain
technology
also it provides its users a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transactions
dosh going uses cryptography to secure
all its transactions
this makes me curious to know what is
the net worth and availability of
dogecoin today
according to market cap today the
current value of dogecoin is
0.266247 usd dollars the circulating
supply of this cryptocurrency is 120 for
mining dogecoin that makes me wonder
what the difference between dogecoin
mining and other cryptocurrencies mining
process
let's have a comparison between dogecoin
mining and the bitcoin mining process
we will be comparing these crypto mining
based on these factors
first
algorithm
it is a set of rules that every
cryptocurrency follows for mining new
coins
in the algorithm doj coin mining uses
script bitcoin mining uses she 256.
script is considered a lot quicker and
cheaper than the ssg256 algorithm making
mining easier for miners of the dogecoin
network
second is difficulty
this represents the complexities and
challenges faced by miners to mine each
block of the blockchain of any
cryptocurrency
in difficulty dogecoin is 2 798
252. bitcoin is 3 trillion 500 11
billion 60 million
552
8999
it proves that dogecoin is easier to
mine among other cryptocurrencies
third is block time
it is the time taken by a new block of
transactions to be checked confirmed and
added to the blockchain block time of
dogecoin is one minute for bitcoin it is
10 minutes
and at fourth and fifth we have reward
per block and per block usd
it is the amount
in usd to the miner for each block added
to the network
block reward for dogecoin is 10 000
dodge coins per block which in usd is
27.36 dodge coins
for bitcoin it is 12.5 bitcoin per block
and in usd it is 86
391.63 bitcoins
moving on finally we have reached the
most crucial point of this video now we
will have a look at how to mine dogecoin
dogecoin can be mined in two ways the
first one
dogecoin pool mining and the second is
solo mining
a dogecoin pool is a group of people who
share their computing power to mine
dogecoin transaction data and get
rewarded by equal share after confirming
the transaction
solo mining is when only one person does
all the work of mining and confirming
transactions
reward is awarded only to that person
after confirming the transaction
let's have a thorough discussion of the
difference between dogecoin pool mining
and solo my name
in dogecoin pool mining you have to mine
as a part of it and pay fees
in dojo in solo mining you don't need to
pay any fees and your mine all by
yourself
also in pole mining you will only get a
part of the reward on by the pool one
button solo mining the total reward on
will be received by you only
as in pole mining many people work
together so the mind blocks more often
and on the other side solo mining could
take a lot of time before one mine their
first block
in pool mining it takes less time to
confirm a transaction as you work as a
part of the pool community on the other
hand in solo mining it can take much
longer to confirm a transaction as you
do all the work and there is a lot of
competition
so this was all about dogecoin pool
mining and solar mining
let's proceed further and see what we
need to start mining dogecoin
but before we start mining we will have
to make sure that we have these things
with us a pc with any operating system
like windows linux ubuntu etc
a good internet connection
and a digital wallet to store the
dogecoins you mine which hardware and
software can we use for dogecoin mining
you will need your pc cpu which should
be powerful enough to mine dogecoin a
gpu or graphics card can also be used
for mining dogecoin for example sapphire
pulse radeon rx 580 asus rx vega 64
and many more
stripped asic miner is programmed to
mine script based cryptocurrencies like
dogecoin
like bitmain antminer l3 bwl 21 strip
miner etc
if you are new to deutsche point mining
then using your pc cpu will be the right
choice and cpu mine is the most
appropriate software
if you are thinking of mining using gpu
or graphics card you can have a wide
range of software
some of the best software is buddha
miner which works perfectly with
nvidia products cgminer which works with
most gpu hardware and easy miner is
considered suitable for beginners
script asic miners are considered to be
very powerful hardware and multi-miner
is excellent with this hardware moving
ahead let's understand what does coin
cloud mining is
doscoin cloud mining is a mechanism to
mine dogecoin using rented data centers
without installing any hardware and
related softwares
it allows people to take an interest and
participate in deutsche point mining at
a very low cost making dogecoin mining
accessible for a broader range of people
worldwide
since the dodge coin mining process uses
the cloud it reduces equipment
maintenance or direct energy cost
this whole concept of dogecoin mining
brings me in front of one question
is dotecoin mining profitable
doj coin mining profitability can be
analyzed based on power consumption hash
rate and cost the dogecoin mining
calculator is used to make it simple in
this calculator
the default value for the latest
dogecoin mining hash rate and latest
dogecoin difficulty target is pre-loaded
for better results dogecoin mining's
reward is
44 lakh forty four thousand four hundred
twelve point two five dollars per year
that is
fourteen million doge per year the block
time for dogecoin is one minute which
means the supply of dogecoin will never
go down
after deducting mining power costs and
mining fees the final daily dose coin
mining profit is 22.53
torch coin to usd with the profit margin
of
positive eighty one point seven two
percent
also i think dogecoin mining is fun
so that brings us to what is dogecoin
wallet
a dogecoin wallet is something where you
can stop store receive or send dogecoins
technically it is very similar to a
real-life wallet
dogecoin wallet consists of its public
and private key connecting it to the
distributed ledger over the dogecoin
network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address for your bank account number for
dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made by maintaining the
anonymity of the user
the private key of your wallet is used
to approve transactions in the ledger
your wallet's public key is used to
receive dodge coins from other users on
the other hand your wallet's private key
is only used to send torch points to
other users in the network so what are
the types of deutsche coin wallet
doch coin wallet is of two types digital
torch coin wallet
and physical dodge point wallet digital
doj coin wallet is accessible through
the web and you can also download it
according to your handset or operating
system
on the other hand physical dogecoin
wallets are pretty expensive and less
accessible so moving on let's see how to
create a dogecoin wallet
to create a dojo coin wallet for
yourself you will have to go through the
following steps
step 1 choose the correct wallet dot co
followed and multi-touch wallet have
been created and are maintained by the
developers team of dogecoin
here we will be using the dojo and core
wallet as reference
step 2 download and install the dogecoin
wallet in your handset
you can also use the official website of
this wallet for your windows
and step three open the doors coin
wallet application and verify your dojo
and wallet address
and that is it it is this easy to create
and have your dojo involved now when you
have your dutch coin wallet in your hand
let's see how you can use it on the very
bottom of the home page of your wallet
there are two options request coins
where you can request torch coins from
other users in the dogecoin network
and send coins where you can send
dogecoins to other users in the dogecoin
network to receive coins
first click on the request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third
have the below generated barcode scanned
by the user you wish to request the
mount
now to send coins
first type the dogecoin wallet address
to whom you want to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send
and there you go now you can use your
dogecoin wallet whenever and wherever
you want this makes me wonder why is
dogecoin so popular
despite being in tough competition with
other strong cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin dogecoin has never missed an
opportunity to be in the limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
community other than that social
platforms like reddit and twitter also
promote a dogecoin to a great extent due
to its fun factor and the whole joke
story behind it celebrities like snoop
dogg kevin jonas elon musk also started
taking an interest in dogepoint and
posting pictures and comments on their
social media handles which increased the
craze of dogecoin all around the world
so this was all about dogecoin wallet
now let's have a look at the top five
deutsche point wallets of 2021. these
are the top five dogecoin wallets of
2021
ledger nano x trees model t
kept key binance and kraken
kraken is primarily a cryptocurrency
exchange platform but can perfectly act
as a dogecoin wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dogecoins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform
it charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it
and it accepts a pretty decent amount of
fiat money in this video we will compare
and contrast dogecoin bitcoin and
ethereum based on a few related concepts
around these cryptocurrencies
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top
cryptocurrencies and will also let us
figure out the individuality of each one
of them
dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
adam beam coin inspired by shiba inu's
popular meme aka doj
but it was very well received by
everyone in the crypto world and today
it is the fourth top cryptocurrency
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that provides its users
with a completely unknown decentralized
and secure environment to make their
transactions
bitcoin led the first revolution of
digital money in 2013.
bitcoin enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
bitcoin is designed to be an alternative
to national currencies and intends only
to be a medium of exchange and value
storage
it comprises of features like a public
ledger immutability and high
transparency making it a great platform
ethereum came into the picture years
after bitcoin ethereum offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized applications
using smart contracts through its
currency ether or eth
the primary function of ether is to help
developers build smart contracts using
dapps or decentralized application
now let's move on to comparison between
dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like algorithm
programming language
mining process
monetary policies
transactions today's value
and availability
so let's move ahead and start with the
very first comparison the algorithm
dogecoin uses stripped cryptography for
mining the blocks of the dogecoin
network
in comparison bitcoin uses the sha-256
hashing algorithm for mining its blocks
in the blockchain network
ethereum on the other hand uses the dash
algorithm for mining its transactions
script language is a password-based key
derivation function that is mainly used
to avoid customized hardware attacks by
raising the resource demands of the
algorithm
she 256 algorithm helps bitcoin users
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys or transaction details and
help maintain the anonymity of the user
for a much secure performance of
transactions
e-algorithm is mainly used during the
proof-of-work function proof-of-work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy specific network requirements
moving on the following comparison
programming language
dogecoin is considered to be an altcoin
for bitcoin both dogecoin and bitcoin
use the same programming language
c plus it is a stack based programming
language used to give bitcoin and
dogecoin software instructions on how to
make transactions
on the other side ethereum uses solidity
which is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
now that we have covered programming
language and the algorithm of these
cryptocurrency let's get to the
following very important parameter which
is mining process
but before getting started with the
comparison first let's understand what
mining is
mining is a process in which
transactions are validated and added to
the blockchain public ledger in blocks
and the people mining these blocks are
called miners
in terms of the mining process also
dogecoin and bitcoin use the same method
to verify and validate the pending
transaction in the networks and that is
proof of work
although ethereum miners also mine the
unvalidated transactions using the proof
of work method it aims to switch to
proof of stake
because it will make its network more
immune to centralization energy
efficient and more vital support for
shared chains
now we have come to the following person
which is monetary policy
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the
competent monetary authority to control
the money supply and achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth
dojo's policy is defined by its block
reward paid to its miners
whereas
bitcoin policy is defined by two
processes having and block reward
having event is when reward of mining
bitcoin is cut in half
and it also cuts the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block
an ethereum's policy is defined as
minimum issuance to secure the network
that is there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
dogecoin's block reward is 10 000 for
mining one block bitcoin's block reward
is 12.5 for mining each block and which
is said to get reduced to 6.25 by 2024
and ethereum's block reward is 2 ether
per block
dogecoin takes one minute to generate
one block
bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate one
block
and ethereum generates one block every
14 seconds
well monetary policies are considered to
be fixed and non-inflationary
due to this over time mining blocks will
become more complex
now moving on to the following
comparison which is transactions
dogecoin is the fastest
and can complete 70 transaction in one
second
and takes just two to three minutes to
confirm a transaction
bitcoin can complete up to five
transaction in one second and takes 10
minutes or more than that to confirm one
transaction
an ethereum can complete 30 transactions
per second and it takes just a few
minutes to confirm it
dogecoin is majorly used for tipping
content creators on social platforms
like reddit and twitter
bitcoin is only used as a superior
alternative for fiat money and is used
primarily for real-world transactions
on the other hand ether the currency of
ethereum acts as the fuel for ethereum
networks
now that we have covered all about
transaction process of these
cryptocurrency
let's have a look at the value of
dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum in today's
date
the value of dogecoin on today's date is
point two nine nine two dollars
bitcoin being the highest is thirty four
thousand eight hundred fifty seven point
five eight
an ethereum holds a value of 2356
for
now we have reached the last comparison
of dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum which
is availability
the circulating supply of dogecoin is
1.7 billion
bitcoin very low as compared to dogecoin
is just
21 million in circulation
ethereum on the other hand is said to be
unlimited but till today the circulation
supply of ethereum is 115.6 million
till today 113 billion dogecoin has
already been mined
for bitcoin 18 million bitcoins are
already mined
and for ethereum roughly 36 million
ethereum has already been mined
in this draft you can see the red box on
the right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that
you can use according to your
requirements like if you want to know
about dogecoin you can go for the first
option that is www.dogecoin.com
which will lead you to the official
website of dogecoin if you want to chat
with the executives of coin market
regarding dogecoin then you can go for
the fourth option which is chat
before that is an address for binance
address through which you can keep a
track of dogecoin's value on that
platform and you can also change it
according to your choice by clicking on
more
right beside the more option you can see
the
market cap value of dogecoin which is
thirty eight billion thirty eight
hundred forty nine million four hundred
sixty nine thousand ninety eight
it is the total value of dogecoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
which is 38 700
795
9006.
it is the capitalization when max supply
of dogecoin was in circulation
and on the right side just before total
supply you can see the volume of
dogecoin one billion seven hundred
seventy nine million four hundred
seventeen thousand hundred
it is the value of dogecoin traded in 24
hours
next is bitcoin similar to dogecoin you
can see the red box on the right side of
the graph shows the maximum supply of
dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that you can use according
to your requirement
like if you want to know more about
bitcoin you can go for the first option
that is www not bitcoin bitcoin.org
which will lead you to the official
website of bitcoin
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of bitcoin which is
651 billion 713 million 10
753
it is the total value of bitcoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
that is
732 billion 387 million two hundred
sixty two thousand six hundred ninety
and on the right side just before the
total supply you can see the volume of
bitcoin
that is 30
nine million nine hundred thirty nine
thousand eight hundred sixty five
ethereum is no different from dogecoin
and bitcoin in this also you can see the
total supply of ethereum
also you can visit the official website
of
www.ethereum.org to explore more about
ethereum
you can have a look at the market cap
value of ethereum which is 273 billion
755 million five hundred eighty six
thousand five hundred thirty four
the fully diluted market capitalization
is 273 billion five hundred seventy six
million nine hundred eighty seven
thousand 049
the volume of ethereum traded in 24
hours is 24 billion 100 1 billion 779
346 but in the end
all these top cryptocurrencies deutsche
coin bitcoin and ethereum share a few
similarities
like they all are decentralized
all three cryptocurrencies are free from
any third-party interference or any
centralized authority
and can be used to have secure and
independent peer-to-peer transaction
maintaining the anonymity of the user
and proof of work that is all their
transactions are verified and validated
before processing
after complete verification further
transaction process takes place
also all of them have a large network of
independent nodes let's get started and
understand what kind of interview
questions can come for a blockchain
interview so let's start with certain
beginner level questions now when you
face a blockchain interview you can get
different variety of questions so we
will be covering that what kind of
questions can be asked at each level
intermediate and expert level so one of
the few questions which you could be
asked is what is the difference between
blockchain and hyperledger blockchain is
basically the underlying concept
blockchain is a decentralized technology
of immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography whereas
hyperledger is a platform or an
organization that allows people to build
private blockchain so basically
blockchain is a concept is a technology
using blockchain you can build public
and private blockchains but hyperledger
is a specific technology which allows
you to build only private blockchains
now blockchain is divided into public
private and consortium blockchains
hyperledger is specifically a private
blockchain technology with access to
blockchain data is limited to predefined
users and it is defined using certain
configurations and programming
blockchain can be used in multiple
fields like business governments
healthcare other different kind of
domains and etc hyperledger is primarily
used in blockchain for enterprise-based
solutions so wherever we are talking
about public blockchains like usage of
blockchain on internet and hyper ledger
based blockchain solutions are solutions
which are meant for internet within an
organization within a corporation second
how do you explain blockchain technology
someone who doesn't know it so basically
in simple terms blockchain technology is
a distributed ledger which stores
transaction details in the form of
immutable records non-modifiable records
which are called blocks which are
secured using cryptography so in order
to explain simplistically let's consider
an example of a school where blockchain
is similar to a digital report card of a
student now each block contains students
records which has a label stating the
date and time of when the record was
entered or when the record was
registered on the blockchain now neither
the teacher nor the student can modify
the details of the block cannot modify
the record of report cards therefore the
record becomes non-modifiable immutable
also the teacher owns a private key that
allows him or her to make new records
and the student owns a public key to
view and access the report card at any
time so basically the teacher owns the
right to update the record but the
student only owns the right to view the
record now this method makes the data
both active and secure and this is what
blockchain brings on the table these are
the primary attributes for which
blockchain is getting widely adopted to
have immutable records available for
view to the public and available for
updating in an untemperable way now what
is a merkle tree merkle tree is a data
structure which is used for verifying a
block it is in a form of a binary tree
containing cryptographic hashes of each
block so basically a merkle tree is
structured similar to a binary tree each
leaf node is a hash of a block of
transactional data so each leaf node is
basically a transaction which is hashed
and each non-leaf node is a hash of its
leaf node so basically hash a a is the
hash of two blocks a and hash b merkel
root or the hash root is the final hash
of all the transaction hashes so
basically merkel root is the hash of a a
and hash bb so it encompasses all the
transactions which are underlying all
the non-leaf nodes what do you mean by
blocks in the blockchain technology what
is the definition of a block so
blockchain is a distributed database of
immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography now as
you see there are the certain attributes
of a block which are displayed here you
have previous hash transaction details
nonce and a target hash value a block is
like a record of transactions each time
a block is verified it gets recorded in
chronological order on the main
blockchain so as you can see as it is
represented over here every time a new
block is verified it gets added to the
main blockchain with all those
attributes populated now once the data
is recorded it cannot be modified it
cannot be changed now another question
which could come into your interview is
how is blockchain distributed ledger
different from a traditional ledger it
is a very important question we need to
know the basic difference and
justification if we have to move from a
traditional database to a blockchain
based distributed ledger what benefit it
bring on the table so certain
differences which are very visible are
transparency blockchain distributed
ledger is highly transparent as compared
to traditional database distributed
ledgers are irreversible once any
information is registered on a
distributed ledger cannot be modified
whereas on a traditional ledger it is
reversible basically distributed ledger
is more secure it uses cryptography
every transaction is hashed and recorded
in a traditional ledger the security can
be compromised in a distributed ledger
there is no central authority it's a
distributed system the participants of
the network holds the authority to
maintain the sanity of the network and
are responsible for validating the
transactions whereas traditional ledgers
are based on the concept of centralized
authority and control and all the
transactions are controlled by the
centralized authority in a distributed
ledger identities are unknown and are
hidden whereas in a traditional ledger
identities of all the participants have
to be known before the transaction can
happen in a distributed ledger there is
not a single point of failure as the
data is distributed information is
shared across multiple nodes even if a
single node fails the other nodes carry
the same copy of the information whereas
in a traditional ledger in a centralized
database ledger based system that
particular system becomes a single point
of failure if the single system crashes
the entire application or the entire
network comes to a standstill ability to
modify data no once the data or a
transaction is registered it cannot be
altered and a traditional ledger it is
possible how validation is done so in a
distributed ledger it is done by the
participants of the network in a
traditional ledger it is controlled by
the centralized authority copy of ledger
is shared amongst all the participants
of a distributed ledger each participant
consists the same information in the
ledger in a traditional ledger only a
single copy is maintained at a
centralized location it is not shared
amongst all the participants thereby
again it remains as a single point of
failure if you have any queries you can
put your comments in the comments
section of this video and we will
definitely come back to you how can you
identify a block what are the attributes
of block in order to understand it so
every block consists of four fields it
holds the hash value of the previous
block therefore it gets linked in a
blockchain it contains the details of
the aggregated transactions which are
aggregated in the block it has a value
called non nonce is a random value which
is used to vary the value of the hash in
order to generate the hash value less
than the target and then finally you
have a hash of the block itself it is
the digital signature of this block a
unique hash for this block it is a
alphanumeric value which is used to
identify a block so that is the identity
of the block the hash address is the
unique identification of a block it is a
hex value of 64 characters that has both
letters and digit it is obtained by
using sha-256 algorithm now this is the
way it is structured the hash of the
previous block the transaction data and
the nouns consolidate the header of the
block they all together
are passed through a hashing function
and then the hash value the digital
signature of the block is then generated
what is cryptography and what is its
role in blockchain blockchain uses
cryptography primarily to secure users
identities and ensure the transactions
are done safely with the hash function
so all the user identities and the
transaction on a blockchain are
encrypted cryptography uses public and
private keys to encrypt and decrypt data
so basically it uses the public and
private key infrastructure in order to
maintain the encryption of the
information on a blockchain network in
blockchain network public key can be
shared with all the bitcoin users all
the blockchain users so public key is
just like your address which you can
share it with anyone but a private key
is like your password it is kept secret
with the user so basically blockchain
uses cryptography to secure user
identities and ensure transactions are
done safely and how does it do it it
uses sha-256 algorithm which is secure
which provides a unique hash output for
every input and it is a very popular
algorithm the basic feature of sha-256
is that whatever input you pass it will
give you a standard output alphanumeric
output of 64 characters so basically it
is a one-way function you can derive an
encrypted value from the input but you
can't do vice versa now what are the
different types of blockchains which
exists there are three different types
of blockchains public blockchain private
blockchain and consortium blockchain
public blockchain ledgers are visible to
all the users on the internet and any
user can verify and add a block of
transactions to the blockchain basically
it's publicly available anyone can
participate in the network and get
hooked up so examples are bitcoin and
ethereum private blockchain ledgers are
visible to all the users on the internet
but only specific users in the
organization can verify an ad
transaction so it's a kind of a
permissioned blockchain though the
information can be available publicly
but the controllers and the validators
of the blockchain are within the
organizations and are pre-determined the
example is block stack consortium
blockchain here the consensus process is
controlled by only specific nodes
however ledgers are visible to all the
participants in the consortium
blockchain example is ripple now what
happens when you try to deploy a file
with multiple contracts in blockchain
deploying a file with multiple contracts
is not possible the compiler only
deploys the last contract from the
uploaded file and the remaining
contracts are neglected and this is the
way a smart contract is deployed on a
blockchain network now very interesting
question what is a genesis block it's a
very important question and could be
asked in an interview multiple times so
basically genesis block is the first
block in the blockchain which is also
known as block zero so as you can see
the sequence number of this block is
zero and in blockchain it is the only
block that does not refer to any
previous block so the hash value of the
previous block will be all zeros because
it is the first block also it defines
parameters of the blockchain such as
level of difficulty consensus mechanisms
etc to mine the block so basically it
defines the primary attributes of the
blockchain which is gonna get initiated
from the genesis block onwards now let's
look at some of the questions which
would come if you are at an intermediate
level now how is the hash of a block
signature generated in blockchain to
generate a digital signature transaction
details are passed through a one-way
hashing function for example sha-256
then the output value is passed through
a signature algorithm like ecdsa with
the user's private key then the
encrypted hash along with the other
information such as the hashing
algorithm is called as the digitally
signed document and is called the
digital signature so this is the entire
process of generating a digitally signed
block list down some of the extensively
used cryptographic algorithms these are
the few popular algorithms which are
extensively used sha-256 bitcoin uses it
it has ethereum uses it rsa is one of
the other popular algorithm blowfish
triple des so it's very important to
memorize these algorithms the names of
these algorithms when asked and she 256
and it hash are used in two of the
popular public blockchain networks what
is a smart contract and lists some of
its application so smart contracts are
self-executing contracts these are
basically digital contracts which
contains the terms and conditions of an
agreement between two parties between
two peers now some of the applications
can be used in transportation where
shipment of goods can be easily tracked
using smart contracts so as there's a
movement of goods and it is exchanging
hands between different parties there
could be need of a contract and a smart
contract between the parties it is also
used in protecting copyrighted content
like music or books or the literature
which you have written so smart
contracts can protect the ownership
rights it can also be used in insurance
it can be used to identify false claims
and prevent forgeries employment
contract smart contracts can be helpful
to facilitate wage payments and it can
be used as a proof of employment now
another important question what is it
network and how many ethereum networks
are you familiar with ethereum is a
blockchain based distributed computing
platform featuring smart contract
functionality that enable users to
create and deploy their decentralized
applications called daps there are three
types of network in ethereum live
network the main net then there are a
couple of test networks like robsten
coven and rink b and then you can also
create your own private network using
ethereum smart contracts are deployed on
the main network they are publicly
available and can be used by others also
test network allows you to run your
smart contracts on a test net validate
the gas which is being used you can just
use these test networks as the main net
deploy your contracts verify your
decentralized application and then move
on to the main net private networks are
those which are not connected to the
main network which run within the
premises of the organization but carry
the features of an ethereum network now
where do nodes run smart contract code
nodes run smart contract codes on a
ethereum virtual machine it is a virtual
machine designed to operate as a runtime
environment for ethereum based smart
contracts evm is operated in a sandbox
environment or isolated from the main
net and it is a perfect testing
environment so you can download the evm
run your smart contact locally in an
isolated manner and once you have tested
and verified it then you can deploy it
on the mainline now very important and a
very good question what is a dab and how
is it different from a normal
application we need to understand these
differences very thoroughly in order to
clear our interview so adap is a
decentralized application which is
deployed using smart contract the
information on a dap is distributed and
shared in a normal application it has a
centralized database which is running on
a centralized server so you have a
single server and a single code which is
maintaining the entire application no
information is shared and it is a single
point of failure a dapp has its back-end
code a smart contract which runs on a
decentralized peer-to-peer network in a
normal application it's a typical
computer software application that is
hosted on a central server so if you see
in the differences in the process you
have a front end then in the middle you
have a smart contract which is acting as
the back-end code and then the entire
transaction executed on a smart contract
is shared between the blockchain
participants in a p2p network whereas in
a normal application the front end
interacts with a centralized api which
performs basic crud operations create
read update delete on a centralized
database and it is a single copy of the
information name some leading open
source platforms for developing
blockchain applications so ethereum is
one of the popular platforms for
building blockchain-based applications
and it is widely getting adopted ares is
also used for building enterprise based
solutions and also some of the widely
used platforms for building blockchain
are listed below hyperledger multi-chain
open chain are available in the market
what is the very first thing you must
specify in a solidity file now it is
necessary to specify the version number
of solidity at the beginning of a code
as it eliminates incompatibility errors
which can arise while compiling with
another version it is a mandatory clause
which has to be there at the top of any
solidity code which you write and you
need to mention the correct version
number for which you have written the
port now what is the difference between
bitcoin and ethereum and it's a very
important question which i also ask in
lot of interviews and it's important for
you to remember these differences so
bitcoin the concept is purely p2p
currency based transaction but in
ethereum you can do both p2p currency
transaction plus you can deploy smart
contracts bitcoin is primarily working
on proof-of-work consensus mechanism
ethereum is shifting from proof of work
to proof-of-stake bitcoin uses sha-256
hashing algorithm whereas ethereum uses
it hash time taken to mine a block
currently on bitcoin is approximately 10
minutes whereas in ethereum it gets
processed in 12 to 15 seconds the reward
for mining on bitcoin as of today is
12.5 bitcoin whereas in ethereum it is
three ethers plus the transaction fees
on bitcoin the transaction fees are
optional whereas in ethereum the fees is
calculated based on the gas which is
being consumed on a smart contract per
transaction value of bitcoin as of 21st
august was captured at
6934 us dollars whereas ethereum stands
at 278
now what is nonce and how is it used in
mining in blockchain mining is a process
to validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now proof of work is the
process to determine a number a nonce
that is the number
along with the cryptographic hash
algorithm to produce a hash value which
is lower than a predefined target nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the hash value so that the final hash
value meets the hashing condition so the
nonce is the value which is being
generated by the miner in order to guess
the hash value which should be less than
the target value and then only the miner
can claim the reward for if he's mining
a bitcoin network of 12.5 btc and
ethereum network of three ethers now
let's look at some of the advanced level
questions name the steps that are
involved in a blockchain project
implementation so in a typical
blockchain based project implementation
we start off with requirement
identification we need to understand the
problem and goal we need to identify the
suitable consensus mechanism what is the
most suitable platform which can solve
the problem and then identify the
implementation and deployment cost we
need to give an roi to the client then
we move on to the planning stage in this
step an individual evaluates all the
requirements list them down prioritize
them and decides a suitable blockchain
platform which has to be used to
implement this particular problem then
kicks off the development and
implementation of the project you design
the architecture you design the user
interfaces and start building the apis
and then comes controlling and
monitoring the project you apply the
proof of concept you start off with that
and then start building the application
on top of it and then once the basic
version of the application is available
you start identifying bugs and start
fixing them explain a real life use case
where blockchain is being used so supply
chain is the biggest adopter of
blockchain and as you can see as the raw
material moves is exchanged between
different entities in a supply chain the
traceability of that particular digital
asset which in this case is raw material
is a big case study on blockchain in
supply chain management smart contracts
provide permanent transparency
traceability and validation of
transaction shared by multiple supply
chain partners so at each level each
supply chain partner has to register a
transaction when it receives a product
and then when it passes it on so
basically the purchaser when consuming
the end product can see the entire
journey of the product list and explain
the parts of evm memory so the memory of
an evm is divided into three parts
storage memory and stack storage values
are stored permanently on the blockchain
network and it is extremely expensive so
whenever you will try to modify a
storage based variable you would have to
pay gas for it memory variables are
temporary modifiable storage area it can
be accessed only during the contract
execution and once the execution is
finished the data is wiped off vanished
and lost stack on the other way is a
temporary and a non-modifiable storage
here when the execution is completed the
content is lost so basically memory and
stack are relatively much cheaper than
storage variables now what happens if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas initially
your transaction will be executed but if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas then the
miners will stop validating your
contract the blockchain will record the
transaction as fail as highlighted and
also the user does not get a refund so
it becomes of utmost important that when
you are deploying your smart contract
you do the calculation of the gas
consumption in the most correct fashion
what does the gas usage in a transaction
depend on and how is transaction fee
calculated so gas usage depends upon the
amount of storage you are using if you
are using storage based variables and
the cost of the transactions will be
high the gas will be high and the set of
instruction codes use in a smart
contract basically what operations you
are performing on the storage based
variables either they're costly and if
you are using huge amount of storage
variables then automatically the cost of
your smart contract will keep on
increasing so basically the transaction
fee is calculated in ethers which is
given as the gas price which you have
determined for your smart contract and
multiplied by the gas limit and this is
how your transaction fee is evaluated
now what is fork and what are some of
the types of forking so in simple terms
updating a cryptocurrency protocol or
code is called forking fork implies that
a blockchain splits into two branches
and forking is done when you want to
modify certain attributes of an existing
blockchain network it can happen when
the participants of the network cannot
come to an agreement with regards to
either the consensus algorithm or they
want new rules for validation so there
are three types of forking heart forking
soft forking and accidental forks what
is the difference between proof of work
versus proof of stake and it's a very
important question in blockchain proof
of work is the process of solving a
complex mathematical puzzle called
mining whereas proof of stake is an
alternative proof of work by which the
blockchain aims to achieve distributed
consensus in proof of work probability
of mining a block is based upon the
amount of computational work done by a
miner basically it consumes huge amount
of resources electricity resources and
computational resources of the miner
whereas in proof-of-stake the
probability of validating the block
relies upon the amount of token you own
beforehand so the more the tokens you
have the more the chance you get to
validate a block so basically proof of
stock has been introduced in order to
reduce the pressure on the resources
which has been put by the proof of work
consensus algorithm miners spend a lot
of computing power for solving the
cryptographic puzzle along with the
hardware and it's a huge cost so
basically proof of stake was created as
a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources spent in mining what
is a 51 attack in blockchain 51 attack
refers to a vulnerability where an
individual or group of people can
control the majority of the mining power
or hash rate so basically they can take
over the 50 of the blockchain network
this would allow the attackers to
prevent new transactions from being
confirmed further they can double spend
the coins now in 51 attack smaller
cryptocurrencies are primarily being
attacked which does not have a huge
network which has a small consumer base
what are function modifiers in solidity
and mention the most widely used
modifiers in solidity function modifiers
are used to easily modify behavior of
your smart contract it can be associated
with a function and then whenever a
function is called the modifier is
called before the main function in
simple terms it can build additional
features or apply restrictions on the
function of smart contracts the most
extensively used function modifiers in
solidity are view view functions are
functions that cannot modify the state
of a smart contract they are only read
only functions here is an example you
have a function get simply learn name
and it is having a modifier view which
only returns a value but you are allowed
to use some inbuilt solidity functions
like msg.sender but in case of pure pure
functions are functions that neither
read nor write the state of smart
contracts they return the same result
determined by its input variables so
basically you can't even access the
inbuilt functions of solidity so here
you have a function called calculate you
can only use the input variables you
cannot use any of the inbuilt functions
also of solidity now let's take a look
of an example in order to write a
crowdsale smart contract code in
solidity programming language so here in
the example you have a smart contract
where you have defined certain smart
contract variables of solidity like
address and uint now the address
function is if you want to send your
token to someone and your uint is the
funding goal in ethers basically how
much amount of ethers you want to
generate in your crowdsale
project then what is the duration of
your project then cost of each token in
ethers then address of token used as
reward so these are the primary
attributes which you have defined then
you have your public functions which are
defined over here the beneficiary is
successfully sent to the funding goal
the deadline of your crowd sale and the
price now here is your default function
which is defined in a solidity contract
which does not have any function name
and is called by default in your smart
contract if anyone invokes a method in
your smart contract which does not exist
in this function you are making sure
that all the amount which has been
passed to the smart contract is passed
to your address basically you are the
originator of your crowdsale function
crowdsale smart contract so you should
be receiving the amount then in your
crowdsales smart contract you can have a
method which is called as safe
withdrawal and you have appended it with
a modifier called after deadline so
which basically
checks that you can only do a withdrawal
after the deadline has been achieved and
in this function you are checking the
balance then you are withdrawing that
amount from the sender and transferring
it to your own account as the sender has
sent that amount to you so you do the
basic validations whether the sender has
that balance and then you do that
transfer to your account meet frank and
daniel
one day they decide to go for a trip to
venice they made a budget list for all
their expenses like residence flight etc
they thought of making their bookings
online from a site that offered
discounts to the first 10 visitors on
that day
while making their respective flight
bookings daniel's transaction failed and
he missed the offer going on
on the other hand frank paid his share
very quickly and easily and became one
of the three lucky draw winners
daniel was surprised and asked frank how
he could make the transaction when
daniel himself could not
to which his response was it's simple i
used bitcoin a type of cryptocurrency
daniel was confused and he asked what
cryptocurrency is and since when has it
been in use
frank stepped up and explained to him
cryptocurrency is a virtual or digital
currency that works on blockchain
technology and is designed to work as a
medium of exchange online to buy goods
and services and make payments which was
introduced to the world first in 2013 by
satoshi nakamoto
daniel felt that it sounds similar to
other online payment options he asked
what makes it so different
frank explained cryptocurrency is
decentralized and free from any
third-party interference
which means it is not issued and
controlled by any government or central
authority unlike other payment systems
that banks or governments are handling
and that's why a cryptocurrency
transaction never fails there could be
many reasons for why daniel's
transaction failed like he may have
exceeded his transfer limit for his
account must have been hacked or there
could have been some technical issue
with his bank server or may be due to
high transaction fees imposed by the
bank
but on the other hand cryptocurrency
charges almost no or very low
transaction cost
there is no limit for making
transactions
in fact you have 24 7 access to your
money there is no extra delay or extra
charges on making international
transactions and the best part is that
anybody can use cryptocurrency without
the hassles of paperwork
all you need to do is create an account
on any digital wallet of cryptocurrency
this is what makes cryptocurrency
different from other online payment
options
daniel was impressed by cryptocurrency
but he wondered how it works without the
control of an external authority
upon research he found out that
cryptocurrency works on blockchain
technology blockchain is a set of blocks
that record information of transactions
like who made the transaction to whom
the amount of trade in the form of a
digital ledger that is distributed
across the entire network meaning the
data is replicated and stored on each
node across the entire blockchain
network making it more secure and
impossible to change hack or cheat the
system
then it is verified and validated by
every node to proceed with the process
of making the transactions
the crypto in cryptocurrency stands for
cryptography which is a method of using
encryption and decryption to secure the
data in the presence of any third party
with ulterior motives
now daniel was completely aware of the
whole technology and concept behind
cryptocurrency and was influenced by
frank to adopt cryptocurrency in his
daily lifestyle too
he did that by booking his ticket but
sadly no discount like daniel
cryptocurrency has influenced and
impacted an enormous number of people
worldwide
due to this increasing popularity new
companies like metoo and paypal are
coming forward and investing in
cryptocurrency every day in 2018 malta
an island located in the mediterranean
sea south of italy was titled blockchain
island as it led to the economic
stability of the nation
many fintech companies like binance and
okcx have already begun to take
advantage of malta's financial
incentives and have moved their
headquarters to the blockchain island
so here is a question for you
which hashing algorithm does
cryptocurrency use
a
script
b
c
sha256 d
none of the above
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
three lucky winners will receive amazon
gift vouchers
cryptocurrency is revolutionizing
finance and banking around the world
thanks to cryptocurrency now anyone with
an internet connection can trade spend
and borrow money around the world and
nobody can stop them
people like bill gates co-founder of
microsoft corporation and elon musk ceo
of tesla support cryptocurrency as it is
much better and secure than physical
money and also holds a great future for
the world's economy
and on the other hand some people think
of cryptocurrency as a bane to the
world's economy like warren buffett ceo
of berkshire hathaway and ajay benga ceo
of global mastercard feel that
cryptocurrency is a platform of criminal
activities and will destroy the world's
economy
well one thing is clear that this
conflict is going to stay put for a
little longer hi guys today we're going
to talk about 10 things you didn't know
about bitcoin firstly we have the
mysterious creator now in 2009 a person
or a group of people known as satoshi
nakamoto introduced bitcoin to the world
he vanished off the internet in late
2010 he hasn't been heard from since now
just like his identity is shorter than
mystery nobody really knows if he's even
alive or dead the only communication
people had with him were through emails
and forums his bitcoin wallet holds
around 980 000 bitcoins which makes him
one of the richest people on the planet
next up we have the satoshi now as a
sign of respect for the bitcoin's
creator the smallest unit of a bitcoin
is known as a satoshi one satoshi is
valued at around 0.000
669 for us dollars which is a very very
low value now to make one bitcoin you
need approximately 100 million satoshi's
now according to the current bitcoin
values which fluctuates a lot to make a
dollar you'd need close to 15 800
satoshi's losing bitcoins losing your
bitcoin address which is also known as
your private key not only means losing
your unique identification it also means
you lose all the bitcoins in your wallet
research shows that at least 60 percent
of all bitcoin addresses are ghosts
which means a huge chunk of the
population that's using the bitcoin
network have lost their addresses now
these are the people who have lost their
addresses and have no way to access
their wallet liberland now in april 2015
a micro nation between croatia and
serbia known as labourland was born now
this was founded by virgilka a
politician publicist activist and the
president of liberland now the official
currency of liberland is bitcoin now the
government took this move believing that
bitcoin and its underlying concepts of
blockchain provides a secure and
transparent method for recording
electronic financial and physical assets
processing power the process of mining
bitcoins is a expensive process now you
pay a high toll to do this like your
money your time and electricity now
mining bitcoins require servers that are
used for that specific purpose alone now
the faster you process the data the
faster the block can be added to the
blockchain and the faster you're
rewarded with bitcoins power consumption
now just imagine how much electricity
ireland consumes in a year approximately
five thousand kilowatt hour now how much
do you think all the bitcoin mining
farms together consume 60 terawatt all
which is approximately 6 into 10 raised
to 10 kilowatt hours which is a large
amount of power now the entire country
of ireland which is the second most
populated city in europe and has 84 421
kilometers square of area consumes
lesser electricity than all these farms
combined bitcoin ban now although
several countries around the world like
canada and america have wholeheartedly
accepted bitcoin there are some that
haven't countries like bolivia iceland
bangladesh and ecuador have completely
banned the usage of bitcoins there are
also countries like india thailand and
iran who ask their residents to be
careful while using cryptocurrencies
they haven't completely banned it
however they do not accept it as a legal
tender law limited number there's a
limit to how many bitcoins can exist in
the market this number is capped at 21
million bitcoins as of this moment 17
million bitcoins are already in
circulation to give you an idea that's
almost 80 percent of the 21 million
already done but don't worry until 2140
we'll still have bitcoins to mine this
is because of how miners are rewarded
now miners are rewarded with 12.5
bitcoins for each block added to the
blockchain and every four years the
reward reduces by half the next halving
is supposed to occur in 2020 where the
reward reduces to 6.25 bitcoins the
power of b the terms bitcoin with an
uppercase b and bitcoin with the
lowercase b mean two different things
the only thing that differentiates the
two into two completely different things
is the letter b the lowercase b in
bitcoin refers to the cryptocurrency
that is used to perform the transactions
the uppercase b in bitcoin refers to the
ledger that stores information regarding
these transactions faster than
supercomputers the world's fastest
supercomputer the summit works at 122.3
petaflops which is nothing but a
quadrillion floating point operations
per second now if you take the bitcoin
network completely into consideration
the processing power is about 80 million
704 290 petaflops but the only thing
here is that a supercomputer can do
several different things but the only
thing the bitcoin network does is add
blocks to the blockchain let's talk
about what is bitcoin mining so what is
bitcoin so let's check an example so
there is someone who wants to send five
bitcoins to rachel now we will see how
this transaction can happen now bitcoin
is based on the concept of digital
currency anyone across the globe can
transfer amount in bitcoin irrespective
of the geography from anyone to anyone
so basically you need to just open an
account on the bitcoin network have some
bitcoins in it and you can transfer it
either you can purchase the bitcoins
online through some exchanges or you can
mine it so once you have bitcoins in
your account you can transfer it to
someone you want whose address you have
now do you want to know how this
transaction work well this transaction
is done by bitcoin mining so we will go
deep and understand that how the bitcoin
transaction works what all entities are
involved behind the scenes in order to
maintain the sanity of the bitcoin
network and make sure that whomever you
wanted the bitcoin to reach to has
reached and there is no loss of bitcoin
in the network and it is a successful
transaction so let's understand certain
basics so what's in it for us today we
need to know what is bitcoin we will
understand the underlying technology
blockchain so we will talk about that
then we will see what are the advantages
of bitcoin as compared to other digital
currencies and other digital
technologies then we will go into the
concepts of bitcoin mining then what is
bitcoin mining and we will do a demo on
certain aspects of bitcoin mining now
what is bitcoin bitcoin is the first
decentralized digital currency that
allows users to transfer money peer to
peer without any intermediaries like
banks governments agents brokers nothing
is involved and all this is done using
blockchain technology so as we saw in
our previous example two parties wants
to exchange money transfer money they
don't need an intermediary now bitcoin
can be used for online purchases
e-commerce transactions it can be used
as an investment instrument and it can
be primarily used for payments to buy
goods and services now it was created in
2009 it came into existence by a person
or a group of people called satoshi
nakamoto now bitcoin helps transferring
of assets faster than regular fiat
currencies it has definitely lower
transaction fees because as it has
removed the intermediaries from between
the cost of transaction also goes down
and it is cryptographically secure it
uses cryptography infrastructure and
thereby the identities of the sender and
the receiver are also secure and entire
transaction is cryptographically signed
and the users information who are doing
the transactions or are part of the
network is also hidden and secure now
what are the advantages of bitcoin so it
allows fast and quick peer-to-peer
transactions it is impossible to
counterfeit or hack the transactions
which are running on a bitcoin network
and it's an overall decentralized
process there is no centralized body
which is controlling the transactions or
charging a fees in order to validate the
transaction it is the participants in
the decentralized network who are taking
care of the sanity of the network
thereby making sure that the overall
transaction cost is low all the
information is accessible to public it
is available publicly on a public ledger
anyone can go and view the transactions
and the volume of the transactions
happening on the bitcoin network and it
is a low fee transaction it is
comparatively low to other
mediums and channels through which today
digital transactions are made now what
is blockchain so bitcoin runs on the
underlying technology of blockchain
blockchain is a public distributed
ledger in which transactions made in
bitcoins or any other digital currency
are recorded in a chronological order so
let's see certain features it is
cryptographically secure signed using
your private key and then shared on the
network with the public key it is
immutable any record or any transaction
added on the blockchain cannot be
modified or altered it is run by a
decentralized system there is no
centralized authority of the body and
the transactions are stored in
containers aggregated in containers
called blocks so a block is the smallest
unit of a blockchain which records all
the transaction a basic structure of a
block is something like this it has four
fields these are the primary attributes
for block it has something called as
previous hash so the previous hash
attribute stores the value of the hash
of the previous block and that's how the
blocks are linked to each other data
this is the aggregated set of
transactions which are included in this
block so these are the set of
transactions which were mined and
validated and included in the block
nonce so in proof of work consensus
algorithm which is used in bitcoin nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the output of the hash value so every
block is supposed to generate a hash
value and nonce is the parameter which
is used to generate that hash value and
the proof of work is the process of
transaction verification done in
blockchain now hash is the resultant
hash value obtained by passing the
previous hash value the data and the
nonce through the sha-256 algorithm to
generate the hash of this block so this
is the digital signature of the block
which is generated and this is the
basically identity of this block now
sha-256 is a cryptographic hash
algorithm which produces a unique 256
bit alphanumeric hash value for any
given input and that is the unique
feature of this cryptographic algorithm
whatever input you give it will always
produce a 256 bit hash now let's
understand the concepts of bitcoin
mining what is bitcoin mining bitcoin
mining is the process of verifying
bitcoin transactions and recording them
onto the public blockchain ledger in
blockchain the transactions are verified
by bitcoin users so basically the
transactions have to be verified by none
other than the participants of the
network those who have the required
hardware and computing power and those
entities are called miners so we will be
talking about them later but the point
to be highlighted is that there is
nothing like a centralized body as in
case of legacy transactions where we
used to be dependent on a regulatory or
governing body or a bank to make our
transactions go through now in bitcoin
here any user with mining hardware and
internet access can take apart that kind
of computer can be a participant and
contribute to the mining community
process is solved based on a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
so every miner's job is to solve the
mathematical puzzle which is called
proof of work in order to validate the
transaction and earn the reward and all
the miners as they are competing amongst
themselves to mine a particular
transaction the miner who first solves
the puzzle gets the reward now users
trying to sell the puzzle as i said are
called miners they are the participants
in the network who have the necessary
hardware and computing power to do all
the transactions to validate the
transactions and validate it they are
called as miners now in order to
understand bitcoin mining we need to
understand three major concepts of
blockchain it is based on distributed
public ledger it uses sha 256 encryption
algorithm and proof of work is the
underlying consensus algorithm for
bitcoin mining so distributed public
ledger a distributed ledger is a record
of all transactions maintained in the
blockchain network across the globe in
the network the validations of
transaction is done by bitcoin users
called as miners sha-256 now blockchain
prevents unauthorized access by using a
hash function called sha-256 to ensure
that the blocks are kept secure they are
digitally signed their hash value once
generated cannot be altered now seq 256
it takes an input string of any size and
returns a fixed length 256 bit output
value and that is the primary feature of
shf 256 encryption algorithm you give
any input it will always give you a 256
256-bit output and it is a one-way
function you cannot derive the input
reversally from the output what you have
generated and third is the proof of work
in blockchain mining is a process to
validate transactions by solving a
difficult mathematical puzzle called
proof of work now in order to do that
the primary objective of the minor is to
determine the nonce value and that nonce
value is that mathematical puzzle that
miners required to solve in order to
generate a hash which is less than the
target defined by the network for a
particular block now in the bitcoin
network users trying to solve
mathematical puzzles are called as minus
now the puzzle is solved by varying
a nonce which produces a hash value
lower than a predefined condition which
is called as the target miners verify
the transactions and add the block to
the blockchain when confirmed and
verified as of today the miners who
solve the puzzle gets a reward of 12.5
bitcoins now once a block is added to
the blockchain the bitcoins associate
with the transactions can be spent so
once the block is validated then the
transfer of bitcoins associated with the
transactions aggregated in the block the
transfers are made then from one account
to the another now in order to generate
the hash let's see you use the sha-256
hashing algorithm you define the hash
value if it is less than the defined
condition the target then the puzzle is
deemed to be solved and if not then you
keep on incrementing nonce value and you
repeat the sha-256 hashing function
passing on to the nonce value and you
define generate the hash value again and
you keep doing this process till the
time you get the hash value which is
less than the target now let's check an
example so for example beyonce wants to
share 10 bitcoin with jennifer now in
order to do that what will be the steps
so beyonce transaction data is shared
with bitcoin users the miners from the
memory pool the transaction goes and
sits in a memory pool of unmined
transactions so in a memory pool set of
unmined or unconfirmed transactions wait
until they are verified and included in
a new block they remain in that
unconfirmed transaction pool now miners
competing to validate the transaction
using proof of work they keep on
continuously pulling the unconfirmed
transaction pool they pick up those
transactions and start validating those
transactions they aggregate in a data
block and start validating they start
solving the puzzle the miner who solves
the puzzle first shares his result
across the other nodes the other set of
miners now once the block has been
verified the nonce has been generated
then the nodes will start granting their
approval if maximum nodes grant their
approval the block becomes valid and is
added to the blockchain now
simultaneously the miner who has solved
the puzzle will also receive the reward
in the meanwhile which will be of 12.5
bitcoin which as of today stands at 98k
around dollars now the bitcoins the 10
btc for which the transaction was
initiated now will get triggered and
will get transferred from beyond to
jennifer now let's take a look at
certain facts in proof of work a
predefined condition the target is
adjusted for every 2016 block which is
approximately every 14 days and an
average time to mine a block is 10
minutes so basically the target keeps
automatically adjusting itself to keep
the block generation within the 10
minute time frame so this is the
representation so in order to keep the
time frame for block generation within
10 minutes the target keeps on adjusting
itself now the difficulty of the puzzle
changes the target changes depending on
the time it takes to mine a block so
this is how a difficulty of a block is
being generated it is the hash target of
the first block divided by the hash
target of the current block so this is
the difficulty which is being changed
after every 2016 blocks so basically it
is very hard to generate the proof of
work but it is very easy to verify by
the miners so once you have solved the
puzzle and you have broadcasted that yes
you have earned you have validated a
record you have determined the puzzle
for other miners it is very easy to
verify what you have done and once they
give their consensus the majority then
the block gets validated and gets added
to the blockchain now since the
difficulty depends on the hash target
its value keep on changing after every
2016 block as i said and as you can see
in due course from the day of inception
of bitcoin in 2009 till today difficulty
has increased exponentially and it has
been increasing and thereby the entire
effort of mining and the computing power
is also increasing so as of what was the
resources which were required to do
mining in 2009 you require more hashing
power more computing power in order to
do the mining today now what if someone
tries to hack the data so let's see
blockchain is a chain of blocks abc now
each block has solved a puzzle and
generated a hash value of its own which
is its identifier now suppose a person
tries to tamper a block block b and
tries to change the data which is
aggregated in the block so if the data
of the block will change the hash value
which is the digital signature of the
block will also change thereby it will
corrupt the chain which is subsequent to
it basically the blocks ahead of block b
will all get d-linked because the
previous hash value of block c will not
remain valid so in order for the hacker
to make the entire blockchain valid for
the block b which he has changed he has
to change the hash value of all the
blocks ahead of block b which will
require huge huge amount of computing
power which will be next to impossible
so as you see the results in the
following block being invalid so with
this whole thing the blockchain is
making sure that the entire sequence
remains non-hackable and prevent data
modification now let's see what are the
underlying hardware requirements for
bitcoin mining and how the hardware is
evolved so in the early days miners used
to solve the puzzles using regular
processors the controlling processor
unit cpus now but it used to take a lot
of time for mining though the difficulty
levels were low but still it used to
take a lot of time now as i said the
difficulties never keep on changing and
growing so the miners also had to
increase the processing power so this
discovered that graphical processing
units gpus proved to be more efficient
than regular cpus so but this also had a
drawback of consumption of electricity
so any miner who has to calculate the
return on investment on the hardware he
also has to accommodate the cost of
electricity and other resources which
are going in in order to do the mining
so finally as of today they are using a
hardware called asic application
specific integrated circuit which was
specifically introduced for mining which
consumes less power and has a higher
computing power and a better hardware
for mining so miners are profitable when
their cost of resources to mine one
block is less than the price of the
reward they receive so definitely they
have to have the investment less than
the reward what they own so as of today
in blockchain miners use their resources
to verify a transaction they each time a
block is mined new bitcoins are created
in the network so the bitcoin total
supply is limited it is at 21 million
dollars approximately 21 million bitcoin
are in supply 17 to 18 million bitcoins
have already been mined so only three to
four million are left as of today a
reward of 12.5 bitcoin is given to the
miner on doing the transaction
verification but the bitcoin mining
reward goes by the huffing principle the
reward given to a miner is half every
210 000 blocks which is approximately
every four years so then after that
threshold is reached the bitcoin reward
will go down to 6.25 bitcoins so let's
take an example of a lottery ticket
where your chances of winning is
difficult so we are talking about what
is bitcoin mining pool your chances of
winning the lottery is difficult but in
a community if individuals buy multiple
lottery tickets and pool their tickets
together then this will increase their
probability and chances of winning more
so suppose you won the lottery then
based on the contribution the reward is
distributed among all the participants
bitcoin mining pool is a similar thing
it's a process where multiple nodes
share their resources together to mine a
block now when a block is solved the
miners split the reward equally based on
the amount of processing power they have
invested so it takes the pool members to
generate a final hash value then it
checks how much amount of work was
contributed by each pool member and as a
result the bitcoin reward gets
distributed proportionally amongst the
participants now let's take a look at a
demo on how can you see what is the
bitcoin reward now this is a actual
block of the bitcoin network as you can
see this is a block and
this is the block reward 12.5 bitcoin so
this was a block which was mined
this is the block number and
these are the set of transactions which
were part of this block now once this
block was mined by the miner all these
transactions then be done these are the
transfers of bitcoin from one account to
the other this is the nonce which was
generated by the miner or the mining
pool in order to mine the block and
these are the other attributes
and if you take a look at this url this
is an example of a mining pool it's a
demo account where the participants have
shared their mining resources and they
are mining it in a pool and see this is
the reward for which they are mining
this is the unconfirmed reward this is
the confirmed reward this is what they
have already validated and this is what
they have earned so far so these are the
hash these are the block numbers which
they have mine
ethereum and its concepts
ethereum
simply put while bitcoin is defined as
digital money ethereum is a
decentralized platform that runs the
smart contracts exactly the way they are
programmed without any downtime
fraud and third-party interference and
also has its own cryptocurrency called
ether
ethereum aims to enable innovations in
three key areas
currency assurance through ether which
serves as an innate currency for the
ethereum blockchain decentralized
autonomous organization
smart contracts
features of ethereum
the first feature of ethereum is that it
is secure because it is almost
impossible to tamper with the
transactions in the block or to add any
fraudulent blocks in the network
the second feature of ethereum is its
community following
ethereum has attracted a lot of
attention from people all over the world
the third feature of ethereum is its
corporate friendly structure
the platform is being leveraged by a
number of corporates to test and build
various applications
the fourth feature that we will take a
look at is the possibility of creating
new assets on ethereum blockchain that
can be used as currency a representation
of an asset
a virtual share
a proof of membership or anything at all
the next feature is the ability of
ethereum to process the transactions
fast
while bitcoin requires a block time of
10 minutes in ethereum it's only a few
seconds
the last feature that we will discuss is
the fact that ethereum is uncensored
ethereum's open source network allows
complete transparency to view every
transaction
all right that's all about the features
of ethereum let me tell you about an
important concept in ethereum called gas
gas in ethereum
gas is the fundamental block of ethereum
ecosystem that is paid for every
operation performed on the ethereum
blockchain
it is the crypto fuel for ethereum it
can be considered a transaction fee
which has to be paid when one party
sends ethers to another party
even when a person deploys a smart
contract on the ethereum blockchain a
transaction fee needs to be paid for
that as well this payment has to be made
regardless of whether the transaction
succeeds or fails
gas price is expressed in ether and the
miner decides whether to refuse the
transaction process or not based on the
expected gas price
one can see their transaction fee in eth
or usd
when searching for the transaction on
etherscan.io
when somebody refers to gas they are
either talking about gas price or gas
limit
the total cost of a transaction is the
product of gas limit and gas price
the gas limit is defined as a limit
since it's the maximum amount of units
of gas one is willing to spend on a
single
transaction this avoids situations where
there is an error somewhere in the
contract and you end up spending a very
high amount of gas
however the units of gas required for a
transaction are defined by the amount of
code executed on the blockchain
lowering the gas limit below the amount
required will not help much
if enough gas to cover the computational
resources of the network is not supplied
with the transaction
the transaction will fail due to an out
of gas error
so
gas is a commodity which is essentially
a cost of using the system
like bitcoins ethereum also has its
currency which is called ether
ether
it is an incentive that the client of
the platform pays to execute requested
operations
it ensures that the developer's write
error-free codes because unnecessary
codes will increase the cost
ethereum is a blockchain-based platform
and ether is the cryptocurrency that
fuels the platform it is commonly
denoted as eth
let's have a look at the differences
between bitcoin and ether
bitcoin versus ether the first
difference is in the hashtag algorithm
used by these cryptocurrencies
while bitcoin uses sha-256
to encrypt blocks of blockchain
ethereum uses eth to encrypt blocks
technically both are one-way
cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
bitcoin and ether
as we have discussed earlier bitcoin is
only used for financial transactions
like purchase and sale of goods and
services however
ethereum being a touring complete
platform also supports smart contracts
and decentralized applications
the third difference is in the price of
the two cryptocurrencies
currently the price of btc is
approximately 3 500 u.s dollars while
that of eth is approximately 100 u.s
dollars
the market cap of btc is almost six
times greater than that of btc even
though eth has a higher circulating
supply
the fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two
cryptocurrencies
btc is a currency created to compete
against the gold and flat currencies by
acting as an alternative however eth is
created as a token to facilitate smart
contract deployment and operations
lastly the transaction speed of btc is
much slower than eth
while btc's transaction speed is
measured in minutes eth is just a few
seconds
like bitcoins ethers are also stored in
cryptocurrency wallets
let's understand what are wallets in
ethereum
ethereum virtual machine
ethereum wallets a wallet is the place
to securely store ethers and other
cryptocurrencies basically a wallet
stores the means of accessing your
currency using the private key
now that i have told you about the
ethereum and its currency
it will only be fair that i explain evm
now
evm
ethereum virtual machine abbreviated as
evm
is an engine which executes translation
code
smart contracts are compiled into
bytecode which an evm can read and
execute
the ethereum virtual machine can be
regarded as a quasi touring complete
machine
it possesses its own programming
language known as the evm bytecode
once the code is written in higher level
programming languages the code can be
compiled to an evm byte code
the ethereum virtual machine uses a set
of instructions called opcodes to
execute specific tasks thus if a user
triggers a transaction of 5 eth using
his desktop wallet the wallet sends the
message to the evm which connects with
the wallet address on the ethereum
network to process the transaction and
send it to the receiver
smart contracts are written in ethereum
specific programming languages
let's learn more about these languages
ethereum languages
every contract written for ethereum is
compiled into the evm byte code and
deployed to ethereum blockchain for
execution
ethereum uses the following languages
the first language is solidity
solidity is an object-oriented
high-level language used for
implementation of smart contracts on the
ethereum blockchain
solidity was influenced by python c plus
plus and javascript
it is designed to target the evm
the second language is a low-level lisp
like language
abbreviated as triple l it is one of the
original ethereum smart contract
programming languages and is similar to
assembly
it is meant to be a very simple and
minimalistic language essentially
serving as a tiny wrapper over coding in
evm directly
the third language is viper which is a
contract oriented programming language
influenced by python the fourth language
is serpent which is an assembly language
that compiles to evm code that is
extended with various high-level
features
the next language is mutant
mutant is similar to c like language and
supports a dynamic
full higher level language
it compiles to native ethereum assembler
however mutant is now deprecated
the last language is julia
it is an intermediate language that can
compile to various different backends
like evm 1.0 evm 1.5 and
ewasm
let me now tell you about the accounts
handled by ethereum
types of ethereum accounts
externally owned accounts
eoa is an account controlled by a
private key that has the ability to send
ethers and messages from it
following are some of the properties of
an externally owned account
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no associated code
smart contract
smart contract is a code running on top
of the blockchain
containing a set of rules for the nodes
to agree upon so that they can interact
with each other
as an account it has the following
properties
firstly it has an ether balance
secondly it has an associated code
thirdly a code execution is triggered by
transactions or messages received from
other contracts
and fourthly when executed it performs
operations of arbitrary complexity some
of the advantages of smart contracts are
as follows
first smart contract is the simplest way
of implementing decentralization
second it provides a high degree of
security
third it eliminates the need for a third
party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement fifth it turns legal
obligations into an automated processes
and lastly it lowers the transaction
cost
characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self-verifying and
self-executing
they operate autonomously to execute the
terms of the contract and verify the
transactions without the need of a
third-party intervention
the elimination of third parties reduces
the cost of operations and further makes
the contracts tamper resistant
process of smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works first
an optional contract between the parties
is written as a code into the blockchain
the individuals involved are anonymous
but the contact is made through a public
ledger then a trigger event like an
expiration date or a strike price is hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms
next regulators can use the blockchain
to understand the activities in the
market while maintaining the privacy of
an individual's position let me show you
the implementation of smart contract in
a simple use case
smart contract example
here we have an example showing the
purchase and sale of a house thus once a
buyer is matched with a seller all
assets are sent into the contract
the contract then distributes the assets
based on certain predetermined
conditions agreed between both parties
and coded into the smart contract
thus the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes undisputed due to the
transparency of blockchain
eoa versus smart contract
in this slide we will understand the
difference between an eoa and a smart
contract based on four critical
properties
nonce
in an externally owned account nonce
represents the number of transactions
sent from the accounts address
however in a contract account the nonce
is the number of contracts created by
the account
the next property is balance this number
shows the amount of whey owned by the
address whether the eoa or contract
account
each ether is divided into 1e plus 18
wei the next property is code hash it is
the hash of the ethereum virtual machine
code of an account this is the code that
gets executed if this address receives a
message call
it is immutable and thus it cannot be
changed once the construction is done
for externally owned accounts the code
hash field is the hash of the empty
string
for contract accounts this is the code
that gets hashed and is stored as the
code hash
the last property is storage root it is
a 256 bit hash of the root node of a
merkle tree that encodes the storage
contents of the account encoded into the
tree as a mapping from the keycap 256
bit hash of the 256 bit integer keys to
the rlp encoded 256 bit integer values
this tree encodes the hash of the
storage contents of this account and is
empty by default
that was all about the ethereum concepts
and accounts
let's understand the process of mining
now
ethereum mining
ethereum mining
ethereum makes use of proof-of-work
mechanism to ensure security
the algorithm used in ethereum is called
ethash
each time an ethereum transaction is
made a miner is responsible for ensuring
the authenticity of information and
updating the blockchain with the
transaction
let's consider an example where bob
wants to send one eth to alice
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process that is followed in
order to confirm this transaction
through mining
first bob attempts to send alice 1 eth
once bob's transaction is initiated it
is combined with other transactions that
have occurred in the last block
the miners will then validate the block
with a new set of instructions
once validated the miner creates a new
block and is rewarded for it
thus
alice receives one eth after the
transaction is validated
ethereum mining
the term transaction is used in ethereum
to refer to the signed data package that
contains a message to be sent from an
eoa to another account on the blockchain
ethereum blocks contain two things a
transaction list and a recent state of
the ledger that comprises these
transactions
in the example shown on the screen we
can see a transaction where one wallet
sends 20 eth to another wallet the
diagram shows the previous state and the
next state for the transaction
state storage
the states are assembled into a state
tree that is linked to the account and
the block
the ethereum includes state routes that
store the root hash of the hash tree
which represents the system state when
the block was created
now we will take a look at the
step-by-step process to see how ethereum
stores transactions
first a hash is generated for each
transaction
then pairs are selected and a hash is
generated for each pair
this way the last remaining hash becomes
the root
the block header as seen in the image on
the screen contains the previous block
hash and three merkle trees these trees
are to maintain the state to maintain
the transactions and to maintain the
receipts
also each block always refers to its
previous blocks hash
ethereum ecosystem
types of ethereum tools
the ethereum ecosystem consists of eight
major tools
they are
geth
ganache
parity
metamask
missed wallet
sporm
ipfs
whisper
now let's move forward and take a look
at each of these in detail
geth
geth is a multipurpose command line tool
that runs an ethereum node implemented
in go
it is the official golang implementation
of the ethereum protocol and is commonly
used to interact with the ethereum
network
though there are several ways to
download geth the fastest one is to get
it from the ethereum.org website
next we have ganache cli
ganache cli
ganache cli is a customizable and fast
emulator for blockchain which permits
making calls to blockchain without the
need for running an actual ethereum node
following are some of the properties of
ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost
thirdly accounts can be recycled reset
and instantiated with a fixed number of
ether without the need for faucets or
mining
fourthly gas price and mining speed can
be modified
fifthly a convenient gui gives you an
overview of your test chain events
parity
parity is the fastest lightest and most
secure ethereum client that provides the
core infrastructure essentials for quick
and reliable services
parity is written in rust language it
offers better reliability code clarity
and performance
it is an ethereum client that is
integrated directly into your web
browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of basic ether and token
wallet it also serves as an ethereum gui
browser
it provides access to a diverse range of
ethereum features including d apps
meta mask
metamask turns google chrome into a
browser that allows the users to send
and receive transactions and also fetch
data from the blockchain
it is a browser-based wallet which can
be added as a plug-in to your chrome
browser
it permits you to run ethereum d-apps
directly from your browser without the
need for running a full ethereum node
metamask accounts
practically it is unrealistic for
everyone in the world to run a node to
interact with the ethereum blockchain to
overcome this metamask hosts a number of
nodes so you don't have to
a user simply needs to install metamask
and can automatically get connected to
the nodes
thus you can use the ethereum blockchain
seamlessly
let's talk mist which is another
important tool of the blockchain
ecosystem
missed wallet
mist wallet is the end user interface
for ethereum that is developed for
browsing and using d-apps
mist is an official ethereum wallet it
was developed and distributed by the
team which is responsible for the
management of ethereum ecosystem it is
usually used by developers who want to
create deploy and use smart contracts
it is a full node wallet which means
you'll have to download the entire
ethereum blockchain onto your computer
some of the applications of missed
wallet is as follows
first sending and receiving transactions
second
storing ether
third creating multi-signature wallets
and fourth deploying smart contracts
swarm
swarm is a platform which supports
distributed storage and provides content
distribution services
it acts as a native base layer service
of the ethereum web 3 stack
it provides sufficient decentralization
and redundant storage of ethereum
records to distribute blockchain data as
well as d-app codes
it leverages the underlying ethereum
infrastructure through the use of
contracts and ethers to encourage
cooperation among nodes
the files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nodes of the network an
accounting protocol is used by peers to
keep track of these chunks delivered and
received and resulting micropayments
associated with it
ipfs
ipfs is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to ethereum
but can be integrated with it
ipfs
stores data by use of a distributed hash
table or dht
once we know the hash we request the
peer network who has a copy of the
content located at the corresponding
hash
and then we download the content from
the node who has the desired data which
we need
the data transfer between the nodes in
the network uses a mechanism which is
similar to the one used in bittorrent
it also provides a versioned file system
capable of storing files and tracking
versions over time
thus it defines how files move across a
network making it a distributed file
system by combining all of these
properties ipfs is enabling a new
permanent web and augmenting the way we
use existing internet protocols like
http
whisper
whisper is an identity based
communication protocol for d apps to
interact with each other
d apps that need to publish small
amounts of information to each other and
have the publication last some
substantial amount of time prefer using
whisper
for instance
a d app running a currency exchange may
use whisper to record an offer to buy a
currency at a pre-agreed price on the
exchange platform
some of the drawbacks of whisper are as
follows
it has low level api which is only
exposed to d apps and never to users
second it has low bandwidth and is not
designed for large data transfers
third it has uncertain latency
and lastly
it has no reliable methods for tracing
packets
ethereum frameworks
we'll look at two types of ethereum
frameworks
web3.js
web3.js is a set of libraries which
permit one to interact with a remote or
local ethereum node
it can be done with the use of ipc or an
http connection the key connection
between ethereum network and dap that
allows you to compile deploy and
interact with smart contracts is called
web3.js
it gives us a way to build a website or
client that can talk to the ethereum
blockchain
let's take an example of traditional
development
when you develop a website
it talks to apis using json or jquery to
make ajax calls
a website talks to blockchain using web3
using json.rpc
which is similar to making a remote
procedure call
ethereum comprises of a large number of
nodes which talk to each other
we use
jsonrpc to make a request to a
particular node which is like an api
call
thus if we want to talk to a smart
contract or read an account we do it
through web3
ethe.js
it is a highly optimized lightweight js
utility for ethereum based on web.js
in this all the unnecessary characters
are removed from the source code and the
code is reduced to 160 kilobytes
ethereum development environment
the three commonly used ethereum
development environments include remix
ide
truffle
and embark
let's understand these environments in a
little more detail
remix ide
remix ide is a browser compiler and ide
that enables users to debug transactions
and build ethereum contracts with
solidity language
you can simply log on to the web-based
editor write the code and compile the
same to create the byte code in order to
test your code
the next slide shows how remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle
truffle is a development environment
testing framework and asset pipeline for
blockchains using the ethereum virtual
machine or evm
it helps users in developing smart
contracts
publish the contracts and test them
then we have embark
embark embark is an environment that
allows you to easily develop and deploy
decentralized applications
it performs the following functions
first automatic deployment of contracts
second keeping track of deployed
contracts
third
managing the complex systems of
interdependent contracts
fourth
performing test driven deployment with
contracts using javascript
fifth
managing different chains like test net
private net and livenet and lastly
redeploy the contracts if any changes
are done
let's talk about ethereum networks
ethereum network
the basis for decentralized consensus is
the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes which maintain and
secure the blockchain
a node is defined as a device or a
program that can communicate with the
ethereum blockchain network
they are also referred to as clients
they provide wallet functionality and
allow users to perform transactions on
the blockchain
thus a node serves as a machine running
as an ethereum client
it is used to store the data and
transfer money it is formed by combining
one or more nodes and each node contains
a copy of the blockchain
type subnetwork there are three main
types of networks the testnet the main
net and the private network
ethereum d-apps and daos
d-app
decentralized application is an
application that is used on networks
with trustless protocols to avoid a
single point of failure
they run on a peer-to-peer computer
network all the activity which takes
place on an ethereum decentralized
application
is cryptographically secured on the
blockchain
d-apps are open source which means that
everyone can verify the contents of the
software
some properties of d-apps are as follows
it uses ethereum as a development
platform it uses cryptographically
encoded blocks
it is not governed by a central server
and there is no master copy of d-app
let's talk about the advantages of
d-apps now advantages of d-app
ethereum d-apps have the following
advantages
improved stability due to a distributed
network
higher reliability
automatic credentials assigned through
smart contracts
no downtime
no third-party intervention
and high security
example of d-apps
some of the known examples of d-apps
include we fund
storage
kyc chain
and 4g capital these companies have
developed different applications using
blockchain
next we have the
daos dao
daos or organizations designed to hold
assets and use the voting system to
distribute them
they exist entirely on blockchain and
are governed by the consensus protocols
they show the potential of blockchain to
revolutionize human social institutions
called daos
it is an organization run by rules
agreed through a consensus process among
its members and written in a set of
contracts run via a blockchain
it is an open source software capable of
modification by its members
process of a dao
now let's take an example and see how
this works
let's consider that a country is holding
elections and wants to prevent fraud in
the voting system
a dao is created to keep transparency in
the voting
this is insured by embedding predefined
conditions in the code
people eligible to vote are assigned
voting tokens and the voting starts
every vote is processed on the ethereum
blockchain and it ensures transparency
by allowing everything to run in a
decentralized way in this video we will
explore ethereum mining and will go
through some of the fascinating concepts
and components revolving around it first
we will have an introduction to ethereum
then we will understand what is ethereum
mining
then we will explore why should we mine
ethereum
we will look into the types of ethereum
mining
and then we will understand how the
ethereum mining process works
then we should explore how exactly to
mine ethereum
then we will discuss will the proof of
stake transaction kill proof of work
and then finally we will find out is
mining ethereum profitable
so without doing much ado let's get
started with the video
let's bring you up to speed on ethereum
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secured in the network
ether is the cryptocurrency of ethereum
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
ether basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network it tracks and
facilitates all the transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple words ethereum mining is a
process of creating and adding a block
of transaction to the blockchain network
of ethereum
it uses the proof-of-work consensus
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network needs to get approved
by the miners
miners is a community of people using a
hashing strip etas to solve
computationally hard puzzles for
successfully mining the blocks of
transactions in the ethereum blockchain
network
which helps secure the network from
attacks like hacking or manipulation of
identity
now let's understand why we need to mine
ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money a their demanding contract
of sectoring the network into a
relatively complex but profitable
business
also miners receive a certain amount as
a reward for mining each block of the
ethereum blockchain network
including the transaction fees paid by
the users
thus iterative mining benefits each and
everyone participating in ethereum
blockchain network
so
what are the types of ethereum mining
ethereum mining can be performed in
three ways
ethereum solar mining ethereum pool
mining and ethereum cloud mining
in ethereum solar mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mine the itarium block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies you have to be very
good at your work
also solar mining is only profitable
when you have plenty of resources with
you like 100 plus graphics cards
and in solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of air needed
iterating coal mining is the easiest and
fastest way to get started with itaria
mining
in this you work along with other people
together in a single pool
and if someone from the pool gets the
hash code correctly they share the
reward among everyone in the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool life pool
size minimum payout and pool fee
pool size determines the number of
blocks you find in the ethereum network
and it shares the word
as the number of miners increases the
chances to get rewards also increase
minimum payout is the minimum amount of
ethereum you need to mine before it gets
credited to your wallet
and 40 is the amount you need to pay to
continue using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum you're mining
ethereum cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to my ethereum
for you
you pay some amount of money as peace to
them for investing their time and
resources
and in return they provide you with the
reward they gained by the mining
ethereum
first
this technique of mining ethereum has to
be close and constantly suppose you're
not responsible for any equipment damage
you don't have to require all the
necessary equipment and look for ample
space to store it
you can set back observe market and
enjoy the reward for your investment
interior mining
cons in the italian price drop then
there is no way you are getting your
money back the money you invested or the
fees paid to the miner is lost
and you can't ask the other person to
change the equipment according to your
concern
italian cloud mining is considered a
safer way for mining service providers
to guarantee a profit for the resource
they have purchased
now let's understand how the ethereum
mining process works
ethereum mining follows a specific set
of steps to function
step 1 a user requests a transaction
with the help of the private key of his
digital wallet account
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pending transactions that
needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
step 4 the miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction and
perform a complex mathematical puzzle on
the transaction data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified and it stores a copy of it in
india the process of proof of work
begins for the respective block
step six then the notes of the ethereum
network verify that the checksum of the
state of the miner's block
matches the checksum of the updated
state of the email after execution of
all transactions
step 7 only after that the block is
added to the italian blockchain network
step 8 on successfully mining the block
it rewards the miner with some amount of
ether in their wallet the block reward
of ethereum is 3 ether
at step nine the requested transaction
is approved and credited for the
respective wallet or wallet
each transaction is mined only once but
every participant of the ethereum
network verifies
it this makes me curious about how to
mine ethereum
tools you will need to be an efficient
miner for ethereum on your personal
computer are an ethereal wallet to store
all your currency on gpu drivers or
graphics card with a minimum of 3gb ram
a mining software suitable according to
your hardware like gpa
and a compatible operating system
windows 7 or 10 with 64 bit
before getting started with mining
iteration you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your ether
pressure model d and ledger nano are the
most reliable and secure wallets in the
market of cryptocurrency
installing gpu drivers or graphics card
after creating your digital wallet
you'll need to update all the hardware
that is drives in your system you can
use two types of graphics card they are
amd graphics card and nvidia graphics
card
claymore is considered the best
processor mining ethereum on gp drivers
now we need to follow a few
set of steps to get started with mining
step 1 download the latest version of
claymore dual miner for the operating
system
the latest version is claymore 11.0
step 2 click on the latest version of
windows and download the zip file
step 3 extract the file with claymore
11.0 to a folder on desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5. right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6. edit the start.txt file and add
these lines
step 7
choose your desired pool from these
recommendations
you can also find better search results
than these according to your region
step 8 type in your full address instead
of mining pool address
step 9 save your start.txt file within
new updates
remember while saving select type as all
files
and step 10 once you save click on the
clay.bat file to begin mining ethereum
now let's explore will the proof of
state transition field grouper work
the newly introduced concept of ethereum
2.0 the roadmap plans to upgrade to
proof of stake
consensus algorithm in which it will
provide all existing miners of the dairy
network with a limited time to earn a
return for the investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021
or the starting of 2022
it was supposed to be launched by
october 2020 but the history of delays
regarding this update is worth talking
about
nobody truly knows when ethereum 2.0
will be completed and introduced to the
crypto mining world
now we may know all about ethereum
mining this makes me wonder if ethereum
mining is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity in
that particular area
as a rule anything below
0.12
per kilowatt consumes in an hour is
considered profitable
you can mine ether and turn it into a
vital source of income by analyzing
these figures like hash rate of ethereum
block reward number of blocks per day
and the coin price of ethereum
you can also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors
or you can use this formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years so it is
an excellent opportunity to invest in
and save an ethereum
in this video we will explore ethereum
2.0 and will go through some of the
fascinating concepts and components
revolving around it
so what is the ethereum network
ethereum
is defined as a blockchain based
computing platform that enables its
developers to build and deploy
decentralized application
ether is the cryptocurrency for ethereum
used to build decentralized application
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
it tracks and facilitates all the
transactions and make sure they are
cryptographically secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades that will make the ethereum
network more secure scalable and
sustainable multiple teams from across
the ethereum ecosystem have come
together to work on these upgrades in
ethereum 2.0
then what led to the region of ethereum
2.0
the growing popularity ether and the
ethereum network has gotten more blocked
by transactions
currently it is capable of handling 15
to 45 transactions per second
which is comparatively impressive but it
is not enough to handle all of italian's
users worldwide
also the high demand is affecting the
driving up of transaction fees
nodes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently its nodes are
experiencing too much volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed that making its
nodes bigger wouldn't be practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable to handle all of the
activities on the ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.0
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of stake and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations suffer from
performance issues because they rely on
a processing power intensive process
known as proof of work
to record and validate their
transactions
the problem with proof of works design
is that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof of stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency and
ability to scale
in the current version of ethereum
blockchain all data that is added to the
chain
undergoes verification by all
participating nodes that means that the
speed of its fluids participant limits
the processing speed of the entire
network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources by bringing data
verification tasks among its set of
nodes
and each of them will be responsible for
validating and verifying just the data
allotted to them
this will increase the network's overall
capacity and make it much faster and
efficient than its outdated version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
why ethereum 2.0 has been in research
and development since 2014.
it has actually been making some
progress the beacon chain went live in
december 2020 introducing the staging
concept but still there is no official
claim for the completion of this
transition
the next phase is mainnet
merging the beacon chain into the
current ethereum network
mining ethereum tokens will officially
end in this phase and staking will
become the primary way to create new
tokens in the ethereum network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the shard genes to give the
ethereum blockchain network more
capacity and efficiency to handle all of
the demand and increased transactions
per second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated and on their way to completing
the whole transition so what is the
future of ethereum 2.0
if executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0 could be a total game
changer it will create a modified
network that could potentially process
one lag transactions per second
and a much more sustainable network
without the energy intensive mining
process and it will introduce smart
contracts worldwide
increasing the ethereum's network
utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
alex buterin once said that the issuance
of new token should be highly reduced
under ethereum 2.0
which could increase its demand
given all these factors ethereum 2.0
seems to hold a bright future for
ethereum blockchain network in the
previous videos we covered what bitcoin
and ethereum are let's proceed further
and have a look at how they both differ
from each other did you know there are
more than 1600 cryptocurrencies
worldwide
and among them bitcoin and ethereum have
always been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world by market
cap
also recently ethereum as well as
bitcoin reached its all-time peak in
worldwide trading
according to decrypt.go everyday new
companies like meto and paypal are
coming forward to invest in bitcoin and
ethereum
on march 7 2021 metoo confirmed that it
had purchased 40 million in bitcoin and
ethereum on the other hand people is
about to launch a scheme where the
public can purchase and sell
cryptocurrencies initially featuring
bitcoin and ethereum via paypal digital
wallet
but have you all ever wondered how they
compare based on their similarities and
differences in various aspects well
before moving any further let's have a
quick look at how bitcoin and ethereum
originated and made a benchmark in the
economic system worldwide
bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
satoshi nakamoto to resolve cyber
attacks double spending and eliminate
the middle man between the transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
on the other hand ethereum came into the
picture years after bitcoin it was first
introduced in the late 2013 by vitalik
buterin after that it was very quickly
and widely adopted because it offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized application
now let's move ahead and see the
difference between them which make them
compete with each other in this economy
this video will cover individual aspects
for comparing ethereum and bitcoin's
performance in that particular field
first we will look into the introduction
of ethereum and bitcoin
then the algorithm they follow
the programming language
mining process of ethereum and bitcoin
monetary policy
transaction
and availability of these two
cryptocurrencies
by time bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency however
ethereum with different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but before moving ahead let's
have an introduction to ethereum and
bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an application
for its users without any centralized
interference for bitcoin it is an
alternative to fiat money or physical
currency the main function of ethereum
is to provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using dapps or decentralized application
on the other side bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money and
value stored in its blockchain network
now let's get started and move towards
the first comparison which is algorithm
ethereum uses the etas cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network on the other hand
bitcoin uses the she-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
bitcoin network
e algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function
proof of work is a small piece of data
that is difficult to generate but easy
to validate and satisfy certain network
requirements
sag 256 algorithm helps bitcoin users to
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys moving on the programming
language of ethereum
and bitcoin ethereum uses solidity
solidity is a high-level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts but in
terms of programming language bitcoin
keeps it simple bitcoin uses c plus as
its programming language it is a stack
based programming language used to give
bitcoin software instructions on how to
make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies now let's take a look
at the mining process of both
mining is a process in which transaction
made are validated and added to
blockchain public ledger and blocks and
the people mining these blocks are
called miners
ethereum miners mine the unvalidated
transaction using the proof of work
method but it aims to switch to proof of
stake because it will make its network
more immune to centralization energy
efficient and stronger support for its
shared chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the
proof-of-work method to mine unvalidated
transactions
these method is enough to function in
bitcoin network worldwide now let's
proceed towards the monetary policy of
both cryptocurrencies but let's first
understand what monetary policy is
monetary policy is known as the process
of drafting announcing and implementing
the plan of actions taken by the
competent monetary authority to control
the money supply and achieve goals that
promote sustainable economic growth so
italian's policy is defined by the
reward paid out by its protocol
ethereum's monetary policies are best
described as minimum issuance to secure
the network therefore there is a
constant trade-off between the
transaction speed and security but
bitcoin's monetary policy comprises two
parts halving and block frequency
halving event is when the reward of
mining bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block the current
block reward for ethereum is two ether
per block and for bitcoin the block
reward is 12.5 bitcoins per block
also every 14 seconds a block of
ethereum is generated and one block of
bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate
monetary policies are considered to be
fixed and non-inflationary due to this
over time mining blocks will become more
difficult next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it on the other side bitcoin's
transaction speed is 5 transactions per
second and it can take up to 60 minutes
or more to confirm either the currency
of ethereum acts as the fuel for
ethereum networks and bitcoin is only
used as the value for real-world
transaction to compete with already
present electronic cash like credit
cards and google pay it element bitcoin
require higher productivity to attain
widespread adoption not talking about
the availability of both
cryptocurrencies
ethereum is not limited but it can
occasionally reduce due to large network
upgrades however bitcoin is limited to
21 million coins and as of today 18
million bitcoin is already used
but in the end both bitcoin and ethereum
being the top crypto currencies share a
few similarities like both are
decentralized and can be used to have a
peer-to-peer transaction
proof of work also both have a large
network of independent nodes now let's
have a demo now let's have a look at the
media outlet website coindesk where we
will see all stats related to bitcoin
and ethereum in detail
coindesk is a site specialized in
digital currencies it is used to explore
the news and price data related to
cryptocurrencies and also explains how
cryptocurrencies contribute to the
evolution of financial system worldwide
now see this graph this graph shows the
change in bitcoin price in 24 hours
duration
this graph shows the gradual change in
the price of bitcoin it started from
sixty four thousand four hundred thirty
nine point two nine dollars on april 14
at 12 p.m
and right now by april 15 at 6 00 am it
is at 63 189
the rate of change is minus zero point
four six percent which shows the change
in the price of bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum two
the value of ethereum started at 2388.13
on april 14 at 12 p.m and the current
status on april 15 is positive with a
value of
forty two 2442.8 three seven dollars
with an increasing rate of four point
six seven percent down below we have a
metric stable that shows the change
between the starting and ending value of
ethereum the total supply of a
cryptocurrency in 24 hours the total
number of transaction that occurred and
the average transaction fee for all
these transactions now this graph shows
the current status of cryptocurrency in
usd dollars we can also see its value
according to any centralized currency
like euro or inr this graph shows the
concentrating change in the value of
cryptocurrencies every moment
we can also access the data of trading
from an hour to its lifetime recently we
all have been hearing about a
cryptocurrency famously known as
dogecoin but what exactly makes it so
different from others that almost every
person is talking about it so let me
tell you that dogecoin is an altcoin and
an almost sarcastic mean coin that
serves as a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency
well that's not enough
so let's dive down and understand the
concept of dogecoin more precisely but
before starting let's have a look at why
is it in the news since the beginning of
the year 2021 dogecoin has surged more
than 950 percent from less than half a
penny to more than five cents per
dogecoin
then elon musk ceo of teslin corporation
took his interest in it and tweeted too
much concentration is the only real
issue for cryptocurrency making the
owner of the dogecoin wallet a subject
of attention later on other celebs like
snoop dogg also started taking an
interest in dogecoin and started
tweeting and promoting it on social
platforms which made dogecoin climb to a
peak of 8.2 us cents and market
capitalization of 10 billion dollars
in this video we will come across the
following topics first we will see the
origin of dogecoin and then we will
understand what is dogecoin how does it
exactly works
and then we will see what led to the
growth of dogecoin
what are the areas of uses of dogecoin
then we will figure out what is the
current value of dogecoin today
and lastly how can we buy it let's start
with the origin of dogecoin
dogecoin was invented by two software
engineers ibm engineer billy marcus and
adobe engineer jackson palmer did you
know that they never even met before
combining the two most significant
phenomena of the year 2013 bitcoin and
deutsche well now let's move ahead and
see what is dogecoin dogecoin is a
peer-to-peer open source cryptocurrency
that provides its user a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transaction
dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a meme coin inspired by sheba inu's
popular meme aka doge moving ahead let's
have a look at how it works to
understand the workflow let's take the
example of two friends mark and susan
mark owes some money to susan and now he
needs to return it
so he thinks of an idea and decides to
send her dogecoin instead of giving her
physical money
they both open their digital wallet
account
to pay her he needs two essential pieces
of information
first his private key
and second her public key
to get access to susan's private key he
needs to scan a qr code from his
smartphone
then the application alerts all the
dogecoin miners around the world to
proceed further with the process the
dogecoin miners validate whether mark
has enough dogecoin to make the payment
or not
and after the validation process they
approve the transaction request dogecoin
miners race with each other to collect
all the data of the pending transaction
known as the nonce
the miners then apply a mathematical
function to produce the correct hash
number for the particular nonce of the
pending transaction the miner who
successfully produces the correct hash
number is rewarded with 25 dogecoin in
his account
after that mark and susan gets a
confirmation message that they request
for the transaction has been approved
and within 10 minutes the requested
amount of dogecoin is credited into the
wallet of susan
thus the transaction is completed so
what led to the growth of dogecoin
dogecoin officially came live in 2013
and became an instant hit within the
community of people who just wanted to
play around the cryptocurrencies freely
as i said earlier dogecoin was intended
to be a joke for content creators but
they were very well received it uses of
internet forums like reddit and twitter
adopted dogecoin and started tipping
their content creators this usage of
dogecoin made it surpass the trading
value of the other cryptocurrencies
specifically bitcoin in 2014.
it also started doing charity work to
introduce and promote themselves in the
real world for example once they raise a
fund of 55 000
for a nascar driver josh weiss and in
return he printed the logo and 98
dogecoin over this race car eventually
it almost became the mascot for what
crypto should be
let's have a look at who uses dogecoin
today many companies and firms like
restaurants process
web hosting
products retailer ebook sellers and
travel services uses dogecoin for
transaction these are a few examples
of companies in every sector that uses
dogecoin
grossers hello pets
gamerheats.com for web hosting
gamer
for products retailer meltdown and
noddex
ebook seller canal and travel services
like bello leo dot it this makes me
curious about the current value of
dogecoin let's have a look at that too
according to the market cap today the
current value of dogecoin is 0.059357
usd with a trading volume of 16 billion
dollars the circulating supply of this
cryptocurrency is 129 billion dogecoin
and the max supply of dogecoin is not
available
how can we buy dogecoin
so to buy dogecoin we will have to
follow a few steps step 1 open a digital
wallet bayou coin is considered a
perfect application for trading
cryptocurrencies step 2 register your
account
step 3 complete your profile kyc by
providing your identity and address
proof like aadhaar step 4 add your bank
account details
step five secure your account by
creating a convenient trading pin that
is only accessible by you
and step six
there you go now you can start trading
that is all about dogecoin currently we
have heard a lot of buzz about the
cryptocurrency dogecoin and the
shenanigans of its community
did you know that on 20th april 2020
dogecoin searched its value to one
dollar
making this day named after itself as
day
the supporters of dogecoin were trying
to amplify the value of it to make it
one dollar
but how is it done in reality how can we
affect the value and availability of
cryptocurrency
well all this is done by a process
called mining
and this is what affected torch coin
resulting in the rise of its value
mining coins of the dogecoin network is
called dogecoin mining
now let's move ahead and see what's in
this video for you
first we will have an introduction to
what is dogecoin
then we will figure out the net worth of
dogecoin today
we will understand what dogecoin mining
is
then we will have a comparison of mining
process of dogepoint with a few other
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
then we will dive into how to mine
dogecoin
in this segment first we will see types
of dogecoin mining like pool and solo
then we will see what exactly you
require to start dogecoin mining
what hardware and software you need for
dogecoin mining
and then we will understand a new
concept of dogecoin mining which is
dogecoin cloud mining
and in the end we will analyze whether
those calling mining is profitable or
not
so let's get started and have a quick
look at what is dot coin
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on blockchain
technology
also it provides its users a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transactions
doshown uses cryptography to secure all
its transactions
this makes me curious to know what is
the net worth and availability of those
coin today
according to market cap today the
current value of dogecoin is
0.266247 usd
the circulating supply of this
cryptocurrency is 127 billion dogecoin
so that brings us to what is dogecoin
mining
dogecoin mining is a process of
validating the data blocks of
transactions by solving a complex
mathematical problem and adding them to
the dogecoin network
each confirmation of transactions adds a
new block to the deutsche coin network
miners perform this process dogecoin
miners are a community of people who
perform complex mathematical solutions
on the transactions for mining dogecoin
that makes me wonder what the difference
between dogecoin mining and other
cryptocurrencies mining process
let's have a comparison between dogecoin
mining and the bitcoin mining process
we will be comparing these crypto mining
based on these factors
first
algorithm
it is a set of rules that every
cryptocurrency follows for mining new
coins
in the algorithm dogecoin mining uses
script bitcoin mining uses she-256
script is considered a lot quicker and
cheaper than the ssj256 algorithm making
mining easier for miners of the dogecoin
network
second is difficulty
this represents the complexities and
challenges faced by miners to mine each
block of the blockchain of any
cryptocurrency
in difficulty dogecoin is 2798
2252 bitcoin is 3 trillion five hundred
eleven billion sixty million
five hundred fifty two thousand eight
hundred ninety nine thus it proves that
dogecoin is easier to mine among other
cryptocurrencies
third is block time
it is the time taken by a new block of
transactions to be checked confirmed and
added to the blockchain block time of
dogecoin is one minute for bitcoin it is
10 minutes
and at 4th and fifth we have reward per
block and per block usd
it is the amount
in usd to the miner for each block added
to the network
block reward for dogecoin is 10 000
dodge coins per block which in usd is
27.36 dodge coins
for bitcoin it is 12.5 bitcoin per block
and in usd it is 86
391.63 bitcoins
moving on finally we have reached the
most crucial point of this video now we
will have a look at how to mine dogecoin
dogecoin can be mined in two ways
the first one
dogecoin pool mining and the second is
solo mining
a dogecoin pool is a group of people who
share their computing power to mine
dogecoin transaction data and get
rewarded by equal share after confirming
the transaction
solo mining is when only one person does
all the work of mining and confirming
transactions
the reward is awarded only to that
person after confirming the transaction
let's have a thorough discussion of the
difference between dogecoin pool mining
and solo my name
in dogecoin pool mining you have to mine
as a part of it and pay fees
in dogecoin solo mining you don't need
to pay any fees and your mine all by
yourself
also in pole mining you will only get a
part of the reward earned by the pool
one but in solo mining the total reward
earned will be received by you only
as in pole mining many people work
together so the mine blocks more often
and on the other side solo mining could
take a lot of time before one mine their
first block
in pool mining it takes less time to
confirm a transaction as you work as a
part of the pool community on the other
hand in solo mining it can take much
longer to confirm a transaction as you
do all the work and there is a lot of
competition
so this was all about dogecoin pool
mining and solo mining
let's proceed further and see what we
need to start mining dogecoin
but before we start mining we will have
to make sure that we have these things
with us a pc with any operating system
like windows linux ubuntu etc
a good internet connection
and a digital wallet to store the dodge
coins you might
which hardware and software can be used
for dogecoin mining
you will need your pc cpu which should
be powerful enough to mine dogecoin a
gpu or graphics card can also be used
for mining dogecoin for example sapphire
pulse radeon rx 580 asus rx vega 64 and
many more
stripped asic miner is programmed to
mine script based cryptocurrencies like
dogecoin
like bit main antminer l3 bwl 21 strip
miner etc
if you are new to deutsche point mining
then using your pc cpu will be the right
choice and cpu miner is the most
appropriate software
if you are thinking of mining using gpu
or graphics card you can have a wide
range of software
some of the best software is buddha
miner which works perfectly with
nvidia products cgminer which works with
most gpu hardware and easy miner is
considered suitable for beginners
script asic miners are considered to be
very powerful hardware and multi-miner
is excellent with this hardware moving
ahead let's understand what does coin
cloud mining is
doing cloud mining is a mechanism to
mine dogecoin using rented data centers
without installing any hardware and
related softwares
it allows people to take an interest and
participate in deutsche point mining at
a very low cost making dogecoin mining
accessible for a broader range of people
worldwide
since the dogecoin mining process uses
the cloud it reduces equipment
maintenance or direct energy cost
this whole concept of dogecoin mining
brings me in front of one question
is dotecoin mining profitable
dogecoin mining profitability can be
analyzed based on power consumption hash
rate and cost
the dogecoin mining calculator is used
to make it simple in this calculator
the default value for the latest
dogecoin mining hash rate and latest
dogecoin difficulty target is pre-loaded
for better results
dogecoin mining's reward is
44 lakh 44
412.25 dollars per year that is
14 million doge per year
the block time for dogecoin is one
minute which means the supply of
dogecoin will never go down
after deducting mining power cores and
mining fees the final daily dose coin
mining profit is
22.53 dollars torch coin to usd with a
profit margin of
positive
81.72 percent
also i think dogecoin mining is fun
so that is all about dogecoin mining
we covered what dogecoin is
its value today and understood dogecoin
mining and its concepts in the previous
two videos now let's proceed further and
look at how to create a dodgeball wallet
and how to use it let's get started what
is torch point
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that works on a
blockchain technology
also it provides its users a completely
unknown decentralized and secure
environment free from any third-party
interference to make their transactions
dogecoin uses cryptography to secure all
its transactions now let's proceed
further and have a look at the process
of how to buy dogecoin
you can buy dogecoin by following these
steps step 1 create a dotecoin wallet
step 2 locate your specific dogecoin
address which is a long area of
characters that starts from capital d
followed by any other capital character
or any number
and step 3 find a source that sells doj
dogecoin
and voila buy dodge coins so that brings
us to what is dogecoin wallet
a dogecoin wallet is something where you
can stop store receive or send dogecoins
technically it is very similar to a real
live wallet
dogecoin wallet consists of its public
and private key connecting it to the
distributed ledger over the dogecoin
network
you can use your wallet's public key
which also functions as your coin
address for your bank account number for
dogecoin where anyone can track the
transactions made by maintaining the
anonymity of the user
the private key of your wallet is used
to approve transactions in the ledger
your wallet's public key is used to
receive dodge coins from other users on
the other hand your wallet's private key
is only used to send torch points to
other users in the network so what are
the types of dojo involved
torch coin wallet is of two types
digital dodge coin wallet
and physical dodge point wallet
digital doj coin wallet is accessible
through the web and you can also
download it according to your handset or
operating system
on the other hand physical dogecoin
wallets are pretty expensive and less
accessible so moving on let's see how to
create a dogecoin wallet
to create a dogecoin wallet for yourself
you will have to go through the
following steps
step 1 choose the correct wallet dot
coin core wallet and multi-touch wallet
have been created and are maintained by
the developers team of dogecoin
here we will be using the dojo core
wallet as reference
step 2 download and install the dogecoin
wallet in your handset
you can also use the official website of
this wallet for your windows
and step 3 open the dogecoin wallet
application and verify your dogecoin
wallet address
and that is it it is this easy to create
and have your deutsche coin wallet now
when you have your dough coin wallet in
your hand let's see how you can use it
on the very bottom of the home page of
your wallet there are two options
request coins where you can request
those coins from other users in the dojo
network
and send coins where you can send dodge
points to other users in the dogecoin
network
to receive coins
first click on the request coins button
second enter the required number of
coins you want to request
and third
have the below generated barcode scanned
by the user you wish to request amount
now to send coins
first type the dogecoin wallet address
to whom you want to send dogecoins
enter the required amount you wish to
send to that user
and third click on send
and there you go now you can use your
dogecoin wallet whenever and wherever
you want this makes me wonder why is
dogecoin so popular
despite being in tough competition with
other strong cryptocurrencies like
bitcoin dogecoin has never missed an
opportunity to be in the limelight
dogecoin's popularity is mainly
attributed to its vast and dedicated
community other than that social
platforms like reddit and twitter also
promoted dogecoin to a great extent due
to its fun factor and the whole joke
story behind it
celebrities like snoop dogg kevin jonas
elon musk also started taking an
interest in deutsche point and posting
pictures and comments on their social
media handles which increased the craze
of dogecoin all around the world so this
was all about dogecoin wallet now let's
have a look at the top 5 dogecoin
wallets of 2021 these are the top 5
dogecoin wallets of 2021
ledger nano x trees model t
kepke binance and kraken
kraken is primarily a cryptocurrency
exchange platform but can perfectly act
as a dogecoin wallet
all you need to do is to register and
then buy some dogecoins
it is a very secure and reliable
cryptocurrency exchange platform it
charges a very low fees for every
transaction taking place on it
and it accepts a pretty decent amount of
fiat money what comes to your mind first
when you hear the word dogecoin
i'm pretty sure either it's a meme or
elon musk
well whatever we think of this
cryptocurrency we can't deny the fact
that dogecoin started as a joke not
turned into the crypto star of the
future
everyone one or the other way knows
about dogecoin
but do you know what makes it so unique
and popular in this video i will take
you through some amazing top 10 facts
about dogecoin
so let's get started
number one
dogecoin has several safety levels
security levels are partially based on
the number of nodes of cryptocurrency
dogecoin has 1090 nodes which makes it
irresistible to hacking plus sometimes
the traffic increases in the dogecoin
network making it more vulnerable to its
security
number two huge and interactive
community of followers
among all of the cryptocurrencies those
going today has the biggest community of
followers they genuinely believe that
dogecoin will rule the future and this
unity proved to be an advantage for
dogecoin
for instance once china banned all the
payment companies dealing with bitcoin
which led to the increase of dojo and
reddit users up to 19 000 in just two
weeks thus the price of dogecoin
escalated to 300 percent
those coins followed provide full
support
to dogecoin and atkin unity to try every
bit to make it more popular and grow
once they raised a fund of 55 000
dollars for a nascar driver john weiss
who in return covered his entire car
with dogecoin and reddit alien images
such a beautiful family
number three
dogecoin is the easiest to buy
the platform for cryptocurrency exchange
provides the most convenient ways to buy
dogecoin
all you need is to create a digital
wallet which can be done on any
cryptocurrency exchange platform's
official website
and choose a reliable exchanger like
kraken or coinbase
and you will also need some bitcoins to
exchange it with doge
that's it it is this simple to trade
dogecoin now you can get rolling with
bang dogecoin
number 4
dogecoin wallet inspired by lucky coin
dogecoin was based on lucky coin as both
of them used the script language
to make dogecoin more ridiculous palmer
and marcus added a weird feature to the
dogecoin wallet
stating that its miner could receive
either zero
or potentially thousands of free coins
to produce new blocks inspired by one of
the quirky features of lucky coin
after a while they changed the block
reward to a fixed number of 10 000 to
make it more feasible
well i think dogecoin needs to be a
little different from these
cryptocurrencies as it holds a different
history of origin and growth
to maintain the faith of its community
it needs to upgrade itself a bit
number five largest circulating supply
of the coin
dogecoin in the crypto market holds the
position of the largest circulating
supply of coins since both the founders
of dogecoin wanted it to be a ridiculous
joe they thought of generating as many
dogecoin unit as possible
therefore they ended up making a
circulating supply of 127 million
dogecoin which is relatedly higher than
the volume of other cryptocurrencies
like bitcoin or ethereum till today
almost 113 billion dot coins are already
mine
every day
10 000 new dogecoins are released in
block rewards
every minute roughly 14.4 million new
dogecoins entering into the circulation
every day therefore 5.2 billion
dogecoins per year
dogecoin mining process is one of the
fastest
at least
98.9815 dogecoin can be mined every day
deutschland uses script encryption which
cannot be harvested using asics making
it easier and faster to mine other than
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
also the block rate is one block per
minute this provides an excellent
opportunity for miners to mine more
blocks and earn as many block rewards as
possible and miner can make make at
least 10 000 dogecoins as a block reward
number seven market capitalization over
435 million dollar
when dogecoin was first introduced to
the crypto world it was supposed to be
taken as a joke
but the people very well received it
this led its more value than 435 million
by 2017.
i don't know about others but this value
of money is a lot
imagine if you had invested 1 000 on
torch coin in january 2017 and then sold
it all after a month do you know how
much money you would have earned
almost twenty two thousand dollars
today the market cap worth of dogecoin
is 70 billion dollars
making it the fourth most valued coin
number eight
huge fan following in the entertainment
world
dogecoin seems to have gained a lot of
popularity among celebrities like snoop
dogg
kevin jonas gene simmons and elon musk
recently kevin jonas the eldest jonas
brother posted saying all i was saying
doge
showing his interest in dogecoin gene
simmons from the classic rock band kiss
also made a massive revelation that he
owns six figures worth of dogecoin well
some have been posting funny pictures or
comments to promote this crypto over
social media and some have been trying
to change the perception of people for
dogecoin
number nine
widely represented on social media
dogecoin has been widely represented on
social media since its origin platforms
like reddit and twitter adopted dogecoin
in its initial days and started
promoting it by tipping dogecoin to
their content creators which turned out
to be a massive success for dogecoin
dogecoin began to catch the attention of
every user on these platforms
i feel twitter has been a slam book for
torch coin as every day one or the other
person tweets about dogecoin there
later other platforms like tick tock
also started developing their interest
in dogecoin in summer 2020 tick tock
introduced a dogecoin challenge to
encourage people to invest in dogecoin
number 10 elon musk the flag bearer of
dogecoin
when deutsche is mentioned how can we
not talk about tesla ceo elon musk
but the question is what makes him love
dogecoin so much
recently one of his followers tweeted
and asked him why do you love dote so
much
he reacted that he loves dogs and loves
memes
he has been so active with dogecoin by
constantly tweeting about it
his first tweet was torched to the moon
which grabbed the attention of both the
followers of elon and followers of
dogecoin this led to the overnight
increase in the price and popularity of
dogecoin later he posted a still from
lion king movie which with his face in
place of rafiki holding simba with the
face of dogecoin stating that he will
always have dogecoins back
his most recent tweet was on wednesday
may 5 2021 the dogecoin father snl may 8
which is a reference to both his
constant tweets on dogecoin as well as
his appearance on saturday night live on
may 8 2020. in the previous few videos
we learned about what dogecoin is and we
also had a comparison between ethereum
and bitcoin in which we talked about
their features and concepts behind the
mechanism but in this video we will
compare and contrast dogecoin bitcoin
and ethereum based on a few related
concepts around these cryptocurrencies
it will help us understand the
functioning of these top
cryptocurrencies and will also let us
figure out the individuality of each one
of them
dogecoin was intended to be an altcoin
and a beam coin inspired by shiba inu's
popular meme aka doj
but it was very well received by
everyone in the crypto world and today
it is the fourth top cryptocurrency
dogecoin is a peer-to-peer open source
cryptocurrency that provides its users
with a completely unknown decentralized
and secure environment to make their
transactions
bitcoin led the first revolution of
digital money in 2013.
bitcoin enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
bitcoin is designed to be an alternative
to national currencies and intends only
to be a medium of exchange and value
storage
it comprises of features like a public
ledger immutability and high
transparency making it a great platform
ethereum came into the picture years
after bitcoin ethereum offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
ethereum serves as a computing platform
that enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized applications
using smart contracts through its
currency ether or eth
the primary function of ether is to help
developers build smart contracts using
dapps or decentralized application
now let's move on the comparison between
dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum
we will be comparing them based on few
major parameters like algorithm
programming language
mining process
monetary
policies transactions
today's value
and availability
so let's move ahead and start with the
very first comparison the algorithm
dogecoin uses stripped cryptography for
mining the blocks of the dogecoin
network
in comparison bitcoin uses the sha-256
hashing algorithm for mining its blocks
in the blockchain network
ethereum on the other hand uses this e
dash algorithm for mining its
transactions
strip language is a password-based key
derivation function that is mainly used
to avoid customized hardware attacks by
raising the resource demands of the
algorithm
she 256 algorithm helps bitcoin users
protect all their sensitive data like
private keys or transaction details and
help maintain the anonymity of the user
for a much secure performance of
transactions
e-algorithm is mainly used during the
proof-of-work function proof-of-work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy specific network requirements
moving on the following comparison
programming language
dogecoin is considered to be an altcoin
for bitcoin
use the same programming language
c plus it is a stack based programming
language used to give bitcoin and
dogecoin software instructions on how to
make transactions
on the other side ethereum uses solidity
which is a high level programming
language used by ethereum for
implementing smart contracts
now that we have covered programming
language and the algorithm of this
cryptocurrency let's get to the
following very important parameter which
is mining process
but before getting started with the
comparison first let's understand what
mining is
mining is a process in which
transactions are validated and added to
the blockchain public ledger in blocks
and the people mining these blocks are
called miners
in terms of the mining process also
dogecoin and bitcoin use the same method
to verify and validate the pending
transaction in the networks and that is
proof of work
although ethereum miners also mine the
unvalidated transactions using the proof
of work method it aims to switch to
proof of stake
because it will make its network more
immune to centralization energy
efficient and more vital support for
shared chains
now we have come to the following person
which is monetary policy
policy is known as the process of
drafting announcing and implementing the
plan of actions taken by the competent
monetary authority to control the money
supply and achieve goals that promote
sustainable economic growth
dogecoin's policy is defined by its
block reward paid to its miners
whereas
bitcoin policy is defined by two
processes having and block reward
having event is when reward of mining
bitcoin is cut in half
and it also cuts the inflation rate
and the block reward is the number of
bitcoins you get if you successfully
mine a blockchain block
an ethereum's policy is defined as
minimum issuance to secure the network
that is there is a constant trade-off
between the transaction speed and
security
dogecoin's block reward is 10 000 for
mining one block
bitcoin's block reward is 12.5 for
mining each block and which is said to
get reduced to 6.25 by 2024.
an ethereum's block reward is two ether
per block
dogecoin takes one minute to generate
one block
bitcoin takes 10 minutes to generate one
block
an ethereum generates one block every 14
seconds
well monetary policies are considered to
be fixed and non-inflationary
due to this over time mining blocks will
become more complex
now moving on to the following
comparison which is transactions
dogecoin is the fastest
and can complete 70 transaction in one
second
and takes just two to three minutes to
confirm a transaction
bitcoin can complete up to five
transaction in one second and takes 10
minutes or more than that to confirm one
transaction
an ethereum can complete 30 transactions
per second and it takes just a few
minutes to confirm it
dogecoin is majorly used for tipping
content creators on social platforms
like reddit and twitter
bitcoin is only used as a superior
alternative for fiat money and is used
primarily for real-world transactions
on the other hand ether the currency of
ethereum acts as the fuel for ethereum
networks
now that we have covered all about
transaction process of these
cryptocurrency
let's have a look at the value of
dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum in today's
date
the value of dogecoin on today's date is
0.2992
dollars
bitcoin being the highest is 34857.58
an ethereum holds a value of 2356.58
now we have reached the last comparison
of dogecoin bitcoin and ethereum which
is availability
the circulating supply of dogecoin is
127 billion
bitcoin very low as compared to dogecoin
is just
21 million in circulation
ethereum on the other hand is said to be
unlimited but till today the circulation
supply of ethereum is 115.6 million
till today 113 billion dogecoin has
already been mined
for bitcoin 18 million bitcoins are
already mined
and for ethereum roughly 36 million
ethereum has already been mined
in this draft you can see the red box on
the right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that
you can use according to your
requirements like if you want to know
about dogecoin you can go for the first
option that is www www.dogecoin.com
which will lead you to the official
website of dogecoin if you want to chat
with the executives of coin market
regarding dogecoin then you can go for
the fourth option which is chat
before that is an address for binance
address
through which you can keep a track of
dogecoin's value on that platform and
you can also change it according to your
choice by clicking on more
right beside the more option you can see
the
market cap value of dogecoin which is 38
billion
3849 million
469 00098
it is the total value of dogecoin and
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
which is 38 700
795
906.
it is the capitalization when max supply
of dogecoin was in circulation and on
the right side just before total supply
you can see the volume of dogecoin 1
billion
779 million four hundred seventeen
thousand six hundred forty seven
it is the value of dogecoin traded in 24
hours next is bitcoin similar to
dogecoin you can see the red box on the
right side of the graph shows the
maximum supply of dogecoin
on the extreme left you can see first
the options that you can use according
to your requirement
like if you want to know more about
bitcoin you can go for the first option
that is www.bitcoin.org
which will lead you to the official
website of bitcoin
right beside the more option you can see
the market cap value of bitcoin which is
651 billion seven hundred thirteen
million ten thousand
seven hundred fifty three
it is the total value of bitcoin in
circulation
beside the market cap option you can see
fully diluted market capitalization
that is 732 billion
387 million 262
690
and on the right side just before the
total supply you can see the volume of
bitcoin
that is thirty billion two hundred forty
nine million nine hundred thirty nine
thousand eight hundred sixty five
ethereum is no different from dogecoin
and bitcoin in this also you can see the
total supply of ethereum
also you can visit the official website
of
www.ethereum.org to explore more about
ethereum
you can have a look at the market cap
value of ethereum which is 273 billion
seven hundred fifty five million five
hundred eighty six thousand five hundred
thirty four
the fully diluted market capitalization
is
273 billion five hundred seventy six
million nine hundred eighty seven
thousand forty nine
the volume of ethereum traded in 24
hours is twenty four billion one hundred
one billion seven hundred seventy nine
thousand three hundred forty six but in
the end
all these top cryptocurrencies dogecoin
bitcoin and ethereum share a few
similarities
like they all are decentralized
all three cryptocurrencies are free from
any third-party interference or any
centralized authority
and can be used to have secure and
independent peer-to-peer transaction
maintaining the anonymity of the user
and proof of work that is all their
transactions are verified and validated
before processing after complete
verification further transaction process
takes place
also all of them have a large network of
independent nodes
meet susan an aspiring painter
she wishes to conduct an online painting
exhibition for all her digital artworks
however as the exhibition is online she
is worried that her paintings won't be
secure as anyone could easily forge or
replicate them
her friend mark came to her rescue with
an idea of nfp
he suggested that susan could buy nfts
for all her paintings as nfts are
trustworthy easily transferable and will
also maintain her ownership rights on
her artworks
susan had no idea what nfts were so mark
stepped ahead and explained it to her
nfts turn your digital assets into one
of a kind by creating a unique digital
signature which defines the ownership of
your assets and that can be bought and
sold for real money cryptocurrency or
any other asset like a non-fungible
token aka nft
non-fungible tokens means that they are
not interchangeable and each of them
represents unique assets owned by a
specific person
on the other hand fungible tokens are
interchangeable and can be divided into
smaller units to form the same value
for example a one hundred dollar bill is
fungible as you can exchange it with
five twenty dollar bills or two fifty
dollar bills
but the painting of the last supper is
non-fungible as it cannot be generated
in bulk even if it is copied it will not
be authentic
each nft contains distinguishable
information like who owns the digital
asset and who sold it making them
distinct and easily verifiable as it is
impossible to forge such a certificate
it will secure her painting's
originality
after learning what nft is susan was
curious to know how exactly nft works
nft basically creates a blockchain based
digital certificate for your digital
collectibles including games music art
and many more
this certificate gives your artwork a
unique identity the underlying
technology and the programming language
used by nfts are the same as other
cryptocurrencies such as blockchain and
the programming language ethash or
script
nft majorly exists on ethereum
blockchain a distributed public ledger
that records all the transactions
however nft is quite different from
these cryptocurrencies bitcoin and
ethereum are fungible tokens which means
if you trade bitcoin or ethereum for one
another you will have the same value or
item in return basically money
on the other hand nft is a unique token
therefore if you try to trade it you may
end up with something completely
different in your hands
crypto punks is a remarkable example of
nft it enables you to buy sell and store
10 000 collectibles with the proof of
ownership being stored on the ethereum
blockchain
after exploring helen ft's work susan
was convinced and bought nfts for all
her paintings due to this her artworks
were secured from any kind of forgery
and also gave her artworks a particular
value this contributed to increased
sales too as everyone was easily able to
buy the artwork without any fear
all in all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others like
jack dorsey the ceo and co-founder of
twitter with his very first and famous
tweet just setting up my twitter and
vignesh sundarsen famously known as
medicovan who bought 69.3 million
dollars worth of nft art on people
owing to its increasing popularity
people are now willing to pay hundreds
of thousands of dollars for nfps
nft has enhanced media exposure and
special perks for aspiring artists like
susan on social media
this popularity of nft creates new
opportunities for new art platforms
motivating people to buy art from
internet platforms and promoting
copyright or originality of digital
assets
so here is a question for you what makes
any item non-fungible
a exchangeability b unique digital
signature
c trade ability
d distributed public ledger
please give it a thought and drop your
answers in the comments section below
many experts in the crypto industry say
that around 40 of new crypto users will
use nfts as their entry point as a
result of its growing popularity nft
could represent a more significant part
of the digital economy in the future
in this video we will explore about
shiva innocoin and we'll go through some
of really exciting concepts and
components revolving around it
so how did this shiva unicorn originate
the shiva inu coin was created in august
2020 by an anonymous person calling
themselves ryoshi an indian
it was intended as an altcoin of
dogecoin which itself was created as an
altcoin of bitcoin
and this meme coin has been named after
the japanese dog breed shiva inu
it feels like the sheba in a coin was
built into existence and is now insanely
popular among major crypto exchanges
through the power of its following crowd
memes and a very cute dog
now we know how it originated so let's
have a look at what is sheba in a coin
shiva inucoin is a decentralized
community building cryptocurrency or we
can say an experiment developed within
the shiba inu ecosystem and built on top
of the ethereum blockchain network like
many other coins
it is a meme coin launched as a rival of
dogecoin a doge killer
both dogecoin and sheepcoin were made in
a humorous manner but sheepcoin has
already taken over some dogecoin markets
attracting a lot of attention and rising
as a popular choice among investors
especially after such market crash of
cryptos like bitcoin and ethereum
but what is the difference between sheba
and a coin and dogecoin
although both shiva inucoin and dogecoin
are main coins and share the same tree
of origin both of them differ a lot from
each other at the same time
and the very first difference between
them is the sheep coin is a token and
dogecoin is a currency
let's have a look at more of those major
differences like this
first is development
shiba inu coins or sheep coins are built
on and powered by the ethereum network
while dogecoin has been developed using
the same technology as bitcoin
then is use cases
shapecoin is still working upon price
more due to its high popularity than
utility
but on the other hand dogecoin has
already established itself to some
extent as a medium of online payments
there is value according to my coin
market cap
the current value of sheepcoin is
0.00007378
and that of dogecoin is zero point two
six one seven one one dollars
and at last availability the
availability of sheep cointel today is
394 million and for dogecoin it is 130
billion
now this definitely raises a question in
my mind
why is she buying a coin so popular
shiba inu coin is majorly popular
because of two reasons
tesla founder elon musk has tweeted
recently expressing that he would like
to own a shiba pub that hyped the crypto
market and its prices rose by 300
percent
on the other hand its prices fell by
around 40 percent after the founder of
ethereum blockchain network metallic
butadiene donated 50 trillion shebang
coins to indian government
for corporate relief fund of an indian
crypto entrepreneur
sandeep naival
so now that we know about sheba in a
coin and its concepts let's have a look
at what is the future of shiba inu coins
though sheba coin is only known as a
meme coin its increasing popularity and
people's interest and participating in
it is pointing towards a different but
bright future
according to investing investingcube.com
the sheba coin is predicted to rise
again
although there isn't much movement among
these token and its value active buyers
could help its value rise
the value could rise to zero point zero
zero zero zero one zero four zero in a
more active buyers market
although it may not appear to be a
significant amount due to its popularity
in future it can have a significant
influence over large investors of the
crypto market
in this video we will explore some of
the interesting and important aspects of
solana crypto
first we will understand what is celana
then we will look into what is a soul
token
or sol token
then we will explore when and how did it
originated
after which we will look into some of
the features of solana
then we will explore what type of
consensus method does solana use
after which we will understand how
solana works
then we will explore the current price
and volume of solana in today's date
after that we will look into the future
of celana holds for itself
and at last we will look into real-life
uses of salaana
so without doing much ado let's start
the video
let's explore what is solana
solana is a cryptocurrency
that is used to pay for transactions or
a decentralized computing network
solana attempts to increase blockchain
scalability by combining proof of stake
and proof of history consensus as a
result solana promises to be capable of
processing 50 000 transactions per
second while maintaining
decentralization now the question arises
what is the sl token or soul token
sonata's ecosystem uses the sl token as
its native currency as a result the
token can be transferred between nodes
in the solana cluster in exchange for
running on-chain programs or certifying
the results
it can also be used to make
micropayments known as lamp ports
now when we are talking so much about
solana crypto let's also dive down and
explore how and when exactly it came
into existence
anatoly yakovenko established the solana
platform in 2017.
before launching solana jakovenko worked
at balcom after working as a software
engineer at dropbox
he has a wide spectrum of knowledge
with compression methods
he developed a new method of dealing
with typical throughput difficulties in
the bitcoin and ethereum blockchain
with the help of eric williams and
solana's cto greg fitzgerald
they intended to develop a trustless
distributed protocol with increased
scalability
the team now has experience from leading
companies around the world including
apple google microsoft intel twitter
dropbox and others
now that we know what solana is and all
about its background let me ask you a
question recently solana joined hands
with two foundations to raise a fund of
five million dollars to encourage the
next wave of creators and fans onto
crypto networks so comment down your
answers in the comment section below
to know the correct answer to this
question watch this video till the end
moving on let's talk about its features
which makes it unique and popular
scalable solana uses proof of history
and a number of other groundbreaking
features to allow the network to scale
at the rate of moore's law
low cost for applications with billions
of users solana is designed to keep fees
low
so you will never have to worry about
rising fees as your user base grows
composable the single global state of
solana guarantees project composability
multiple shards and layer 2 systems
should never be dealt with
so we have heard a lot of references to
proof of history but what exactly is it
that we will discuss within the type of
consensus method solana uses
the solana network which has 200
physically different nodes
can handle a throughput of more than 50
000 tps
when using gpus is one of the most
performing permissionless blockchain
unlike bitcoin which employs the proof
of work algorithm as the system
decentralized clock solana uses the
proof of history technique
you can use proof of history to
construct historical records that verify
an event occurred at a given point in
time
this algorithm is a verifiable delay
function with a high frequency
this function requires a specific number
of sequential steps to evaluate
each transaction or even that is
examined will be assigned a unique hash
an account that can be verified publicly
and effectively
the count serves as a cryptographic
timestamp
allowing us to determine when each
transaction or event occurred
this provides increased throughput and
efficiency within the solana network
now that we know about its structure and
mechanism let's explore how salana works
now we know solana has built a
one-of-a-kind method for determining the
time of a transaction known as proof of
history
let's see the step-by-step procedure of
how it works
step 1 input the details of transactions
performed in the network to its leader
step 2
leader will now efficiently sequence and
organize the messages so that they can
be processed by another nodes
step 3 the leader then executes the
transactions based on the ram's current
state
4 the completed state's transactions and
signature will then be published by the
leader to the verifiers or replication
nodes
step 5 if the state receives
confirmation the verifiers will perform
the same transactions on their copies of
the state and publish their signatures
and at last step 6 the consensus process
will then use the published
confirmations as votes now that we know
everything about solana let's have a
look at the price and volume of solana
according to market capitalization
the solana network can process more than
50 000 transactions in one second
and the current price of it is thirty
dollars with a circulating volume of 270
million sql coins
which is quite impressive considering
its time span in market capitalization
as well as compared to other
cryptocurrencies
let's see what future the solana holds
for itself
filana although being a new project has
delivered on its promises of speed and
scalability its token price has also
done well
attack attracting investors attention
nonetheless the network acceptance and
usage are still in the early stages
we won't know whether solana speed make
a significant difference in the bitcoin
realm
until we witness substantial traffic and
more use cases
having a fast network is beneficial but
the advantages will only occur as more
people utilize it and more use cases
emerge
real-life uses of solana
serum radium bone pedal orca
oxygen and phantom wallet are some of
the recent projects that solana is
working with
well this is all about solana crypto
first we will explore what is binance
coin
following that we will understand how it
works
then we will dive down deeper and
explore a very interesting concept
followed by binance which is bnb burning
then we will look at the uses of the
binance coin
followed by its benefits
after that we will come across some
important factors to consider before
investing in the binance coin
and at the end
we will see the pricing dynamics of the
binance coin
the first thing that we are going to
explore is what is binance coin
so binance coin or bnb is a
cryptocurrency that may be used on the
binance cryptocurrency exchange to trade
and pay fees as of january 2018 the
binance exchange was the world's largest
cryptocurrency exchange conducting over
1.4 million transactions
every second
this coin is limited to
200 million bnb tokens and runs on the
ethereum blockchain using the standard
erc 20 protocol
as an incentive binance coin users
receive a reduction in transaction cost
on the finance exchange
other cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin
ethereum litecoin and others can be
exchanged or traded for bnb
now let's move on and see how it works
bnb is a crypto asset that fluctuates in
value as individuals use and trade it
similar to other digital assets on the
market
bnb can be stored in suitable wallets
obtained from crypt exchanges
and sent directly to others for payments
and other purposes
but there is a whole working initiative
behind this process
bedance layer 1 blockchain is merged to
form the bnb chain previously the
binance marked chain and the binance
chain
binance design the blockchain for best
performance when it comes to trading
on-chain when building the bnb chain and
binance d-e-x
it is also based on this newly developed
chain furthermore bnb chain transactions
are powered by the bnb gas token which
stands for build and build previously
also known as binance coin
now bnb beacon chain and bnb smart chain
make up the bnb chain the former is
concerned with bnb chain governance
which allows bnb holders to vote and
stake their coins then it's a consensus
layer that's compatible with the
ethereum virtual machine and has
multi-chain hubs
now moving on let's have a look at the
bnb burn concept
binance uses 20 percent of its profit
each quarter to buy back and burn
finance coins completely destroying them
finance has consistently performed
quarterly burns the most recent been on
october 17 2020 which was 13th quarterly
burn
binance will continue to burn bnb coins
every quarter until it has purchased and
destroyed 100 million binance coins or
half of the total supply
finance coins supply is reduced as a
result of the procedure and its rarity
is affected which could affect the
assets value
binance also has a program called the
bnb pioneer burn program which assists
cases when bnb holders have
unrecoverably lost bnb and compensate
them them by reducing the amount from
the next bnb burn
now let's have a look at some of the
uses of the binance coin
the binance coin like other developing
cryptocurrencies has a variety of
applications outside of the binance
exchange including
first is trading
binance coin can be exchanged for other
cryptocurrencies on a variety of
exchanges depending on the exchange's
regulations
next is transaction fees on the binance
exchange
users can use bnb to pay for
transactions on the binance exchange and
earn a hefty discount
next we have is credit card payments on
crypto.com bnb can be used to pay for
crypto credit card bills
next is payment processing merchants can
accept bnb as a form of payments giving
customers more options in terms of
payment methods
next we have is booking travel
arrangements on certain websites bnb can
be used to book hotels flights as well
next is entertainment
now bnb is used for a variety of
purposes in the entertainment industries
from paying for virtual kits to
purchasing lottery tickets as well
next in the line is investment
binance coin can be used to invest
in stocks etfs and other assets on a
variety of platforms
and at last is loans and transfers on
some platforms bnb can be used as a
collateral for loans there are also apps
that allow users to use binance coin to
split bills and pay friends and
relatives
so now that we have covered the basics
of the binance coin let's have a look at
some of its benefits that makes it
unique
starting with
quick transactions
when you trade on the exchange with bnb
you'll have access to the platform
property matching engine which can
handle up to 1.4 million orders per
second
finding the appropriate transaction is
always possible and using bnb makes it
even easier and more reliable
next is secure and trustworthy
binance already has millions of
cryptocurrency users and dealers who
rely on the platform and believe in the
security and protection aspects of this
exchange
to keep your funds safe the exchange
uses a multi-cluster and multi-tire
system framework as well as the secure
assets funds for users
next is trade multiple cryptocurrencies
you can trade more than 150
cryptocurrencies on the exchange with
bnb thanks to a rapid secure and low
cost transaction matching technology
aside from that bnb has its own trading
pair to fulfill your individual trading
needs there's no need to seek elsewhere
moving ahead is trading discount
you can also get a 50 discount on your
trading charge if you use bnb with
traditional payment methods if you buy
10 000
worth of coins you'll be charged
dollar and if you use bnb though the
trading charge is cut in half so you
will just have to spend five dollars
next is
spending binance coin you can utilize
bnb in a variety of ways in addition to
having a smooth experience
within the binance ecosystem and
receiving transaction fee discounts
several service providers particularly
in the travel and hotel industries
accept it using bnb you can purchase
dinner or a new phone as well
now let's have a look at some of the
factors that you should consider before
investing in binance coin
now binance coins can be used to invest
in some icos listed on binance launchpad
program the binance exchange will
publish new cryptocurrencies and the use
of binance coins will provide a seamless
marketplace for trading a range of
virtual tokens
binance will eventually become the
decentralized binance exchanges
principle currency
the visa debit card of monaco the
world's first payment and cryptocurrency
platform and the platform's mobile app
also support binance coin
now as we are talking about investments
let's have a look at the peak at bnb
pricing and dynamics
bnb's pricing has traditionally varied
in a similar way to the price of other
crypto assets traded on the market
finance coins market capitalization has
increased over time topic 70 billion
dollars bnb was also sold for around
0.10 per token during finances ico
today the current value of bnb is
286.67 with the market capitalization of
46 billion eight hundred one million two
hundred ten thousand eighty one dollars
bnb has seen a tremendous increase in
value since its ico reaching a high of
more than six hundred dollar per coins
at time is it wise to invest in binance
coin
well if perches join and sold at the
right times it's conceivable and its
past price growth resulted in profit
however only time can tell where the
price of bnb will go in the future
first we will understand what is ripple
followed by what is xrp
then we will see the working of ripple
then we will learn how to mine xrp after
that we will have a comparison between
bitcoin and ripple then we will explore
the pros and cons of ripple
after which we will see how you can
actually use ripple
followed by we will see how can we buy
ripple
and in the end we will see if it is a
good investment or not
so let's get started with the video
first let's understand what is ripple so
the firm behind x rp is ripple
which is a payment settlement systems
and currency network that can handle
transactions all across the world
basically it acts as a trusted
intermediary between two parties in a
transaction
as the network can be immediately
validated that the transaction was
completed successfully
ripple can ease the exchange of a wide
range
of fiat currencies and cryptocurrencies
including bitcoin
so when users utilize a network to make
a transaction the network takes a modest
charge in the form of xrp
and ripple was built from the ground up
to be a swift a leading money transfer
network successor or to otherwise
replace sentimental layer between large
financial institutions so this raises
the question of what is xr so let's have
a look at it the x rp ledger created by
jade mckayla arthur brito and david
schwartz is a blockchain that runs xrb
mckillib and brito would go on to form
ripple which would employ xrp to enable
network transactions
you can acquire xrp as an investment
crypto to trade from other
cryptocurrencies or as a way to fund
ripple network transactions
xrp's blockchain in particular drift
from that of most other cryptocurrencies
other cryptocurrencies give anyone who
can solve difficult equations quickly
access to their transaction ledgers and
verification processes
ripple transactions on the other hand
are safe since the majority of ledger
holders must agree to the verification
before they can be added also the ripple
network which employs xrp
is somewhat centralized and uses a
consensus protocol this means
while anyone can download its validation
software it has its own node list that
consumers can use to validate
transactions based on which participants
they believe are least likely to cheat
them
so now that we know the basics of ripple
and xrp let's have a look at working of
ripple to verify transactions the xrp
cryptocurrency employs a consensus
protocol validators verify that proposed
transactions are valid by comparing them
to the most recent version of the xrp
ledger now a tran transaction must be
accepted by the majority of validators
in order to be verified
once it's verified the transaction is
then added to the blockchain so now that
we know it's working let's have a look
at how ripple can be mined by its users
ripples or excel is created using a
crypto ledger that is akin to blockchain
technology and is federated by financial
institutions and payment processor
networks
while it is true that ripple xrp cannot
be mined by miners it is technically
viable to do it using other
cryptocurrencies
so one of the most viable techniques for
mining xrp is to mine other
cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin and
ethereum and then transfer the mine
crypto for ripple through exchanges
and that's how the mining is done
so as we have discussed all the basics
of ripple let's dive down deeper and
have a look at how it differs from
bitcoin
to verify transactions and distribute
new currencies bitcoin employees mining
participants set up mining devices to
solve complex mathematical equations
with the first person to solve the
equation winning the right to add a
block of transaction to bitcoin's
network
then participants receive bitcoin
rewards for each block they add in the
exchange for bitcoin mining whereas the
consensus protocol used by xr plane
confirms transactions for a transaction
to be accepted it must receive the
approval of a majority of validators who
actually review it then bitcoin
transaction confirms can take several
minutes and are associated with
significant transaction charges
due to the intricate
and expensive nature of mining utilized
in the cryptocurrency but on the other
hand xrp transactions are instantly
confirmed and have really cheap
transaction fees
the user is charged a small amount of
xrp each time a transaction is completed
on the ripple network
now the supply of bitcoin is limited to
21 million which means there will be
never more than 21 million bitcoin the
artificial scarcity of 12 bitcoin has
sparked investor interest in the
currency's potential as a safe haven but
in contrast at the time of introduction
one billion xrp was free mined and
progressively distributed onto the
market by the company's major investors
next we have when miners discover
bitcoins they are released and added to
the network they have no set release
date and their supplies is largely
determined by network speeds and the
difficulty of the algorithm
used to create coins on the other hand
the release of xrp is controlled by a
smart contract
according to an inbuilt smart contract
ripple is expected to distribute a
maximum of 1 billion xrp tokens per
month
so the current circulation is 55 billion
till now
so this was all about the difference
between bitcoin and ripple
and i'm pretty sure that till now you
have understood all the basic knowledge
about ripple so let's move ahead and
look into some of the pros and cons
of ripple
though xrp transactions are quick and
inexpensive ripple's consensus protocol
is perhaps less secure than other crypto
transaction processing technologies
next is
even though financial organizations are
already using ripple's payment network
ripple's financial partners primarily
use triple net rather than xrp
cryptocurrency
next we have is small company owners and
individuals who can utilize xrp to make
safe money transactions
yet because it is administered by a
private corporation and because of the
sec litigation ripple has sparked the
debate
and for foreign currency transfers xrp
can be utilized as a bridge currency but
in the united states buying serpi is
quite challenging so now that we know
its pros and cons also let's have a look
how you can actually use ripple
xrp can be used in the same way as any
digital currency for transaction or as a
possible investment
other sorts of transactions such as
currency exchange potentially be
processed using the ripple network for
example instead of dealing with the
currency conversion directly through a
bank or money changing exchange
you may first exchange your us dollars
for xrp on the ripple network and then
use them to buy euros rather than paying
the hefty cost that banks and money
transmission businesses may demand this
can be a lot fast and less expensive
option
so now that we know everything about
ripple let's explore how can we actually
buy ripple
so all you need is sign up for an
account on an exchange that sells
ripples xrp cryptocurrency to buy it
then using any of the exchanges allowed
payment methods buy it here are a few
places where you can get xrp q coin
uphold and coinmama
now the question is
is ripple a good investment
so
xrp
is a risky investment that is not for
the faint of art
however if you feel ripple will succeed
as a payment system it may be worthwhile
to invest in xrp so just be sure you're
not gambling with money you can't afford
to lose
well this was all about what is ripple
recently you all must have noticed that
the crypto market has caused quite a
buzz in social media and other online
forums and perhaps even in your dinner
time conversations
but what is all this commotion about
this is about the recent downfall of
cryptocurrencies in the crypto market
in this video we will let you through
some very important aspects of this
phenomenon of cryptocurrency
first of all we will understand what
cryptocurrency and crypto market are
after that we will understand how the
market works
then we will look into the reasons for
the market crash of cryptocurrency
and how it has affected people at all
levels
then we will figure out the factors that
can help the market to grow again
and at last we will look into the future
of cryptocurrency and trip to market
so let's start with the very first
aspect that is what cryptocurrency and
crypto market are
a cryptocurrency is a kind of virtual or
digital currency that works on
blockchain technology a public ledger
enforced by a distributed network of
computers
it works as a medium of exchange online
to buy goods and services and make
payments
like for example bitcoin ethereum
dogecoin these are some of the popular
cryptocurrency
cryptocurrency is decentralized and free
from any third-party interference
which means it is not issued or
controlled by any government or central
authority the crypto in cryptocurrency
stands for cryptography which uses
encryption and decryption to secure the
data
crypto market is where you can trade
cryptocurrency cryptocurrency trading is
an act of speculating the price movement
of cryptocurrency without taking
ownership of the underlying coins
through a trading account or by buying
and selling the underlying coins through
an exchange
you can buy cryptocurrency if you think
it will rise in value or sell them if
you think it will fall
now let's understand how it works
the price of crypto currency is quoted
in traditional currencies such as the us
dollar and you never take ownership of
the cryptocurrency itself
one can buy and sell at cryptocurrency
through their trading account or via
exchange which helps them speculate on
whether the chosen cryptocurrency will
rise or fall in value
both buy and sell are leveraged products
which means you only need to put up a
small amount as a deposit known as
margin to gain total exposure to the
underlying market
your profit or loss is majorly
calculated based on the total size of
your position
so leverage can affect your profits as
well as your losses if the market moves
against you
so that makes me question what the
reasons behind the market crash of
cryptocurrency
are on 19th may 2021 the crypto market
saw a massive drop in prices or
cryptocurrencies including bitcoin
ethereum and bnp crashing up to 30
within a span of just 24 hours
this came in the backdrop of the chinese
regulators announcing a ban of
cryptocurrency
china has banned payment companies and
financial institutions from providing
any services such as registration
trading clearing and settlement related
to cryptocurrency transactions
this announcement made by china broke
the markets back
and then the panic increased because
tesla announced that they would not
favor bitcoin on environmental concerns
anymore therefore they will not accept
any payment made by bitcoin
and also there are rumors of irs
investigation into the largest crypto
exchange platform binance which also has
weakened investors resolution to invest
more in crypto market
now we know the reasons behind the
crypto market crash so let's take a look
at how it has affected people at all
levels
the crypto market means different things
to different people it is an object of
speculation that consumes almost all the
media coverage
about the space to many people
for them the day crypto market crashed
was a black day as they faced a
tremendous loss of the leverage invested
in cryptocurrencies
even the bloomberg galaxy crypto index
plunged 19.2 percent in its worst slide
in more than a year
and to others the crypto market is more
than a speculative instrument
for them this incident proved to be a
huge opportunity as they got a chance to
uncover problems of the system of the
crypto market like high fees to trade at
the most crucial moments and find
solution to these problems by adding
more capacity and efficiency to the
system
so now we have covered everything about
the market crash of cryptocurrency
let's dive into the factors that can
help the market to grow again
despite their dramatic downturns these
cryptocurrencies have consistently
recovered from their downtime people in
the crypto market systems have termed
this decline as a short-term correction
long-term investors like microstrategy
call this crash a buying opportunity of
these cryptocurrencies and
is investing more to stabilize them
many people believe that what we
witnessed in the last few days was the
liquidation of the leverage long
positions followed by a panic selloff
and is considered a very normal
phenomenon in thin markets like
cryptocurrency
they believe that this situation can be
thought down by extensive adoption of
cryptocurrency and constant
participation in the crypto market
well this whole scenario makes me
question what the future cryptocurrency
and crypto market holds
cryptocurrency is a highly speculative
and volatile investment and it may or
may not succeed over time
therefore there is no guarantee for
these cryptocurrencies that all will
always recover from this type of market
crashes
a few experts of the crypto market say
that investors should hold a long-term
view of the digital assets market
as they will bounce back swiftly
also small investors should be better
off staying away from the market as this
current volatility can be overwhelming
for them
and some experts suggest that holding on
to these cryptos will be a wise option
and small investors should buy these
cryptos slowly and steadily through a
systematic plan
therefore if you're thinking about
investing in cryptocurrency
be sure you know what you're getting
into although the crypto market is
lucrative
keep in mind that there's always a
chance that sometimes cryptocurrencies
are not able to bounce back let's have a
look at the top crypto trading platform
in 2022 but before diving right into the
list let's have a quick and crisp
understanding of what crypto trading
actually means
so
taking a financial on the price
direction of individual cryptocurrencies
against the dollar or against any other
cryptocurrency is what crypto trading is
all about
cfds or contract for difference are a
popular weight of trading
cryptocurrencies because they offer more
flexibility leverage and the ability to
trade both long and short positions
also it's essential to consider things
like supported assets fees
payment methods and security when
considering a cryptocurrency trading
platform
so we have also considered these factors
to give you a better idea of which
platform will be the best for you
so now that we have a basic idea what
crypto trading is let's dive into the
list of top crypto trading platforms for
2022.
the first platform in the list is
coinbase
for many first-time cryptocurrency
buyers coinbase has become the go to
exchange the platform has the appearance
and feel of an online banking tool which
the majority of consumers are already
familiar with
making the transfer to crypto investing
simple
coinbase is the finest cryptocurrency
exchange overall as well as the best
cryptocurrency exchange for beginners it
supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrencies and provide a high
level of security
it's also a wonderful alternative for
expert traders because it offers an
advanced trading platform coinbase pro
in addition to being a beginner-friendly
platform
so let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for coinbase
it supports more than 150 plus cryptos
for trading with the transaction fee
ranging between 0
to 0.60
also the minimum deposit of purchase
price should be at least two dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
coinbase offers large volume of
cryptocurrencies
what to trade for it provides more
experience to beginners as well as offer
easy trading to advance members of it it
also provides liquidity and ease on its
platform
now cons
the customer service provided by them is
not up to the mark as well as
coinbase.com is an institutional account
which means you don't have access to
your private keys
moving on next we have is crypto.com
crypto crypto.com offers a diverse
digital asset ecosystem that includes is
its own blockchain the crypto.org
a native token known as cro a crypto
visa card eel generating crypto products
and more it was chosen as the top mobile
crypto exchange application because it
offers a comprehensive digital asset
trading and investing environment that
you can access from your smartphone
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for crypto.com
it supports more than 250 plus cryptos
for trading with a transaction fee
ranging between 0.04
to 0.40
also the minimum deposit or purchase
price should be at least one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
crypto.com supports a huge range of
cryptocurrencies to trade for and other
crypto related services like payments
and asset avoid evaluation
now moving towards cons it fees is
relatively high also the customer
service is a little poor and stagnant
next in the list we have is gemini
gemini stands out as a sign that
prioritizes security and compliance hot
wallet insurance is provided by the new
york based exchange to ensure that user
funds are protected in the event of a
security comprise because it has
comprehensive security protocols ensures
customer cash and is soc 2 certified
gemini is the most secure crypto
exchange
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for gemini
it only supports 75 plus cryptos for
trading with the transaction fee ranging
between
0.99 percent to 2.99
also it has a minimum deposit
or purchase price and it varies
according to the asset invested
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
gemini is available in all 50 states of
united states with extremely liquid
market
all the funds stored in the wallets are
perfectly insured and secure also if ui
is pretty strong
coming to its cons
many traders in it have high cost also
as compared to other crypto trading
platforms it supports less
cryptocurrencies as well
now moving on to the next platform in
the list we have
binance
the most appealing feature of binance is
it's low cost when compared to other
exchanges beginners will appreciate the
simple buy sell option while
professional traders will appreciate the
in-depth basic and advanced trading
platforms now let's have a look at the
account prerequisites for binance it
supports more than 500 plus cryptos for
trading with a transaction fee ranging
between 0.10
to 0.50
also it has no minimum deposit or
purchase price of 50
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
binance purchase piece is non-immediate
as well as instant also a huge variety
of coins is available on its platform
along with this it offers various other
services
coming to the cons once the verification
of account was hampered it is not yet
available in united states and its
corporate structure is pretty opaque
next we have is
kraken
kraken is one of the world's most
well-known bitcoin exchanges in the
early days of the crypto market it
established itself as the go-to site for
professional investors it has retained
its image as a trustworthy and
professional trading venue
it has some of the lowest fees in the
cryptocurrency exchange world it's also
our top pick for experienced traders as
it allows leverage and futures
trading as well as enables complex order
types
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for kraken
basically it supports more than 120 plus
cryptos for trading with a small
transaction fee ranging between
0.00
to 0.26 percent
also it has minimum deposit or purchase
price of minimum one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
kraken supports a large range of
cryptocurrency with minimum fee and also
provide the traders more market
liquidity
coming to the cons not all states in
your skin accepted
as options for financing your account
are limited
next in the list we have bitstamp
bitstamp is one of the most
cost-effective bitcoin exchanges it
offers a simple pricing structure that
bases your trading fees on your 30-day
trading volume
for users with less than
10 000
on bitstamp the highest trading cost is
merely zero point five zero percent with
its pros and cons
in terms of trading fees bitstamp is one
of the top cryptocurrency exchanges
trade view a real-time trading platform
is also available this version contains
more extensive charting and trading
forms this platform offers a diverse
range of points including many of the
most popular as well as some lesser
known cryptos
and the cons are while bitstem offers a
good selection of cryptocurrencies there
are a significant ones that aren't
available
its bitstam make program which allows
you to stay crypto allows you to earn
passive money but there are a few
drawbacks as well in 2015 hackers were
successfully in launching a phys
phishing assault against bitstam workers
which resulted in a security breach
following bitstamp we have bitmap
bitmap is a global bitcoin exchange with
over 180 locations
users can purchase sell and store over 1
000 different digital currencies and
tokens
investors
wishing to add newly launched
or obscure crypto assets to the
portfolios while likely find what they
are searching for on this exchange as it
offers more assets and trading pairs
than its market leading counterparts
let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for bitmap
bitmap offers 1 000 plus cryptos for
trading with a very small transaction
fee that ranges between
0.045 percent to 0.25 percent
also coming to its minimum deposit or
purchase the price is 30
when purchasing wire bitmap
for spot trading the price is not
published yet
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
bitmap supports a huge variety of
cryptocurrency and provide great crypt
opportunities to earn cryptocurrency as
well
along with that it provides an easy
trade option for buying and selling
cryptocurrencies
now moving on to the cons
there was a large scale hack on this
platform in 2021 also the customer
reviews are average for this application
moving on next in our list is q coin
q coin is a third party cryptocurrency
exchange that lets you buy sell and
trade a variety of cryptocurrencies
the founder's goal was to provide a
simple and secure platform for people
all around the world
to exchange a variety of digital
currency cupoin has a large number of
cryptocurrencies to choose from and has
minimal cost when compared to other
cryptocurrency exchanges
staking leverage futures and
peer-to-peer trading are all supported
which may appeal to more experienced
users
now let's have a look at the account
prerequisites for q coin
so q coin offers only up to 28 cryptos
for trading with a very small
transaction fee ranging between 0.00 to
0.10
also coming to its minimal deposit or
purchase the price is merely five
dollars
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
q coin maintains the anonymity of the
user while trading yet it offers secured
platform as well also it supports
multiple cryptocurrencies
coming to the cons the trading volume of
cryptocurrencies are pretty low and also
during heavy traffic it can face some
serious issues
following q coin in our list we have
cash app
now individuals in the united states and
the united kingdom can use the cash app
to send spend deposit and invest money
it's an essentially a peer-to-peer
payment app with an investment component
through the cash app
users can also invest in stocks etfs and
bitcoin it enables you to purchase sell
and store bitcoin
from your smartphone itself in a more
simpler and safer manner
now
looking at its account prerequisites
like we discussed cash app is only a
bitcoin exchange application so it
supports only one cryptocurrency that is
bitcoin the transaction fee varies
depending on the action
also the minimum deposit of purchase is
just one dollar
now let's have a look at its pros and
cons
cash app provides an easy access ui and
quick withdrawal from its wallets
other than this it also supports bitcoin
lighting network it's a second layer
bitcoin technology that employs micro
payment channels to increase the
blockchain's ability to perform
transactions more quickly
moving on to the cons it only supports
bitcoin the wallet is always volunteered
and it has limits on everything bait
deposits sales and other items
so now we have reached a
last crypto trading platform in our list
which is
bishk
bish is a peer-to-peer cryptocurrency
trading platform that allows individuals
from all over the world to trade a
variety of digital currencies and tokens
customers are not required to complete a
know your customer or kyc identity
verification process and this trading
platform is not restricted to users in
specific jurisdictions it lets users to
buy and sell bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies with a variety of
payment options such as bank wire
transfers ach transfers and cash
deposits as well
now let's have a look at its
prerequisites
bish currently supports 100 plus
cryptocurrencies for transaction with
transaction price ranging between 0.10
to 0.70
and there is no minimal deposit or
purchase required
now moving on to its pros and cons
this bish application is available
throughout the world and anyone can use
it
it provides a high-end security and
doesn't requires any sort of kyc or id
verification
and it provides almost 50 payment
options for crypto transactions
moving on to the cons the speed of the
transactions are pretty low and low
trading
values are also possible as it doesn't
consist of any minimal deposit or
purchase
also it is not a great option for active
trading and with that we have come to
the end of this video on blockchain and
cryptocurrency full course for 2022 i
hope you found it useful and
entertaining please ask away any
questions you have concerning the topics
covered in this video in the comments
down below our experts will assist you
in addressing your problems thank you
for watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you